TODAY'S -- ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING ON
EDUCATION FINANCE TODAY'S TOPIC
IS OF COURSE EARLY EDUCATION.
SO I WERE THE LUCKY T<c.cyan> LITTLE</c>
HANDS.
GET OUT ONCE A YEAR SO TODAY'S
THE DAY -- MáS GONNA BE GOING
VISITING OUR GOVERNOR LATER ON
TALKING ABOUT EARLY EDUCATION SO
I THINK DOUBLY -- IMPORTANT THEY
BRING THE A LITTLE HANDS OUT
TODAY SO THIS IS A AN ISSUE THAT --
WE ALL EMBRACE THE ISSUE OF
EARLY EDUCATION WE KNOW IT IT IT
MAKES IT MEANS SO MUCH.
TO GIVE OUR YOUNGEST LEARNERS A
HEAD START IN SCHOOL AND LIFE
AND ABLE TO ADDRESS AS I ALWAYS
SAY THE ISSUES OF THE DAY
WHETHER IT'S THE EDUCATION
ACHIEVEMENT GAP --
INTERGENERATIONAL POVERTY.
IN ADDRESSING CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM EARLY EDUCATION IS A
PROVEN DIFFERENCE MAKER AND
WHERE I'M GONNA BE TALKING TODAY
A ABOUT A A RECORD INVESTMENT IN
THE JANUARY BUDGET FOR REALLY
EDUCATION OF PRIOR YEARS WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO GET THE MAY BUDGET
WITH -- SOMEWHAT CLOSE AS FAR AS
A DOLLAR AMOUNT BUT NEVER THIS
MUCH IN THE JANUARY BUDGET SO A
LOT OF PROPOSALS FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET THAT WE'RE
GONNA DISCUSS TO THEY RELATE TO
HER.
PRESCHOOL ITS EXPANSION FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN FACILITIES WORK
FORCE AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
IS A CERTAINLY A GREAT START I
COMMEND HIM FOR HIS FOCUS ON
EARLY EDUCATION -- THERE ARE OF
COURSE SENSE AND GAPS WE'RE
GONNA BE LOOKING AT AND SOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO BUILD
UPON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
BUDGET TO MAKE IT.
BETTER -- ONE OF THE MAIN THINGS
OF COURSE WE HEAR IS THE USE OF
ONE TIME MONEY WHEN SOME OF
THESE ISSUES WERE TRYING TO
FOCUS ON REQUIRE -- ONGOING
INVESTMENT SO WE WILL CERTAINLY
LOOK AT THAT FOCUSING ON US ON
HIS AS I MENTIONED HIS.
PROPOSALS RELATED FACILITIES AND
THE WORK FORCE AT THIS IS THAT A
GOOD TIMING TO DISCUSS THIS.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE ASSEMBLY
JUST CONCLUDING OUR WORK ON
EARLY EDUCATION A TWO YEAR
PROCESS.
WITH OUR ASSEMBLY BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY EDUCATION
THAT WAS SPEARHEADED BY OUR
SPEAKER WHICH WE JUST AYE
WRAPPED UP.
AND THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
ARE A DRAFT FORM RIGHT NOW
BECOMING PUBLIC AND NUMBER WEEKS
AND DOVETAIL NICELY -- WITH THE
PROPOSAL WE HAVE BEFORE US.
IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGETS AND WE
REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON A
COMPREHENSIVE PLAN GOING FORWARD
AS WELL AS MAKING INVESTMENTS IN
THIS YEAR.
SO WITH THAT WE'RE CERTAINLY --
LOOK FOR IT CERTAINLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
MINISTRATION OVER THE NEXT FEW
WEEKS. TO TO FINE TUNE -- THIS
PROPOSAL AND WITH THAT WE WILL
BEGIN -- THE HEARING AND WILL
FOCUS WITH ISSUE NUMBER ONE
FIRST THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN SO LET'S
BRING UP DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE LA -- AND THE OFFICE OF
PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION
.
OKAY PLEASE BE GET BERMAN A
FINANCE.
YOU -- KEITH IS ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND -- TO ADDRESS
FACILITIES NEEDS THAT ARE
DRASTIC -- PREVENTING SOME
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FROM I'M NOT
OFFERING -- ALL DAY KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS THIS BUILDS UPON -- ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET ACTED --
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ONE MAIN
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN -- THIS
PROPOSAL LAST YEAR'S IS THERE WE
ARE -- ALLOWING VISIT SAVINGS ON
FACILITIES PRICE TO BE USED FOR
A PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
INSTRUCTION MATERIALS THAT WOULD
HELP ADDRESS -- BUILT RAMP UP TO
PROVIDE THE THE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS AT THOSE --
SCHOOLS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
LA A GOOD MORNING THIS CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE IN THE LEAD WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
YOU SHOULD HAVE RECEIVED A
HANDOUT WHICH WILL BE
REFERENCING FOR THE FIRST THREE
AGENDA ITEMS THIS MORNING.
STARTING ON PAGE ONE WE OFFER
SOME BACKGROUND ON FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN AND KINDERGARTEN
FACILITY GRANTS.
AS BACKGROUND ON KINDERGARTEN AT
THE STATE REQUIRES DISTRICTS TO
PROVIDE KINDERGARTEN BUT LEAVE
IT TO THE DISTRICTS TO DETERMINE
THE LENGTH OF THESE PROGRAMS.
ARE DAY PROGRAMS OPERATE BETWEEN
THREE TO FOUR HOURS WHEREAS FULL
THE PROGRAMS OPERATE MORE THAN
FOUR HOURS.
AS YOU MAY RECALL LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED ONE HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
TO FIND MORE DEFINED CONCERNING
FACILITY GRANTS.
IS GRANTS WERE PRIMARILY
INTENDED TO ENCOURAGE MORE FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE I COVERING
FACILITY COSTS AS A SEED WITH
CONVERTING THOSE PART DAY
PROGRAMS TO FULL DAY. FOR
INSTANCE A DISTRICTS ME RUN A
MORNING SESSION AND AN AFTERNOON
SESSION IN ONE SHARED CLASSROOM
BUT ONCE THOSE TWO PARTY
PROGRAMS ARE CONVERTED TO FULL
DAY EACH PROGRAM REQUIRES ITS
OWN SEPARATE CLASS ROOM.
THESE GRANTS WOULD HELP COVER
ASSOCIATED FACILITY COST.
IN THE FIRST APPLICATION AROUND
WHICH CONCLUDED JANUARY THIS
YEAR A TOTAL OF SEVENTY
DISTRICTS SUBMITTED TWO HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO PROJECTS
REQUESTING TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO MILLION AND PROJECT FUNDS.
THIS MEANS THAT.
AT THE PROJECT THE PROGRAM IS
NOW OVERSUBSCRIBED EXCEEDS THE
ONE HUNDRED MILLION INITIALLY
ALLIED.
AWARDED -- A SECOND APPLICATION
AROUND WILL OCCUR AND MADE TO
ALLOCATE THE REMAINING FUNDING.
I'M PAGE TWO WE COVER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ALREADY
COVERED AND SO WILL BE SKIPPING
ON TO PAGE.
THREE OUR THIS PAGE CONTAINS OUR
ASSESSMENTS OUT WE OUTLINED
THREE MAIN CONCERNS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
FIRST WE ARE CONCERNS THAT THE
DIGITAL GRANTS ARE NOT LIKELY TO
CHEAT THE STATE'S GOAL OF HAVING
MORE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAMS.
AS YOU CAN SEE IN THE FIGURE ON
PAGE THREE WE ANALYZE THE
INITIAL ROUND OF APPLICANTS AND
FOUND THAT 76%.
OF THE SEVENTY APPLICANTS
ALREADY RUN FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
THESE ARE PROGRAMS LARGELY TO
ARE LARGELY APPLYING TO REPLACE
EXISTING FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS THAT O NOT MEET CD
E. REGULATIONS THIS WAS A
SECONDARY PURPOSE FOR THESE
GRANTS.
IF THE LEGISLATURE WORD EXPANDS
THE PROGRAM AS THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES WE THINK A SIMILARLY
HIGH SHARE OF THE GRANTS WOULD
GO TOWARDS DISTRICTS ALREADY
RUNNING FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
SECONDLY WE FOUND THAT DISTRICTS
ME OPERATE PARTY PROGRAMS FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS BEYOND JUST
FACILITY CONSTRAINTS. FOR
EXAMPLE SOME DISTRICTS TOLD US
THAT THEIR PARENTS PREFERRED TO
SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO PART DAY
PROGRAMS -- OTHER DISTRICTS
INDICATED THAT THEIR TEACHERS
PREFER PART DAY PROGRAMS BECAUSE
THEY LEAD CLASS FOR PART OF THE
DAY AND THEY OFFER OTHER
TEACHERS ASSISTANCE AT AND YOUR
THROUGHOUT THE REMAINDER OF THE
DAY.
GIVEN THOSE ISSUES WE THINK THAT
SOME PORTION OF DISTRICTS
RUNNING PARTY PROGRAMS MAY
SIMPLY NOT BE INTERESTED IN
THESE GRANTS.
THIRD MOST DISTRICTS OPERATING A
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN WERE ABLE
TO COVER EXIST WERE ABLE TO
COVER FACILITY COSTS WITH
EXISTING SOURCES OF STATE AND
LOCAL FUNDING.
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS THE
SHARE OF STUDENTS ENROLLED IN
FULL DAY PROGRAMS GREW FROM 43%
270%.
A DISTRICT INTERESTED IN RUNNING
FULL DAY PROGRAMS MAY BE
ELIGIBLE FOR FACILITY FUNDING
UNDER THE EXISTING SCHOOL
FACILITY PROGRAM THE STATE'S
BROADER LONGER STANDING PROGRAM
THAT HELPS STIFF SPONGE SCHOOL
FACILITIES FOR ALL GRADES.
OR DISTRICTS MAY RELY ON LOCAL
FINDS A DRESS SO ANY CONSTRAINTS.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE
RECOMMENDING THE LEGISLATURE
REFRAIN FROM EXPANDING THE
PROGRAM AT THIS TIME.
TURNING TO PAGE FOUR AND WE DO
OFFER TO TARGETED OPTIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE REMAIN INTERESTED IN
PROMOTING FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN.
FIRST THE LEGISLATURE COULD
REVISIT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
NEXT YEAR AFTER KNOWS MORE ABOUT
THE DEMANDS AFTER THE INITIAL
ONE HUNDRED MILLION IS AWARDED.
IF THE LEGISLATURE DESIRES TO
PROVIDE MORE FACILITY GRANTS
BASED ON ANY REMAINING DEMANDS
WE RECOMMEND IT.
FOCUS THE PROGRAM SPECIFICALLY
ON DISTRICTS RUNNING PARTY
PROGRAMS DUE TO FACILITY
CONSTRAINTS.
SECONDLY THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER CREATING AN EVEN
STRONGER INCENTIVE FOR FULL DAY
PROGRAMS BY REDUCING THE PARTY
PER STUDENT RATE UNDER LCF OVER
THREE YEARS.
CURRENTLY PART DAY AND FULL DAY
PROGRAMS ARE FUNDED AT THE SAME
PER STUDENT FUNDING LEVEL AND
THIS IS DESPITE THE DIFFERENCE
IN INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS.
HOWEVER BEFORE LOWERING THE PART
DAY RATE THAT LEGISLATURE SHOULD
CONSIDER WEIGHING THE TRADE OFFS
CAREFULLY SINCE SOME PARENTS DO
PREFER TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN
APART DAY PROGRAMS.
WITH THAT I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS -- AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ALLEY -- WILL BE
COVERING THE REMAINDER OF A HAND
OUT THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU OFFICE OF PUBLIC
SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION.
I AM SO WE ARE.
A PRIMARILY HERE FOR QUESTIONS
BUT WE CAN THAT'S OKAY.
SURE I KNOW WE HAVE A FEW
QUESTIONS BUT MAYBE I'LL JUST
ASK THE FIRST ONE I KNOW YOU'RE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
PRESENTATION WAS WAS BRIEF JUST
GOT IT IS WHAT IT IS AND THE
GOVERNMENT'S BUDGET BUT I
WONDERED IF YOU COULD.
START US OFF BY RESPONDING TO
WHAT OUR STAFF OUTLINED IN THE
AGENDA AND WHAT LA -- TALK ABOUT
AS FAR AS THE THAT THE DEMAND
WHETHER OR NOT THERE TRULY IS.
DEMAND FOR THE HUNDRED MILLION
LAST YEAR ALONE SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MORE THIS YEAR.
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE LAW THE
SCHOOLS AT THAT -- THAT THAT
PICKED UP ON THIS LAST YEAR RT
WERE AT FULL DAY IN THE USE THE
MONEY FOR OTHER.
OTHER WHERE THE NEEDS FACILITIES
OF COURSE BUT NOT NECESSARILY TO
EXPAND THE FULL DAY.
SURE -- YET WHEN WE WERE
DEVELOPING THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
WE DIDN'T HAVE THE BENEFIT OF
SEEING THE THE TYPES OF
APPLICATIONS ARE COMING IN AND
FROM WHICH SCHOOLS THEY'RE
COMING IN FROM -- WE'RE
CERTAINLY GOING TO BE -- LOOKING
AT THAT INFORMATION AS WE
DEVELOP THE MAY REVISION -- AND
TRYING TO A LINE -- THE PROGRAM
WITH THE BROADER INTENT OF YOU
KNOW.
REDUCING BARRIERS FOR FOR
CONVERSION FROM PART DATA FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS -- IN
TERMS OF DEMAND -- WE LOOKED AT
RESEARCH FROM THE DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION THAT AND INDICATED
THAT THERE'S SIXTEEN HUNDRED
SCHOOL SITES THAT AREN'T
OFFERING HER ONLY OFFERING PART
DAY -- PROGRAMS AND BASED ON
THAT -- NUMBER -- WE DEVELOPED
IN AN ESTIMATE AN ASSUMPTION
THAT THERE THERE WOULD BE SOME
DEMAND FROM THOSE DISTRICTS
AFTER A PROPER INCENTIVES WERE
THERE TO REDUCE THE MAIN BARRIER
WHICH FROM THE RESEARCH WE
LOOKED AT IS.
FACILITIES CONSTRAINTS.
SO DOES THAT MEAN I'LL BE A
REVISED PROPOSAL.
IN MAY ARE YOU LOOKING FOR THE
COMMITTEE THAT HELPED SHAPE WITH
THAT SHOULD LOOK LIKE.
I'M UNABLE TO SAY WE KNOW WHAT
WILL BE IN A MARRIAGE THAT IS MY
BEST EVELYN WE'RE TAKING IN THE
FEEDBACK THAT WE'VE WE'VE HEARD
FROM YOU KNOW LET THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE AS
WELL AS FEEDBACK FROM THE FIELD
AND WE'RE CONSIDERING THAT AS AS
WE DEVELOP.
THE CHAIR.
AND THESE ARE ONE TIME MONIES
OUTSIDE OF NINETY EIGHT SO
CERTAINLY OTHER.
AT INTEREST IN THE STATE COULD
COULD YOU KNOW VIE FOR THIS BUT
OF COURSE WE HAVE OTHER
INTERESTS IN EDUCATION EARLY AT
FOR ONE TIME.
SUCH AS T. K. FACILITIES OR
STATE PRESCHOOL THE SO SO FAR SO
THE AN INTEREST IN THE OPEN TO
LOOK AT THOSE OTHER NEEDS WITH
THIS ONE TIME PART OF MONEY.
CERTAINLY -- THE YEAH THAT TKA
CLASSROOMS ARE AND IN OUR VIEW
IS THE SAME AS THE THE
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM SO ON
THEY WOULD ALSO BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS FUNDING -- AND YET THAT IS
A GOAL OF THIS FUNDING IS TO CAN
YOU KNOW PROVIDE FULL DAY.
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM AS WELL OKAY YET WE'RE
TAKING ALL THE FEEDBACK INTO
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU I WANTED
TO ALSO WELCOME OUR BUDGET CHAIR
THING FOR JOINING US TODAY POTS
AND HEARING THERE ESPECIALLY.
AREAS THAT HAVE A STRONG
INTEREST TO HIM IN THIS ONE FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN SOMETHING THAT
WE'VE BEEN LOOK AT LAST COUPLE
YEARS.
LARGE PART BECAUSE OF YEAR
RAISING THIS ISSUE SO I KNOW YOU
WANTED TO JUMP IN HERE MISTER.
THANK YOU MISTER JUST -- TO L.
L. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU LOOKED AT
I KNOW YOU MENTIONED THAT
PERHAPS SOME PARENTS SOME
DISTRICTS MAY NOT WANT TO MOVE
TO A FULL DAY -- WAS OR ANY LOOK
AT WHAT THE BENEFITS OF FULL DAY
PURSES PART DAY.
WERE FROM A PEDAGOGICAL POINT OF
VIEW ARE ARE ARE THEIR BENEFITS
OR IS IT YOU KNOW A FULL DAY OF
VERSES PARTY THEY'RE ALL THE
SAME.
SURE SO WE DID EXPLICITLY
INCLUDE A THOROUGH REVIEW OF THE
RESEARCH AND ANALYSIS BUT WE DID
TAKE A BRIEF LOOK AT IT.
THROUGH THE MAIN PROPONENT OF
THE MAIN ARGUMENTS THAT THE
PROPONENT SHARES A IS THAT
HAVING MORE INSTRUCTIONAL HOURS
BENEFITS CHILDREN ESPECIALLY LOW
INCOME CHILDREN -- AND THIS IS
MORE LIKELY TO PRAYER THEM
BETTER FOR FIRST GRADE AND THIS
ALSO HELPS PARENTS WITH CHILD
CARE NEEDS.
WHEN WE DID A TIME LIMITED
REVIEW OF THE LITTLE RESEARCH WE
FOUND THAT SOME RESEARCH DID
SUPPORT ACADEMIC BENEFITS BUT
OFTEN TIMES THERE WAS A FEET OUT
A FACT SO YOU COULD SEE
IMPROVEMENTS AND EITHER READING
OR MATH BUT THEY WOULD?
DISAPPEAR BY FIRST OR THIRD
GRADER SOMEONE -- AND SO IN OUR
UNDERSTANDING THE RESEARCH ISN'T
ENTIRELY.
CONCLUSIVE BUT UP THERE IS A
FAIR AMOUNT OF SUPPORT OF
EVIDENCE OUT THERE.
GREAT IN IN TERMS IN JUST IN
TERMS OF THE REGION -- IT IS IT
IS A GEOGRAPHICALLY DISPERSED
WHO DOES FULL DAY VERSUS --
PARTY OR IS IT IS OUR
CONCENTRATION IN CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE STATE.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
TREND IS MORE BY INCOME LEVEL --
PER DAY SEEMS TO BE MORE
PREVALENT.
AMONG HIGHER INCOME GEHRY AS
WHEREAS FULL DAY SEEMS TO BE
MORE PROBABLY IN LOWER INCOME
AREAS -- WE BELIEVE PART OF THIS
IS BECAUSE IN HIGHER INCOME
AREAS PARENTS DO HAVE OTHER
CHILD CARE OPTIONS AND SO IT
MIGHT BE MORE CONVENIENT FOR
THEIR SCHEDULE OR THEY'RE DOING
THEIR NEEDS TO ACTUALLY.
DO PART DAY.
THANK YOU AND THEN WITH WITH THE
CURRENT -- GRANT PROCESS -- YOU
HAD MENTIONED LOOKS LIKE.
I BELIEVE -- NINE NINE DISTRICTS
THAT ARE FULL AND PART DAY
APPLIED AND THEN. EIGHT
DISTRICTS THAT ARE PART DAY ONLY
THEN THEN BASED ON THAT GO HOW
WHAT DO YOU ANTICIPATE THE
PERCENTAGE WOULD JUMP FROM
BECAUSE YOU HAD 70% FULL DAY.
TWO WHAT WOULD YOU THINK IT'LL
MOVE TO BASED ON THAT -- THAT
PARTICIPATION.
AND THEN THE AND THE SUPER
TENNIS OPTICALLY AFTER TWO OR
OUR ACCOUNT MINOR AT THE OFFICE
OF PUBLIC SCHOOL CONSTRUCTION I
AM IN THIS ROUND WE DID SEE THE
MAJORITY OF DISTRICTS THAT
APPLIED WERE ALREADY OFFERING
FULL THEY CAN -- BUT ON THE
APPLICATION FORMS THEY'VE
INDICATED THAT THEY'RE OFFERING
IN CLASSROOMS THAT WERE NOT
DESIGNED OR MAYBE ARE NOT
SUITABLE FOR KINDERGARTEN
PURPOSES.
WE HAVE SOME EXAMPLES OF THAT
TEACHER WORK ROOMS OR SCIENCE
LABS ARE JUST ROOMS THAT WERE
NOT DESIGNED FOR KINDERGARTEN.
YEAH BUT IT WAS SIXTEEN
DISTRICTS OUT OF A SEVENTY TWO
THAT DID NOT OFFER FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN SO WE WOULD -- IF
THERE WERE NO PROGRAM CHANGES WE
WOULD EXPECT ALL OF THESE
DISTRICTS TO APPLY AGAIN IN THE
SECOND ROUND BECAUSE THEY HAVE
NOT.
ALL OF THEM OVERSEE FUNDING THIS
ROUND SO THAT PERCENTAGE CAM
COULD BE THE SAME BUT WE ALSO
ARE GETTING PHONE CALLS FROM
OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THAT DID NOT APPLY IN THE FIRST
ROUND SO WE ANTICIPATE
ADDITIONAL DISTRICTS COMING IN
FOR OUR SECOND ROUND THAT OPENS
UP IN MAY AS WELL WE DON'T KNOW
THE BREAKDOWN YET OF WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ASKING.
FOR DO YOU DO HAVE A SENSE OF
WHAT THE PERCENTAGE MIGHT JUMP
TO THEN BECAUSE RIGHT NOW YOU'RE
AT 70% FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
[inaudible]
AND WE IT'S KINDA HARD TO TELL
AT THIS POINT WE WOULD MAYBE
KNOW A LITTLE MORE AFTER THE
SECOND ROUND BUT WE ARE GETTING
CALLS FROM THOSE THAT DON'T
CURRENTLY OFFER IT IT'S JUST WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT APPLICATIONS ARE
GONNA MATERIALIZE YET GOT IT.
THE BILL JUST COME BACK TO THE
LA IS POINT SO SO YOU'RE WHAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS THAT --
THE AREAS WHERE THERE IS LESS
PARTICIPATION OR OR THEY'VE
MOVING IN TO A PART THAT SCRIPT
PART TIME IS RIGHT PRIMARILY THE
THE HIGHER INCOME ERROR IS THAT
IS THAT [inaudible]
CORRECT.
I'M SORRY WOULD YOU MIND
REPEATING THAT YEAH SEE SO YOU
HAD SAID EARLIER THAT.
THE DISTRICTS THAT HAD PARTAKE
IN THE GARDEN A LOT OF THEM WERE
DOING IT MORE OUT OF CONVENIENCE
AND THEIR PARENTAL INTEREST
WHICH IS.
A BIT SO THEY ARE HIRING CAMARO
SOURCES LOWER INCOME AREAS.
YES BUT THERE ARE STILL SOME
LOWER INCOME AREAS THAT ARE
RUNNING PER DAY PROGRAMS.
AND WHO DID.
DID THEY SHOW INTEREST IN
APPLYING OR WERE THEY ALSO
RESIST NOT RESISTANT BUT NOT
INTERESTED APPLY.
WE DIDN'T REACH OUT TO YOU
DISTRICTS TO THOSE DISTRICTS
SPECIFICALLY -- OUR ANALYSIS WE
REACHED OUT TO A HANDFUL OF
DISTRICTS ARE RUNNING PER DAY
PROGRAM -- BUT WE CAN DEFINITELY
FOLLOW UP WITH YOUR OFFICE AND
GET MORE INFORMATION ON THAT
YEAH IF YOU COULD THOUGH I THINK
THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL BECAUSE AT
THE BECAUSE I THINK WE DO WANNA.
MAKE SURE THAT -- THE MONEY'S
REALLY HAVE IN THE BUT YOU KNOW
THAT THE PROPER BENEFIT
IMPROPERLY BENEFITING THE
COMMUNITIES THAT.
REALLY NEED THESE TYPES OF
RESOURCES [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MR O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND NO THE STATE HAS AN INTEREST
IN IN IN SERVING WANTS AND NEEDS.
AND I THINK IN THIS ARENA TITLE
ONE SCHOOLS ARE REALLY THE NEED.
AND THEN THEY NEED NOW -- WHAT
ARE WE DOING TO PRIORITIZE --
THIS EFFORT THE FACILITY EFFORT
THE FULL THEY CAN -- EFFORT ON
ON THE TITLE ONE SCHOOLS BECAUSE
THAT'S REALLY WHERE WE NEED IT I
UNDERSTAND THAT AS A PARENT I
WOULD LIKE FULL THEY CAN -- IN
MY KIDS DID NOT HAVE FULL DAY
BUT I MAYBE FOR A MORNING CARD
FOR CHILD CARE PURPOSES BUT
REALLY WE'RE FOCUSING ON CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP WE NEED TO
TALK ABOUT THOSE THOSE TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS.
WHAT ARE WE DOING OF TO FOCUS
THIS MONEY ON TITLE ONE SCHOOLS?
SO THE PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE PREFERENCE IN FUNDING TO
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT.
HAVE A HIGH PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS TO QUALIFY FOR FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS AND ALSO FOR
DISTRICTS THAT.
QUALIFY FOR WHAT'S THAT CALLED
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP UNDER THE
SCHOOL FACILITY PROGRAMS OF
THOSE DISTRICTS THAT DON'T HAVE
LOCAL RESOURCES -- TO MAKE THEIR
MATCHING SHARE FOR FACILITIES.
AND SO WE DID SEE A MIX IT'S A
SLIDING SCALE ON THE FREE AND
REDUCED PRICE MEALS SO THE THE
THE MORE STUDENTS YOU HAVE THAT
QUALIFY FOR THAT PROGRAM THE
MORE PREFERENCE YOUR APPLICATION
WILL RECEIVE.
AND WITH THE OTHER COMPONENT OF
THE FINANCIAL HARDSHIP IT'S IT'S
AN ALL OR NOTHING SYSTEM SO IF
YOU CAN'T MAKE YOUR MATCH YOU
GET FORTY POINTS IF YOU CAN MAKE
YOUR MATCH YOU DON'T GET THOSE
POINTS AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN
THIS FIRST ROUND OF APPLICATIONS.
IS THAT IF YOU DID NOT QUALIFY
FOR FINANCIAL HARDSHIP -- THEN
YOU'RE NOT IN THE MIX FOR
FUNDING SO ALL OF THE DISTRICTS
THAT WILL BE FUNDED OUT OF THIS
FIRST AB BATCH OF THIRTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION FOR THE FIRST
ROUND.
QUALIFIED FOR FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
SO THEY NEED ASSISTANCE FOR THAT
PROGRAM.
AND THEN THE FREE AND REDUCED
PRICE MEALS OF THE SLIDING SCALE
AND THE PERCENTAGES ARE PRETTY
HIGH.
THE POINTS CUT OFF AT ABOUT 60%
SO YOU DON'T GET ANY PREFERENCE
UNLESS YOU'VE HAD AT LEAST 60%
FOR INTRODUCED PRICE MEALS.
DO WE HAVE ANY DATA THAT TELLS
US HOW MANY TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
ARE NOW.
PROVIDING FULL THEY CAN -- DOES
ANYONE HERE KNOW THAT.
IT DOES LOOK LIKE WE DO DO WE
KNOW HOW MANY TITLE.
ONE OKAY BELIEVE IT AT THAT BUT
I JUST I JUST WANT TO BACK UP
TALK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS AT A
SCHOOL SITE TO WHEN THERE IS.
PART A KENDER.
AND I THINK AGAIN I'VE BEEN
PRETTY CLEAR THROUGHOUT THIS
DISCUSSION WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING
THIS A COUPLE YEARS I KNOW MR
TINGS A BIG PROPONENTOF THIS
CONCEPT.
WITH THAT TITLE ONE SCHOOLS NEED
TO BE FIRST.
THAT THAT THAT'S MY BIG PRIORITY
AND THEIR IMMEDIATE -- BECAUSE
THERE IS AN ABSOLUTE CONNECTION.
BETWEEN PEOPLE THEY CAN -- IN
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
VI<c.cyan> QUALITATIVE BE A</c>
QUANTITATIVE -- ALSO ON A SCHOOL
SAY WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE SCHOOL
DAY I THINK SOME PEOPLE THINK BY
THE TEACHER THAT THE KIND OF OUR
TEACHER ONLY WORKS HALF AND THEN
THE THE REST THEY MAY THEY GO
HOME EARLY THAT THAT'S NOT ALL
THE CASE -- IF IT'S DONE RIGHT
AND TYPICALLY IT IS DONE RIGHT
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
WHEN THAT -- PART DAY CANDOR
TEACHER IS NOT WITH THEIR HEART
A CLASS BECAUSE THE DAY HAS
ENDED THEY WILL GO INTO ANOTHER
CLASSROOM IT TYPICALLY WOULD BE
A KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM.
SO TEACHERS WOULD DOUBLE UP.
BASICALLY GIVE STUDENTS FOCUS OR
THEY MIGHT BE IN A GREAT ONE TWO
THREE DOING A READING RECOVERY
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SO I JUST YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S
IMPACTS TO OF OF OF CREATING FOR
THEY CAN -- BECAUSE YOU GONNA
TAKE SOME TEACHERS OUT OF
CLASSROOM SO THEY MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE IN.
CLOSING THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAPS I
JUST WANT THAT DYNAMIC TO BE TO
BE ACKNOWLEDGED HERE TO WITH
THAT THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY I FOR THE QUESTIONS.
ALL US ONE MON MORE AS WELL BUT
ALSO I THINK IT HAS A GOOD
QUESTION MISTER O'DONNELL ABOUT.
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS AND WHERE THE
BIGGEST THE IT IS SO I KNOW WE
HAVE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
SOMEWHERE OUT THERE SO IF
SOMEONE'S HERO.
WHAT'S TO COME UP AND HAS THE
ANSWER -- YOU'RE WELCOME BUT YOU
DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER YOU CAN
JUST THINK THEY ATTACK WE DON'T
KNOW WE DON'T KNOW.
I ALSO WANTED TO ABOUT EVEN IF
IT IS -- THE FACILITIES IN
CLASSROOMS THE ISSUE IS IS IS
THE RATED SO.
HAVING YOU KNOW DOUBLE DOUBLE
DARE ONCE A DAY -- DOES IT MAKE
SENSE TO TO ALTER.
THE AMOUNT THAT WE THAT WE PAY
FOR THE STATE FOR FULL DAY
VERSES PARK DAY TO INCENTIVIZE.
DISTRICTS TO GO [inaudible]
FULL DAY.
WE THINK THAT WOULD BE UP TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO DECIDE WE
UNDERSTAND IT IS QUITE A SHIFT
FROM.
WE GET THAT BUT YES IS IT A GOOD
IDEA.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE MERITS TO
THAT IDEA WHICH IS WHY WE
BROUGHT IT UP AS A POTENTIAL
OPTION FOR THE LEGISLATURE.
I'M CURRENTLY PER DAY AND FULL
THEY ARE FIND IT AT THE SAME
RATE DESPITE THE DIFFERENCE IN
INSTRUCTIONAL OUR IN SO IT MAY
BE A SIMPLE INCENTIVE THAT
WOULDN'T.
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL FUNDING. TO
ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS TO PICK UP
FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN YEAH WILL
BE THE DOWNSIDE OF COURSE THAT
THEIR SON THEY'RE DOING FULL DAY
AND SO THE SOMEONE OF A WINDFALL
FOR THEM.
BUT WHAT WOULD BE THE DOWNSIDE
IF IF THERE DISTRICTS THAT.
FOR VARIOUS REASONS PARENT
DEMAND.
JUST SPACE LIMITATIONS.
WHERE WE REDUCE THE RATE?
FOR YES FOR CLASSROOMS AGO PARK
DAY KINDERGARTEN AND WHAT
POTENTIALLY WOULD BE THAT THE
DOWNSIDE TO THAT.
I'M STILL AT JUST TO CLARIFY.
DISTRICTS THAT ARE RUNNING FULL
DAY KINDERGARTEN THEY WOULDN'T
SEE A CHANGE AND THEY'RE FINDING
UNDER THIS PROPOSAL.
IT WOULD JUST BE DISTRICTS
RUNNING PART DAY PROGRAMS -- I
THINK THEIR CONSIDERATIONS WOULD
REALLY BE SOME PARENTS PREFER
NOT TO RUN OR NOT.
TO SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO FULL
THEY PROGRAMS AND SO SOME OF
THESE DISTRICTS MAYBE
INTENTIONALLY CHOOSING TO RUN
PART DAY PROGRAMS IN REFLECTION
OF THE PROVINCES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
THIS READ ON IF I MAY.
I I THINK THERE WOULD BE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT IF YOU'RE
PAYING IF YOU'RE GOING.
TO BUY FOR GATE DID THAT BUT
I'VE YOU'RE GONNA SPLIT UP HOW
YOU PAY -- SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR
IF YOU PAY THEM FOR PART DAY AND
PAY THE PAY THEM SO MUCH FOR
PART IN AND MAYBE MORE FOR FULL
THEY REMEMBER.
YOUR TYPICALLY GOING TO HAVE A
FULL TIME TEACHER THERE AND AS I
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT FULL TIME
TEACHER HAS DUTIES OTHER THAN.
IS THAT THAT THAT. THREE HOURS
THREE HOURS THEY MIGHT SPEND
WITH STUDENTS SO THAT I THINK
THERE'D.
BE A SIGNIFICANT.
FINANCIAL IMPACT AND WE HAVE TO
HAVE A GREATER STAKE YES HI ACID
WITHIN ABOUT DOWNSIDES WERE
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
THE MEDICAL INSURANCE.
OKAY WELL FOOD FOR THOUGHT AND
WE WILL HOLD THIS ISSUE
[inaudible]
OPEN.
LET'S PROCEED NOW NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS ON THIS SCENE WILL
PROCEED NOW WITH ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
TWO PRESCHOOL EXPANSION.
TALK ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE.
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION IN.
ONGOING NONPROFIT NINETY EIGHT
FOR TEN THOUSAND THIS IN A FULL
DAY STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS. FOR
NON ELLIE A PROVIDERS.
AND WITH THIS WE ARE GOING -- TO
DO A LITTLE DIFFERENTLY TODAY
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TWO PANELS ONE
OF COURSE IS THE TYPICAL.
BERMAN A FINANCE LA -- AND
DEPARTMENT OF BAD IN OUR SECOND
PANEL WILL HEAR FROM.
ELLIE A AS WELL AS A COMMUNITY
BASED.
PROVIDER IN CALIFORNIA SO FIRST
WE'LL START WITH PANEL.
ONE FROM THE FINANCE LA OF
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
GOOD MORNING SIR BURDEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL FOR
EARLY LEARNING AND CHILD CARE
INCLUDES MULTIPLE AUGMENTATIONS
TO STRENGTHEN PROGRAMS FOR ZERO
TO FIVE YEAR OLDS IN THE STATE.
THE EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IS JUST
ONE PART OF IT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION DON
PROPOSITION -- NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS. TO PROVIDE TEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS
TO NON LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S GOAL IS TO
PROVIDE TEN THOUSAND SUBSEQUENT
SLOTS FOR THE NEXT TWO BUDGET
YEARS TWO AT A TOTAL OF THIRTY
THOUSAND SLOTS TO SERVE ALL LOW
INCOME FOUR YEAR OLD.
IN THE STATE FOR A TOTAL OF TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND SLOTS BY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AS THE
ADMINISTRATION'S FIRST STEP
TOWARDS UNIVERSAL PRE K.
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ELIA -- GOOD MORNING SERRA
CORTEZ WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT THAT MY
COLLIE PROVIDED -- DURING THE
LAST ISSUE UNTITLED EARLY
EDUCATION BUDGET PROPOSALS AND
WILL BE STARTING -- ON PAGE FIVE
OF THIS HAND OUT -- OFFERS
PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THIS ISSUE SO THE
STATE SERVICE THE STATE SERVES A
PRESCHOOL CHILDREN IN THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS FROM LOW INCOME
FAMILIES -- THIS THIS PROGRAM
HAS TO KEY OBJECTIVES ONE IS TO
PROVIDE KINDERGARTEN READING
THIS AND THEN FOR THE FULL DAY
COMPONENT OF TO HELP LOW INCOME
WORKING FAMILIES I MEET THEIR
CHILD CARE NEEDS WHEN THEY'RE
WORKING OR GOING TO SCHOOL OR
HAVE OTHER NEEDS.
YES TO MAKE THE PROGRAM SERVES A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
STATE PRESCHOOL CHILDREN THE
BULK OF THAT -- IN HIS FOUR YEAR
OLDS.
ON PAGE FIVE THIS FIGURE SHOWS --
THAT'S A PRE SCHOOLS OFFERED BY
SEVERAL TYPES OF PROVIDERS AND
THIS IS SPLIT BETWEEN ELEAZAR
AND NON ELLIE PROVIDERS ELOISE
WOULD BE SCHOOL DISTRICTS COUNTY
OFFICES OF EDUCATION.
NON LEDS WOULD BE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CITY GOVERNMENTS.
ELLIE IS PROVIDE TWO THIRDS OF
THE SLOTS NON ELLIE'S PROVIDE A
THIRD OF THE SLOTS FOR ELLIE ETS --
THE BULK OF THE SLOTS THAT THEY
SERVE OUR PART DAY SLOTS WERE
FOR NON LEDS AT THIS LITTLE BIT
US MORE SPLIT HOW HALF AND HALF.
TO A GREATER SHARE OF NON
ELEAZAR OF SLAUGHTER FULL DAY
RELATIVE TO ELEAZAR.
I'M MOVING ON TO PAGE SIX THIS
DISPLAYS THE EXPANSION OF THE
STATE PRESCHOOL THE FULL THEY
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS -- THIS PIECE A
PRESCHOOL THE FULL THEY SAY
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM HAS EXPANDED
BY 70% AND I WOULD JUST KNOW
THIS IS JUST FULL DAY PRESCHOOL.
I'M MOVING ON TO PAGE SEVEN ON
THE PERMANENT FINANCE ALREADY
WENT THROUGH THE GOVERNOR'S UP
PROPOSAL I'LL JUST NOTE TO MORE
THINGS ON THE SECOND AND THIRD.
OF BOLD OF THIS PAGE THIS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ALSO EXT.
ALSO EXPAND THE ELIGIBILITY FOR
THOSE WHO CAN TAKE UP A FULL
THEY SLIDE IT'S REMOVING -- THE
WORK RECALL OF ITS REMOVING THE
REQUIREMENT THAT FAMILIES HAVE
TO WORK OR GO TO SCHOOL TO FOR
THEIR CHILDREN TO BE ELIGIBLE
FOR THE FULL DAY PROGRAM.
THE OTHER THING IT DOES IS IT
SHIFTING ON SOME OF THE STATE
PRIEST THE SOME OF THE PRESS A
STATE PRESCHOOL FUNDS THAT ARE
FUNDED THROUGH PROP NINETY EIGHT
OUTSIDE OF PROP NINETY SO.
UP AND NON ELLIE IS WOULD BE
FUNDED COMPLETELY WITH NINE
NINETY EIGHT MONEY.
I'M MOVING ON TO PAGE EIGHT IS
OUR ASSESSMENT.
A WE WE THINK THAT EXPANDING
STATE PRESCHOOL FOR NON ELEAZAR
IS MORE LIKELY TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF WORKING FAMILIES AND
THIS IS BECAUSE IN OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH -- NON
ELEAZAR TENDED TO OPERATE LONGER
PROGRAMS -- TYPICALLY A TEN
HOURS A PROGRAMS OR MORE -- SO
WE THINK THIS WOULD ADDRESS
FAMILIES AT WORK LONGER HOURS.
WE DO KNOW THAT THE STATE AND
PROVIDERS AND MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO EXPAND AS QUICKLY AS THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES.
AND THIS IS RECOGNIZING SOME
ADMINISTRATIVE AND LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES.
ADMINISTRATIVE SIDE ON THIS
WOULD BE A HEAVY LIFT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF EDUCATION -- THEY
WOULD HAVE THEY WOULD HAVE.
TO THEY WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE REVIEW
APPLICATIONS FROM HUNDREDS
ADDITIONAL PROVIDERS WHICH WOULD
OKAY A MUCH LARGER WORKLOAD
COMPARED TO THE OF THE PRIOR
MORE MODERATE EXPANSION -- AND
WE DO WE WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT
THE LAST TIME NINE LA PROVIDERS
WERE YOUR MARKS LOTS IT WAS ONE
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED PLUS WHICH
IS QUITE.
WHICH IS A MUCH LOWER AMOUNT OF
SLOTS COMPARED -- TO THAT WHAT
IS PROPOSED.
AND WE'RE ALSO RECOGNIZING SOME
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES ON
FACILITIES ARE A KEY COMPONENT
OF THE OF THIS EXPANSION AND
THIS A MAGNITUDE OF EXPANSION
FOR REQUIRE PROVIDERS.
TO SECURE ADDITIONAL FACILITIES --
WHICH COULD WHICH COULD BE A
BARRIER FOR SOME PROVIDERS.
MOVING ON TO PAGE -- NINE WE
CONTINUE OUR ASSESSMENT ON THIS
PAGE WE DISCUSSED THE WORK
REQUIREMENT WE THINK THE WORK
REQUIREMENT IS REASONABLE TO
PRIORITIZE FULL DAY CARE -- TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE SLOTS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
THE WORKING OR SCHOOL
REQUIREMENT MEANS.
AND ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT ALL
LOW INCOME ELIGIBLE CHILDREN HOW
ARE.
ALTHOUGH INCOME CHILDREN ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR THE PART A PART OF
THIS PROGRAM -- AND THEN WE ALSO
NOTE THAT REMOVING THE WORK
REQUIREMENT COULD INCREASE COULD
SUBSTANTIALLY INCREASE THE COST
OF THE PROGRAM SO THE FULL DAY
SLOT IS DOUBLE THE COST OF A
PARTY SLOT SO THIS COULD CREATE
SOME COST PRESSURE ON THE
PROGRAM WHERE SOME SLOTS TO
CONVERT.
SOME PARTY THOUGHTS WERE COULD
TO CONVERT TO FILL THE SLOTS --
AN ABSENT ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THIS COULD RESULT IN SERVING
FEWER CHILDREN.
WE HAVE A FEW RECOMMENDATIONS ON
PAGE -- TEN AND IF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS INTERESTED IN
ADOPTING THE GOVERNOR'S LONG
TERM PLAN OF SERVING ALL LOW
INCOME FOUR YEAR OLDS WE JUST
HAVE A FEW SUGGESTIONS.
AND THE FIRST IS TO START UP TO
FUNDS FEWER SLOTS IN THE FIRST
YEARI'M STE IN THE FIRST YEAR
OF IMPLEMENTING THIS PLAN.
AND STARTING SLOTS OF IN
STARTING THE SLOTS MEDIA YOU
SUMMARIZE WHAT THEN PAGE TEN
ONLY BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE PAGE.
TEN SUMMARY -- I AM SO SORRY
GIVE US THAT SNAPSHOT YEAH SO
FIRST THING IS WE'RE SAYING
FUNDS FEWER SLOTS -- AND AND
THAT'S IF THE LEGISLATURE IS
INTERESTED IN ADOPTING THE THE
THE THE PLAN OF SERVING ALL LOW
INCOME FOR YOUR OWN THAT THREE
STATE WE SHOULD FUND TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED NOT YEAH WE'RE JUST THEN
WE SHOULD ACTUALLY -- TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AS A
STARTING POINT -- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD FIND MORE OR
LESS BUT TAKING THIS FIRST YEAR
IN LOOKING AT AND LETTING IT BE
A BENCHMARK FOR WHAT THEY COULD
CONSIDER TO FIND IN FUTURE YEARS
TO MEET THE GOAL OF SERVING ALL
INCOME FOR OLD.
ROSS IS SUGGESTING START A
FUNDING SLOTS MID YEAR JUST TO
GIVE TIME FOR STEVIE E. TO
REVIEW APPLICATIONS FOR
PROVIDERS TO SECURE FACILITIES
HIRE ADDITIONAL STAFF AND ROLL
CHILDREN.
WE ALSO HAVE A RECOMMENDATION TO
PROVIDE -- ONGOING FUNDING TO
ASSIST WITH THE FACILITY ISSUES
SO WE'RE RECOMMENDING FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS OF ON GOING
FUNDING TO LOCAL PLANNING
COUNCILS -- WITH THIS FUNDS A
LOCAL PLANNING COUNCILS WOULD
HIRE FACILITY SPECIALIST
BASILEUS SPECIALISTS WOULD HELP
PROVIDERS ME SOME OF THE LOCAL
BARRIERS.
WE'RE ALSO RECOMMENDING FUNDING
THE WORK REQUIREMENT FOR FULL
DAY PROGRAMS AND GIVES AND GIVES
LOTS TO PROVIDERS -- OPERATING
AT LEAST TEN HOURS A DAY AND
THESE TWO RULES WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT THE STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS
ARE AVAILABLE TO ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF WORKING FAMILIES.
WE ALSO SUPPORT ANON ELLIE A
SLOTS FROM ONE FUND SOURCE IN
THE LEGISLATURE COULD GO FURTHER --
INFANCY PRESCHOOL FOR ALL
PROVIDERS FROM ONE FUND SOURCE.
ON THIS CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
THAT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN -- STAFF AND
MEMBERS NAMES KIND JACKSON ON
BEHALF OF SUPERINTENDENT.
STATE SUPERINTENDENT TONY
THURMOND BEFORE YOU BEGIN THIS
ITEM I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
THANK THANK YOU AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR HARD WORKING
GAUGING AND ELEVATING EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE ISSUES OVER
THE YEARS.
AND FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
EXPANDING ACCESS TO QUALITY
PROGRAMS.
THE SUPERINTENDENT IS SO EXCITED
TO SEE THE EGG KNOWLEDGE MINT
AND THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
REGARDING THE IMPORTANCE OF
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE AND THE
FOCUS ON SUPPORTING THE WHOLE
CHILD.
AND FAMILY MORE BROADLY WHILE
THE FOCUS ON THIS ITEM IS
PRIMARILY ON PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION WE WANTED TO QUICKLY
ACKNOWLEDGE THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE GOVERNOR'S.
CONCENTRATED FOCUS ON THE WHOLE
CHILD WITH AN ENTIRE CHAPTER THE
FIRST CHAPTER ONE IS BUDGET
SUMMARY DEVOTED TO EARLY
CHILDHOOD ISSUES.
IN THIS CHAPTER THE GOVERNOR
LAID OUT THREE ESSENTIAL PILLAR
TO SUPPORTING THE WHOLE CHILD
AND FAMILY IS BUDGET.
AS A MEANS TO BREAK THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY AND REDUCE ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES WHICH ARE
EARLY ACCESS TO EDUCATION AND
HEALTH OPPORTUNITIES. TO
EXPANDING EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE OPPORTUNITIES TO ALLOW LOW
INCOME FOUR YEAR OLDS PAID
PATERNAL LEAVE AND DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENINGS. TO HELP CATCH
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS EARLIER.
TWO GENERATIONS STRATEGIES SUCH
AS HOME VISITING AND CAL CAL
GRANT ACCESS AWARDS FOR STUDENT
PROGRAMS.
AND ECONOMIC SECURITY SUCH AS
INCREASING CAL WORKS GRANTS.
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN STRONGLY
BELIEVES THIS FOCUS ON THE WHOLE
CHILD IS ESSENTIAL TO MOVING THE
NEEDLE ON IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR
CHILDREN.
OF ALL AGES.
BY FOCUSING ON THE WHOLE CHILD
IN INVESTING IN QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE PROGRAMS.
WE WILL BEGIN TO SEE PROGRESS
AND BAY BREAKING THE CYCLE OF
POVERTY CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP CLOSING THE OPPORTUNITY GAP
IN STOPPING.
THE SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
WE ALSO WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE HOW FAR CALIFORNIA
HAS COME IN THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND TO THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN YOURSELVES
FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO EXPANDING
ACCESS.
AND TO THE QUALITY OF EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE.
THANKS TO YOUR INVESTMENTS AND
EFFORTS OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND GOVERNOR BROWN IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE SYSTEMS.
ARE NO LONGER BELOW PRE
RECESSION LEVELS THIS IS DUE IN
LARGE PART TO RATE INCREASES
ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND THE EXPANSION OF STATE
PRESCHOOL.
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE AS ADDED
FUNDING TO SUPPORT NEARLY TWENTY
THOUSAND NEW FULL DAY FULL YEAR
SLOTS IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
THE SUPERINTENDENT IS EXCITED BY
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
FURTHER EXPAND STATE PRESCHOOL
SO THAT ALL LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR
OLDS WILL BE SERVED BY
SUBSIDIZED PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
STARTING WITH AN INCREASE OF TEN
THOUSAND NEW FULL DAY. FOUR YEAR
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOTS FOR NON
ELEAZAR IN THE BUDGET YEAR WE
ARE VERY GRATEFUL THAT THIS
PROPOSAL RECOGNIZES THE
PROVIDERS IN THE FIELD THAT ARE
BEST POSITIONED TO FURTHER
EXPAND ON FULL DAY FOR YOUR
SERVICES.
AND THAT THE PROPOSAL COMES
PAIRED WITH THE RECOGNITION THAT
IN ORDER TO BE SUCCESSFUL
ADDITIONAL SYSTEMS CAPACITY
INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT EARLY LEARNING.
IN CARE WORK FORCE AND
FACILITIES.
WE KNOW THAT FURTHER EXPANDING
STATE PRESCHOOL IS VERY IS A
VERY STRONG FIRST STEP. TO
EXPANDING ACCESS TO OPPORTUNITY
RESEARCH SHOWS US CAN BREAK THE
CYCLE OF POVERTY CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND DISRUPT THE SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
AS WE THINK AS A STATE ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES TO EXPAND EARLY.
EXPAND EARLY ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE STILL
GREAT NEED FOR INCREASED ACCESS
FOR INFANT AND TODDLER CARE IN
MANY COUNTIES STATEWIDE.
OVERALL THE NUMBER OF SLOTS
AVAILABLE FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS HAS DECLINED BY ABOUT
26% FROM TWO THOUSAND AND SEVEN
TO TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN
ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED SLOTS.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THE
SUBSTANTIAL RATE INCREASE IN THE
RATES FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE ENACTED
LAST YEAR WHICH MAKE IT EASIER
FOR PROVIDERS TO OFFER
SUBSIDIZED INFANT.
AND TODDLER SPACES.
WHAT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
CURRENT FUNDING FOR SUBSIDIZED
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE ONLY
SUPPORTS ABOUT 16% OF THE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS FROM
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES?
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN THE PROCESS
OF REVIEWING APPLICATIONS FARGE.
FOR OUR GENERAL FUND CHILDCARE
TITLE FIVE INFANT AND TODDLER
PROGRAMS AND WHILE WE ONLY HAVE
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING
THE APPLICATIONS AMOUNTED TO
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED AND NINE
MILLION DOLLARS.
IF THE LEGISLATURE IS INTERESTED
IN DRESSING THIS ISSUE WE'D BE
HAPPY TO PARTNER WITH YOU TO
IDENTIFY THE BEST WAY TO INVEST
IN THIS MUCH NEEDED AREA.
I WILL NOW TURN OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE SEPT SERRA NEVER
MORGAN WHO IS THE DIRECTOR OF
OUR EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
DIVISION AND SHE WILL PROVIDE A
MORE DETAILED UPDATE ON THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS OF PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION.
AND OUR THOUGHTS ON IMPLEMENTING
THE GOVERNORS EXPANSION PROPOSAL.
GOOD MORNING THANK YOU AND
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THEIR
NOVEL MORGAN WITH THE EARLY
LEARNING CARE DIVISION AT THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND AS
MY COLLEAGUE SAID WE ARE
EXTREMELY EXCITED BY THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO EXPAND
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM.
SO THAT ALL FOR LOW INCOME FOR
GIRLS WILL BE SERVED BY
SUBSIDIZED PEACE BOAT PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM.
THIS SUPPORTS THE
SUPERINTENDENT'S GOALS AND AS
PART OF ITS PLAN TO ADDRESS THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WE ARE ALSO
GRATEFUL THAT THE SLOTS ARE FULL
DAY FULL YEAR.
THIS CHANGE ALIGNS WITH THE
FEDERAL HEAD START PROGRAM AND
WILL BEST PROMOTE CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AS WELL AS
SUPPORTING WORKING FAMILIES
NEEDS WHO TRULY NEED AN EXPANDED
OUR FOR CARE.
FINALLY WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
FINE CHEF TO FIND ALL OF FULL
DAY STATE PRESCHOOL AND NON
ELEAZAR WITH NON PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
CURRENTLY ARE NON ALLEY ACE TO
HAVE TO JUGGLE A MIXED PROP
NINETY EIGHT AND NINE NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND WHICH CAN BE
CHALLENGING.
SHIFTING THOSE FINES FOR NOT
ONLY A C. S. B. P. PROGRAMS
MEANS THEY'LL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
SO DIVING DEEPER INTO THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO PRESCHOOL WE KNOW THAT
THIS INVESTMENT IS MUCH NEEDED
TO AS MANY THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLD.
FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES STILL
LACKS ACCESS TO QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE TO GIVE YOU A
QUICK BREAK DOWN.
BASED ON CENSUS DATA WE KNOW
THERE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLDS
IN CALIFORNIA.
OF THOSE FOUR YEAR OLDS ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
ARE FOR FAMILIES WITH INCOMES
BELOW 85% OF THE STATE MEDIAN
INCOME.
WHICH IS ABOUT SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED FOR A
FAMILY OF FOUR OF THOSE LOW
INCOME FOUR YEAR OLD ABOUT A
HUNDRED NINETY ONE THOUSAND ARE
FROM LOW INCOME WORKING FAMILIES.
HOWEVER OUR STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM ONLY SERVICE A HUNDRED
AND TWELVE THOUSAND FOUR YEAR
OLDS FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES
CURRENTLY.
IN ADDITION TO SEE SB P. WHERE
WE KNOW THE QUALITY IS HIGH AND
THE STANDARDS ARE INTENTIONALLY
ALIGNED TO WHAT BASS PERMITS
CHILDREN'S DEVELOPMENT.
WE ALSO SERVE ABOUT TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLD IN OTHER
C. D. E. PROGRAMS AND ANOTHER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND FOUR YEAR OLDS
ARE IN T. K. OR TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT THAT THAT
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR HAVE
MADE OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
AS WE'VE EXPANDED STATE
PRESCHOOL -- THERE WERE ABOUT
TWENTY THOUSAND NEW FULL DAY
FULL YEAR STATE PRESCHOOL SPOTS
BETWEEN FOR TWENTY FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN SO WE ARE.
VERY THANKFUL FOR THAT BUT ALSO
THANKFUL FOR AN ADDITIONAL PIECE.
WE'VE LEARNED A LOT THROUGH THE
RECENT AUGMENTATIONS AROUND
CHALLENGES THAN BARRIERS TO
EXPANDING THE STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM.
ANY EACH YEAR OF EXPANSION
INTEREST AMONG NON ELLIE ACE FOR
STOCKS OUTPACED AVAILABLE FUNDS
FOR THOSE THOUGHTS.
OVERALL IN YEARS WERE EXPANSION
FUNDING WAS AVAILABLE TO BOTH
ELEAZAR AND NON ELLIE ACE.
NON ELEAZAR PRIDE FOR MORE THAN
THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT OF FULL
DAY FULL YEARS.
I AM THOUGHTS THAT ELEAZAR
APPLIED.
FOR SO FOR EXAMPLE IN OUR TWENTY
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
MADE ABOUT FIFTY EIGHT HUNDRED
FULL DAY FULL YEAR SLOTS
AVAILABLE TO ELEAZAR.
AND ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED FULL
DAY FULL YEAR SLOTS AVAILABLE TO
NON ELLIE ACE.
OTHER THOUGHTS FOR ELEAZAR WE
ONLY RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR
ABOUT SIXTEEN HUNDRED FULL DAY
FOR YOUR SOCKS.
HOWEVER OF THE SLOTS FOR NON
ELEAZAR RE RECEIVED A REQUEST
FOR SEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTEEN SOCS.
AS A REMINDER WE ONLY HAD
AVAILABLE.
ONE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SO FAR
OUTSTRIPPED THE AMOUNT OF
AVAILABLE FUNDS THAT WERE THERE.
YOU CAN ALSO SEE IN YOUR AGENDA
THE ASKING AWARD AMOUNT FOR THE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND
FISCAL YEAR.
WE ARE STILL IN THE PROCESS OF
AWARDING THE SLOTS AVAILABLE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BUT WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT THERE'S A MUCH
HIGHER REQUEST ON FULL DAY SLOTS
AT THE NON ELEAZAR THEN WE CAN
FIND. TO ILLUSTRATE THE CUTENESS
OF THIS GAP.
THE NON ELEAZAR REQUESTED JUST
OVER TWENTY SIX HUNDRED FULL DAY
FULL YEAR SLIGHTLY -- THOUGHTS
WHICH WE WOULD NEED ABOUT THIRTY
THREE MILLION AND NON PROP
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT HOWEVER WE ONLY HAVE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION AVAILABLE.
QUITE A GAP IN THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE.
SO WHY AM HAVE THE ELLIE AIDS
NOT APPLIED FOR THESE FUNDS.
AS WE'VE GONE THREAT WE FEEL
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR AT LEAST
OFFER THE FULL DAY FULL YEAR
PROGRAMS FOR SEVERAL REASONS
INCLUDING THE LOW REIMBURSEMENT
RATE.
WE KNOW THAT THAT LOW
REIMBURSEMENT RATE WITH A
REGIONAL MARKET RATE FOR OTHER
PROGRAMS HIGHER THAN OUR
STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
ACROSS MOST OF THE STATE.
PROVIDES CHALLENGE US THERE ALSO
IS AN INCENTIVE AS YOU LOOK AT
PUTTING TOGETHER TO PART DAY
pPROGRAMS FIRST IS OFFERING A
FULL DAY PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY ALLEY IS CAN EARN
MORE FROM SERVINGFOUR YEAR OLDS
AND TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
THEN THEY CAN IN THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
THE LACK OF FACILITIES COMES UP
AS THE BARRIER ALL THE TIME AND
SO ADDRESSING NOT IN THE BUDGET
MOVING FORWARD IS KEY AND WE ARE
VERY GRATEFUL TO SEE THAT AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S CORE.
INFRASTRUCTURE PIECE WE ALSO
HEAR FROM ELEAZAR THAT THE FULL
DAY FULL YEAR OPERATIONS ARE
DIFFICULT BECAUSE A LOT OF THEIR
SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE CLOSE
DURING THE SUMMER.
SO LOOKING AT ALL OF THOSE WE
ARE REALLY GREAT FAULT THAT THIS
PROPOSAL FOCUSES ON EXPANDING
THE NON ALLEY A COMMUNITY BASED
PROVIDERS.
THAT HAVE DEMONSTRATED OVER THE
YEARS THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND SERVICES
pTHOSE SERVICE SAYS.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT NOT ONLY A
PROVIDERS OFTEN CAN OFFER THE
FULL DAY AT TEN HOURS OR MORE OF
CARE WHICH REALLY ALIGNS WITH
WHAT WORKING FAMILIES NEED.
M. ONE IMPORTANT PART OF ANY
EXPANSION ESPECIALLY THIS ONE IS
LOOKING AT WHERE TO ALLOCATE THE
FANS AND PROVIDING ENOUGH
RESOURCES TO CD E. TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN PROVIDE TICKET
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
PROVIDERS AS THEY APPLY FOR
FUNDS AND IMPLEMENT EXPANSION.
ONE THING TO REALLY CONSIDER AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH AN
EXTENSIVE EXPANSION AS HOW WE
MOVE INTO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY WHAT DO WE DO WITH
ELECTRONIC MONITORING ELECTRONIC
OR A PHASE.
COULD BE EASIER ON OUR
CONTRACTORS AND HELP THEM LEFT
UP AND APPLY FOR THE DOLLARS
MORE IN A MORE STREAMLINED
MANNER.
WE ALSO OBSERVE THAT FOR
EXISTING CONTRACTORS EXPANDING
IT PROBABLY TAKES THEM SIX TO
TWELVE MONTHS TO IMPLEMENT THE
EXPANSION AFTER THEY'VE BEEN
AWARDED FUNDS THERE'S A LOT
AROUND HIRING STAFF GETTING
PROGRAM.
I'VE BEEN GOING FOR BRAND NEW
CONTRACTORS WHO HAVE NEVER
WORKED WITH THE STATE IT TAKES
LONGER -- PROBABLY BETWEEN
EIGHTEEN TO EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS ESPECIALLY IF THEY'D
HAVE TO DEAL WITH GETTING THE
FACILITY UP AND GOING.
UNDERGOING LICENSING AND OTHER
CORE COMPONENTS.
ALL OF THESE PROGRAMS ESPECIALLY
NEW CONTRACTING AGENCIES WOULD
BENEFIT FROM MORE FOCUS
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
TRAINING AND SUPPORT ON HOW TO
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT A STATE
CONTRACT.
BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR PUBLIC FUNDS
AND BEST SUPPORT THE CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES IN THIS PROGRAM.
ADDITIONALLY THAT LEGISLATURE
MAY WANT TO AND CONSIDER
ACCOMPANYING THE SLIDING CLEATS
BUT AN EXAMINATION OF
OPPORTUNITIES TO INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL.
THIS COULD BE EXPLORED MORE
DEEPLY AND THE STUDIES
COMMISSIONED AS PART OF THE TEN
MILLION STRATEGIC PLAN THAT WILL
COME UP LATER IN THE AGENDA.
CELL I LOOK FOR IT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU IN THE COMING MONTHS AS YOU
ANALYZE THESE PROPOSALS.
THIS CONCLUDES MY PRESENTATION
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE.
OKAY.
SO WE'RE GONNA KEEP THAT EAT YOU
UP HERE FOR A LITTLE BIT FOR
QUESTIONS BEFORE YOU BRING THE
NEXT PANEL.
QUESTIONS FOR THIS [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LIMóN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION I I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE AND
SPECIFICALLY -- I I HEARD FROM --
THE OFFICE OF THE SUPERINTENDENT
OF PUBLIC INSTRUCTION HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS TO CATCH
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS EARLY AND
SO IN LIGHT OF THAT ARE THERE
ANY.
THOUGHTS OR IDEAS IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE CAN DO TO ENSURE THAT
THE WORK FORCE.
IS ALSO -- IT TRAINED AND EIGHT
YOU KNOW STATE WIDE.
IS THINKING ABOUT HOW WE CATCH
THOSE DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS I
THINK THAT THERE'S BEEN SO MUCH
INTEREST ON THE NUMBER OF SPOTS
AND CLEARLY THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE -- OUR EVIDENCE
TO WHY THE NUMBER OF SPOTS ARE
IMPORTANT BUT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE WE DON'T
LOSE THE FACT THAT.
THE ISSUE OF QUALITY A CHILD
CARE GOES HAND IN HAND WITH THE
NUMBER OF SPOTS AND WE CAN'T
JUST INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
SPOTS WITHOUT ALSO TARGETING
SOME OF OUR ADDITIONAL VERY
IMPORTANT GOALS WHICH IS. TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE HEALTH YOUR
KIDS THAT WERE CATCHING
DEVELOPMENTAL DELAYS AND SO I'M
JUST WONDERING IF YOU CAN
COMMENT.
STILL YES DEFINITELY AND I THINK
WE'LL GET TO THAT A LITTLE BIT
IN THE WORK FORCE ITEM A LITTLE
BIT LATER ON BECAUSE THE WORK
FORCE IS KEY.
WE ALL KNOW IT'S ALL ABOUT THOSE
ADULTS IN THE ENVIRONMENT WITH
THE CHILDREN IN THOSE ADULT
CHILD INTERACTIONS.
WE APPRECIATE YOU.
MENTIONING NOT AND THE QUALITY
OF THE PROGRAM IS ALSO REALLY
COR SUPER THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM THEY FOLLOW
THE TITLE FIVE STANDARDS WERE TO
A LITTLE BIT HIGHER.
THEY DO NOT REQUIRED
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING OUR HEAD
START COUNTERPARTS DO REQUIRE
DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING AS PART
OF THEIR PROGRAM STANDARDS.
SAID THAT SOMETHING AS WE
CONTINUE TO TRAIN A LYING AT A
STATE LEVEL BETWEEN US -- HEAD
START AND WHAT WE'RE DOING WITH
THE STATE PROGRAMS IT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU COULD ALWAYS
CONSIDER AS A PIECE OF THAT WE
DO HAVE IT IN THE QUALITY COUNTS
CALIFORNIA QUALITY RATING
IMPROVEMENTS SYSTEM.
SAID DEVELOPMENTAL SCREENING AS
SOMETHING THAT THE EARLY
EDUCATORS AND FAMILY CHAPTER
PROVIDERS ARE TRAINED JOHN AS
PART OF THEIR QUEUE CC.
PARTICIPATION AND THEN -- THEY
GET POINTS AWARDED ON SORT OF
HOW OFTEN AND HOW THEY'RE DOING
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SCREEN AND HOW
THEY'RE TAKING THAT INFORMATION
BACK INTO THE PROGRAM. TO ENSURE
THAT THE BEST SUPPORTING
CHILDREN.
SO THEN I MINUTES SAVE SOME OF
MY QUESTIONS AND FOR THE WORK
FORCE PART OF IT BECAUSE I HAVE
MORE QUESTIONS ABOUT THOSE KINDS.
OKAY I WANT TO GO NOW TO THE
OVERALL ISSUE THAT.
YOU KNOW THE GOVERNOR HAS THAT
PROPOSAL FOR UNIVERSAL.
PRE K. WHICH OF COURSE WOULD BE
SEVERAL BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S A
GOOD ASPIRATIONAL GOAL I I
SUPPORT THAT.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME I THINK THE
NOTION IS THAT WE SHOULD FIND AT
THE MINIMUM ALL EXISTING INCOME
ELIGIBLE. THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS SO -- WHAT'S NEEDED TO TO
ACHIEVE THAT THAT GOAL AND AND
HOW MANY YEARS WILL IT TAKE AND
WHAT ARE THE THE PIECES THAT WE
NEED.
TO PUT IN PLACE. TO TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN.
FROM HAVING A FINANCED CD E.
[inaudible]
THE ADMINISTRATION'S UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL PRE K. PLAN IS IS MUCH
SLOW AND METHODICAL SO THE IDEA
IS TO FIRST FIND THE LOW INCOME
FOUR YEAR OLDS WHICH WE HAVE
CALCULATED AT THERE'S AROUND
THIRTY THOUSAND THAT STILL.
DON'T HAVE ANY ACCESS TO
SERVICES AT ALL SO THE PLAN TO
ROLL THAT OUT BY TEN THOUSAND
SLOTS EACH YEAR IS PART OF THAT
SLOW AND METHODICAL ROLLOUT OF
GETTING TO UNIVERSAL PRE K..
AND THAT'S WHERE THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS OUT RIGHT NOW
IN TERMS OF SERVING THOSE FOUR
YEAR OLDS ON IN THIS BUDGET IN
THE NEXT COUPLE OF BUDGETS.
AND BESIDES THE NUMBER AT SLOTS --
WHAT'S NEEDED FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PERSPECTIVE WE
KNOW THAT.
AS THE TO PART OF AN MENTIONED.
WE'VE HAD ROUGHLY TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND SLOTS PROVIDE IN THE
LAST FIVE YEARS AND WE I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THAT IN THE
SUBCOMMITTEE LAST.
THIS OUR FIFTH YEAR DOING
WORKING ON THOSE.
A BUDGET INCREASES.
AND WE'VE HAD SOME LIMITATIONS
WITH ELEAZAR BECAUSE OF RATES
JUST RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
WE'RE FACING THAT BUDGET CRISIS
IN MY HOME DISTRICT HERE AT SAKS
CITY.
GRANT HAS ALL KINDS OF OTHER
ISSUES ABOUT THAT BUT ONE THING
THAT WE'RE REALIZING.
IS THERE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
IS THAT IT WAS BEING SUBSIDIZED
BY THEIR GENERAL FUND AND THE
RATE REIMBURSEMENT STRUCTURE
WASN'T VIABLE TO TO TO MAKE IT
WORK.
AND SO THAT LEADS US TO BELIEVE
THAT THERE PROBABLY ISSUES ALL
ACROSS THE STATE AS FAR AS OUR
OF OUR OVERALL -- FUNDING TO
MAKE SURE WE YOU KNOW PAY THE
WORKERS ADEQUATE WAGES AND
FOCUSING ON THE MINIMUM WAGE
INCREASES AND CONTRACTS AND
QUALITY ISSUES THAT SOMEONE
MEMBER LIMO AND TALKED ABOUT SO.
BESIDES LOTS WHAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN. TO MAKE -- THOSE SLOTS
VIABLE FOR BOTH ELEAZAR AND CBS.
GOOD MORNING LISA RESIDENTS GIVE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I THINK I
ONE OF THE ISSUES ARE AND THAT'S
ON THE AGENDA AND LATER IS THE
TREE TO STRATEGIC PLAN THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS -- I THINK IN
THE STATE WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO
DO IS WE NEED TO HAVE A REALLY
GOOD NEEDS ASSESSMENT OF WHERE.
WHERE THE -- HIGHEST LEVEL OF
NEED AS AND THEN WE NEED TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT NEEDS TO DO
WE NEED AS A STAKE IN ORDER TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY AT THAT LEVEL
RATES AND IS CERTAINLY PART OF
THAT CONVERSATION -- BUT IT'S
REALLY A HOLISTIC LOOK.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF ALL THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES -- THAT NEED
TO COME TOGETHER AND START
SUPPORTING THESE CHILDREN I'M IN
WITH REGARD TO PRESCHOOL AGAIN I
THINK -- WE JUST NEED IS A STATE
OF PLANNED WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THE SLOTS WHERE THE
PRESCHOOL SLOTS ARE NEEDED.
WHAT IT COSTS AND MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S?
IT ALL WORKS TOGETHER.
I I I KNOW WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
OUR NEXT PANEL WHICH IS AN ALLEY
A FROM WEST CONTRA COSTA AND A
CBO.
BUT I THINK THEY WOULD SAY THAT --
WE WE KIND OF KNOW.
BASED UPON IS THOUGHT TO BE
PUTTING OUT LAST FOR YEARS.
WHAT THE LIMITATIONS ARE SO
WHAT'S THE -- THE APPETITE FOR
THE MINISTRATION IN ADDITION TO
HAVING THAT A PLAN BECAUSE THE
PLAN REALLY IS THAT THE
UNIVERSAL ASPECT AS WELL.
HOW YOU DO IT NOT JUST FOR ALL
LOW INCOME KIDS BUT ALL -- FOUR
YEAR OLDS IN CALIFORNIA AND
REVENUE IS CERTAINLY AN ISSUE
THERE BUT IN THE IMMEDIATE TERM.
WHAT ABOUT -- THE RATE STRUCTURE
DO WE THINK THAT'S ADEQUATE WITH
THE EXISTING SLOTS THERE'S NEWS
LOTS PROPOSED MASTERS BUDGET IN
THE SLOTS WE'VE JUST -- APPROVE
THE LAST -- TWO BUDGET YEARS
THREE BUT YEARS.
YOU'RE GONNA HATE THIS ANSWER
BUT I'M NOT IN A POSITION TO
PROVIDE -- ANY ANY COMMENT ON
THAT AT THIS POINT IN TIME
HOWEVER I THINK THIS GOVERNOR
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS MADE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT EARLY LEARNING
CARE.
AND THE SPORTS GIVEN TO YOUNG
CHILDREN IS A VERY IMPORTANT AND
A HIGH PRIORITY SO I THINK TO
THAT EXTENT THERE'S GOING TO BE
MORE CONVERSATIONS.
OUT AS WE MOVE FORWARD SURE I
THINK THIS IS SOMEWHAT CAM
PARABLE TO YOU KNOW THE HEALTH
CARE DEBATE THAT JUST BECAUSE
YOU GIVE SOMEBODY.
A MEDICAL CARD AND SAY HERE YOU
HAVE HEALTH CARE.
UNIT ALONG IF THEY DON'T HAVE.
THAT A DOCTOR CLINIC TO MAKE
THAT -- WORK IN ITS IT'S HAVE AN
EMPTY PROMISE I'M NOT SAYING
THIS IS EMPTY BUT WE WOULDN'T DO
THINK ABOUT THE SAME THING WE'VE
BEEN INCREASING SLOTS AND
THEY'VE BEEN COMING BACK FROM
THE ELLIE I ELLIE A SIDE FOR
SEVERAL REASONS AND WE NEED.
TO OWN THAT FIGURE OUT WHAT THAT
IS AND ALSO -- HERE FROM THAT
FOR THE NOT ONLY A SO WE I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT WE LOOK AT THE
WHOLE PICTURE THERE AS AS WE GO
FORWARD -- SO WITH THAT OF MR
TING.
OR JUST TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT I I
THINK IF.
WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR NUMBER
YEARS BEEN A MAJOR LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITY AROUND -- PRESCHOOLS IF
THERE ARE OPEN SLOTS I THINK WE
DO NEED TO LOOK AT WHETHER THOSE
SLOTS ARE BETTER SHIFTED TO NON
DALY ETS -- WHO SEEM TO HAVE A
LONG WAITING LIST SO IT'S NOT
IT'S NOT AS IF?
THE NON ELEAZAR SAYING HOW WE'RE
WE'RE FINE TOO BUT THEY IN IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AT LEAST IN
THE COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT
THE TO TO HAVE A FAIRLY LONG
WAIT LIST. FOR DEMAND SO AGAIN
IT DOES MAKE SENSE TO HAVE THE
SLOTS THAT ARE FUNDED IT TO SIT
EMPTY -- RATHER THAN TO FIND THE
WHERE THE NEED IS AND REALLY HOW
BEST WE CAN SERVICE THAT NEED.
IF IF FOR EXAMPLE IS MISSED
MCCARTY SAID.
REALLY.
APPS LA AREN'T AREN'T BEST
PROVIDED TO SERVE THIS.
PARTICULAR NEED WE DO HAVE TO
LOOK AT WHAT ELSE ARE OUR
OPTIONS.
AND THAT THAT NUMBER THIRTY
THOUSAND WE THINK THAT'S
ACCURATE NUMBER OF LOW INCOME OF
THREE AND FOUR YEAR OLDS THAT
ARE.
THAT ARE NOT SERVED WITH HEAD
START STATE PRESCHOOL NTK WHEN
THEY ENTER KINDERGARTEN.
YES THIRTY THOUSAND NUMBERS JUST
LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR OLD THAT
ARE NOT BEING SERVED BETTER ON
SERVE CURRENTLY BY ALL THE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
THAT.
HAVE EDUCATIONAL FOUR YEAR OLDS
AND BUT JUST FOR YOUR OWN WHAT
DO YOU BASE THAT ON DOT IS BASED
ON ENROLLMENT NUMBERS IN HEAD
START AND T. K. AND THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM AND TAKING
INTO ACCOUNT THE POPULATION OF
FOUR YEAR OLDS IN THE STATE.
I KNOW INCOME WHAT I MEAN WHERE
WAS THAT RESEARCH DONE WHAT
REPORTERS THAT FRIENDS YOU KNOW.
THAT'S THAT'S OUR RESEARCH
LOOKING AT JUST THE ENROLLMENT
NUMBERS IN COMING UP WITH THAT
NUMBER ON OUR END OKAY.
THAT'S A HARD NUMBER TO PIN DOWN.
OKAY LET'S MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
PANEL HERE FROM THE PROVIDERS OF
THESE STATE PRESCHOOL CONTRACTS
FROM THAT.
SCHOOL DISTRICT PERSPECTIVE.
AS WELL AS A CBO SO WITH THAT WE
HAVE.
PAGE IS THAT ON WE HAVE A ROBIN
LAYTON FERMENT EDUCATION
RICHMOND SERVICES THE STATE
PRISCO THAT CONTRACT PROVIDER IN
SAN DIEGO IN FROM THE WEST
CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
A MISS LINE RAY.
A JOCKEY.
THE RIGHT YES OKAY THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING.
YES WILL START WITH THE SCHOOLS
COULD HAVE GOOD MONEY MISTER
CHAIR AB ACTUALLY THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- FOR ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK
ON SOMETHING I'M REALLY
PASSIONATE ABOUT -- WCCO AS THE
C. S. B. B. CURRENTLY PROVIDES
THIRTEEN PARTY AND TWO FULL DAYS
PROGRAMS.
AND THE FOR THEIR PROGRAMS AT
PARIS AND CORONADO. TO ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN OF LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES.
THE FAMILIES ACCESS SITES HAVE
LOW INCOME.
OUR OWN GOVERNMENT ASSISTANCE.
THE FAMILIES ESPECIALLY IN REACH
ONE I AM TRIANGLE WE ARE ONE OF
A FULL DAY PROGRAM IS LOCATED
IMMIGRATION ISSUES HI CRIME
ENVIRONMENT.
LOW FAMILY EDUCATION THAT
ATTAINMENT AND SOMETIMES DRUG
USE THAT IMPACTS THE ABILITY TO
ADEQUATELY SUPPORT THEIR
CHILDREN'S LEARNING.
OUR PROGRAM PROVIDES A CRITICAL
HEAVEN FOR YOUNG CHILDREN TO
ACQUIRE THE NECESSITY FOR
INDIGENOUS SKILLS.
THAT ENABLE SCHOOL SUCCESS. 77%
OF OUR CHILDREN ARE FREE AND
REDUCED LUNCH.
I'M GOOD I'M NOT GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE WHOLE DISTRICT I'M
JUST GOING TO FOCUS ON THE
PRESCHOOL AND THE FULL DAY
PROGRAM BECAUSE OF PILOT THIRTY
FOR TWO YEARS.
AND I'M GOING TO TELL YOU ABOUT
THE SUCCESSES I'M REALLY HAPPY
TO BE HERE BECAUSE YOU'RE
HEARING FROM PEOPLE.
THAT REALLY DOING THE JOB NOT
RESEARCH ALL JUST FROM
[inaudible]
ASKING.
QUESTIONS SO I WENT TO TALK TO
YOU.
ABOUT THE SUCCESS IS THAT WE
HAVE HAD.
I PROGRAM PROVIDES HIGH QUALITY
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM.
ALL UP PROGRAMS IS THAT YES FIVE
ON FOR FROM THE CARROTS SO I
HAVE WE HAVE SEVEN FIVE TWO OF
FIVE PROGRAMS.
AND IT'S TEMPLE.
SITES.
OUR LAST SB TO JAVA FULLY
CREDENTIALED AND THEY HAVE THAT
YOU SEE APARTMENTS.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT AND
THAT'S WHAT THE STATE IS TRYING
TO ACHIEVE.
ARE WE HAVE.
EXTENSIVE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
AND THEREFORE THAT'S AFFECT IN
THE PROS -- THE PRODUCT OF THE
KIDS THAT THAT AT THAT WE ARE
PRODUCING MY TO MY PERCENT OF
OUR STUDENTS.
AB FROM PRESCHOOL MEDS EARLY
LITERACY BENCHMARK IN SPRING OF
TWO THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN IF
YOU LOOK AT GO PUBLIC.
SCHOOL OF WEST CONTRA COSTA PAGE
TWENTY SIX IS THERE.
THERE ARE NONE PUBLIC --
ORGANIZATION.
I ENROLLMENT PRACTICES.
AFTER ANOTHER MINUTE WE
ADVERTISE IN LOOKOUT MAGAZINES.
OUR MOVIE THEATER.
LEARNED REMARKS STALLS FIFTH
BEST -- AGENCIES.
WE ALSO HAVE ACADEMIC
CONFERENCING WE HAVE TIME FOR
PLANNING WITH TEACHERS DURING
SCHOOL AND AFTER SCHOOL SO WE
HAVE.
EXCELLENT.
FAMILY INVOLVEMENT PROGRAM
COMMUNICATION AND TRAINING FOR
EXAMPLE. TO IMPROVE THE LITERACY
OF ARCADES WE HAVE -- READY FOR
KIDS IS A TEXT MESSAGE THE SAGE
THAT WAS SENT TO PERRANCE.
SO THAT THEY CAN -- WALK WITH
THEIR KIDS AT HOME.
WE ALSO HAVE NEWSLETTER AS WE
HAVE MAGAZINES WE HAVE PARENTS
TRAINING SO WE'VE BEEN ABLE --
TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES.
FOR A PRESCHOOL CHILDREN
[inaudible]
BUT WE HAVE A LOT OF CHALLENGES.
IN GIVEN LAST STUDENTS FULL DAY
PROGRAM IT'S WELL NEED THAT
BECAUSE OUR PARENTS REALLY NEED.
A FULL DAY PROGRAMS BUT WE HAVE
A LOT OF CHALLENGES IS LIKE
STARTING A NEW BUSINESS.
GOING THROUGH ALL THE
REGULATIONS.
AND ALSO FIGURING OUT THE
BENEFITS WHY CHILDREN. FOR
EXAMPLE IF PERRANCE -- I'M NOT
IN SCHOOL.
ALL THE ITEMS THAT CAN FOR JOBS
THEY DON'T QUALIFY.
BUT IT'S A NEEDED SERVICE THAT'S
ONE ALSO BE IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE HAVE TO FIND A WAY
OF PROVIDING SERVICES FOR KIDS.
THERE IS NO WAY A SCHOOL
DISTRICT COME PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED AND FOUR TO SIX DAYS.
OF SERVICES TO CHILDREN.
THERE'S NO WAY MOST
ADMINISTRATORS WERE FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIVE DAYS.
SO THAT WILL BE ADMINISTRATIVE
SUPPORT OF THE SITES SO.
IF YOU'RE WONDERING WHY PEOPLE
ARE NOT ASKING FOR THE SLOTS
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE NOT GREEN.
IT IS THAT SORRY INTERRUPT YOU
YES YOU THINK THAT THE TOP
REASON THAT'S A TOP PRISON.
I HAVE HAD SLEEPLESS NIGHTS
TRYING TO WORK WITH MARK I'M NOT
LEAST ON THIS ISSUE.
YEAH TO THE EXTENT THAT.
YEAH I HAVE BEEN CAN YOU GO BACK
AND YEAH I THINK IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE CAN YES
EXPLAINED TO US IN THE PUBLIC
MORE ABOUT THAT.
THE LOG.
AND THE OBLIGATION FOR STATE
PRESCHOOL TO BE.
HOW TO HAVE MORE DAYS THAN THE
TRADITIONAL YOU THEN YOUR
KINDERGARTNERS FIRST GRADE AND
WHAT THAT MEANS FOR A SCHOOL
DISTRICT OKAY PLACE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS?
BECAUSE OF THE CONTRACT ISSUES
WITH TEACHERS.
HE DOES HAVE TO GO ON HOLIDAYS
THAT'S ONE WE HAVE TO HAVE --
NEGOTIATE WITH THE UNION.
BECAUSE THE TWO DOES HAVE TO BE
PAID EXTRA.
WE HAVE TO NEGOTIATE WITH.
HE MERRY SAYS DEPARTMENT SO THAT
THE TEACHERS.
CAN COME BACK AND TEACH THE KIDS
OUT OF THAT AFTER THE ONE EIGHTY
DAYS OF SCHOOL.
SO IT'S A LOT OF THEIR AND ALSO
WE NEED MOST OF THE SITESARE A
DIFFERENT SITE.
THEY'RE NOT IN THE CENTER SO WE
NEED ADMINISTRATIVE COVERAGE AND
THE PRINT AND THE PRINCE WAS OUT
ON HOLIDAYS.
SO IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT THE
BEST THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
PROVIDE IS ABOUT TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE DAYS THAT THESE.
UP TILL JUNE.
THEN ABOUT TWENTY DAYS AFTER
JUNE.
END OF JUNE THE BEST THAT CAN
PROVIDE BECAUSE OF SUMMER SCHOOL.
THAT YOU CAN HAVE ADMINISTRATORS
SO NEGOTIATING WITH THE AND I
LEAST.
IT'S IT'S REALLY TOUGH I'M
THAT'S WHY PEOPLE ARE NOT.
LOOKING FOR THE SLOTS IS NOT
BECAUSE HERE'S NO MONEY IS NOT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT NEED THAT BUT
THAT'S THE MAJOR REASON.
BUT ISN'T IT A CATCH TWENTY TWO
BECAUSE IF YOU.
HELP SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE YOURS
THIS.
BECOME MORE FINANCIALLY VIABLE
AND HAPPIER DAYS.
THEN YOU MAY HAVE PARENTS WHO
SAY WELL ONE MILLION YOU FOR
THOSE TWO MONTHS DURING THE
SUMMER LOOK AT WHAT WE DO ABOUT
THAT GOOD. FOR EXAMPLE MOST OF
THE THE PARENTS HAVE KIDS WELL
OLDER SIBLINGS THEY WANT TO GO
ON VACATION.
SO DURING THE SUMMER MONTHS AND
ROMANCE IS REALLY LOW.
THE BILL.
HOLD ON TO THE SPOT BUT THEY'LL
GO ON VACATION.
AND SOME OF THEM GO TO MEXICO
FOR LIKE THREE WEEKS.
YEAH SO WHAT ARE THE WHAT ABOUT%
THE ONES WHO DON'T GO ON BECAUSE
OKAY WHO ARE IN THE POVERTY AND
DON'T.
HAVE THE YOSEMITE OPTION OKAY SO
MY OKAY.
OKAY MY THING IS WHAT WHAT WHAT
WE TELL THEM FOR THE OKAY MY
CITIES AND I AND I I'M VERY.
OPEN TO THIS BUT I THINK WE NEED
TO ASK YEAH I UNDERSTAND BUT I
THINK MESSAGES WHAT'S THE GOAL
WHAT'S THE ULTIMATE GOAL DO YOU
WANT TO PROVIDE A DO YOU WANT TO
PREPARE THE KIDS.
SO THAT THEY CAN BE READY FOR
KINDERGARTEN OR DO YOU WANT TO
PROVIDE THEM WITH.
DAYCARE.
SO IS THERE WHAT WE CAN DO
REFERENCE SERVICES. FOR THOSE
STUDENTS THAT IT'S NOT.
OUR SCHOOL BASED.
BECAUSE IF THE GOAL IS TO GIVE
THEM THE ACADEMIC -- FOUNDATION
OF SKILLS THEY NEED THEN WE NEED
THE SERVICES BUT IF THE GOAL IS
TO PROVIDE DAYCARE.
THEN THAT'S A DIFFERENT THING
ENTIRELY.
OKAY SO.
I MEAN I INTERRUPTED YOUR
PRESENTATION NO THAT'S FOR AN
ISSUE MAYBE LET'S GO BACK YEAH
YEAH THAT'S OKAY -- ALSO DURING
THE SUMMER MONTHS WE ALSO HAVE
TO REPAIR THE SCHOOL SITES DEEP
CLEANING.
YOU KNOW THOSE YOU KNOW THAT'S
ONE OF THE THE THINGS THAT I
LIKE I SAID.
WHAT MADE YOU WE ARE THE
ADMINISTRATORS -- TO TO BE AT
THE SITE [inaudible]
ARM.
I THINK THOSE ARE THE MAIN
CHALLENGES THAT WE HAVE.
BUT OVERALL HE SAID NEED AT
PROGRAM ESPECIALLY FOR KIDS FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES BECAUSE THEY
HAVE THE HEAD START YOU NEED TO
VISIT OUT OUR PROGRAM I WISH
THAT YOU COULD.
COME AND VISIT THE PROGRAM YOU
SEE THREE YELLED OUT FOR YELLS
READING ALREADY.
I I I I I CAN.
TESTIFY TO THAT SO IF THAT'S THE
GOAL IF YOU WANT HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAM.
WE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE TO BE
SUPPORTED.
OKAY THANK YOU YOU WELCOME.
PLACE THANK YOU HIGH -- ROBIN
LAYTON THAT.
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
EDUCATIONAL RICHMOND SYSTEMS AND
DIEGO WE'RE A NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION OR A COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION OR A NON
ELLIE.
EIGHT AND WE'RE CELEBRATING
FORTY YEARS THIS YEAR.
I'VE BEEN WITH THE ORGANIZATION
THIRTY FIVE YEARS SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY ON BEHALF OF ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES BEHIND ME AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
THIS IS A VERY EXCITING YEAR FOR
US.
SO -- I'VE BEEN AT THIS TABLE --
OVER THE THIRTY FIVE YEARS AND
IT HAS NOT BEEN AS EXCITING AS
IT IS TODAY SO THANK YOU.
IN OUR PROGRAM WE HAVE -- TWENTY
ONE EARLY EDUCATION CENTERS WE
SERVE ABOUT A HUNDRED ELEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS A DAY.
AND WE SERVE THEM IN BOTH FULL
AND PART DAY PROGRAMS WE HAVE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH US TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHERE THEY GIVE US WE
ARE -- OPEN UP -- STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM FOR THREE
HOURS.
AND WE THEY GIVE US A ROOM WE
GIVE THEM READY CHILDREN WE ALSO
HAVE THE NEED BASED PROGRAM
WHICH IS -- WE HAVE SEVEN OF
THOSE SCHOOLS AND THAT IS THE
PROGRAM THAT IS YEAR ROUND FULL
DAY.
AND WE'RE TALKING TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY DAYS A YEAR OVER TEN HOURS
A DAY.
AND THAT IS -- SEEMS TO BE WHAT
OUR FAMILIES IN OUR COUNTY AND
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
NEED WE PROVIDE A BREAKFAST
LUNCH AFTERNOON SNACKS SO THE
CHILDREN ARE GETTING NUTRITIOUS
MEALS.
WE ARE ORGANIZATION ACTUALLY
SERVES A WE STARTED EIGHTEEN
MONTHS AND GO TO FIVE YEARS WE
ACTUALLY DID WHEN I STARTED AND
UP UNTIL ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO WE
SERVED.
IN FENCE BUT WE HAD TO GIVE THAT
UP DUE TO BUDGET CUTS SOME HOPE
WERE -- ACTUALLY APPLIED TO
BRING THAT BACK.
EVERYTHING THAT -- MY COLLEAGUE
SAID OVER HERE AS FAR AS THE
PROGRAM.
WHERE EXACTLY THE SAME SO WE
ALSO HAVE A PART OF THE Q. R. S.
AND OUR PROGRAMS ARE ALSO A TIER
FIVE IN?
FOR ALL OF THE STATE MANDATES
REGARDING THE EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENTS AND WHAT THE CHILDREN
ARE PROVIDED.
IS EXACTLY THE SAME WE HAVE THE
SAME RATIO SO FOR PRESCHOOL TO
ONE TO EIGHT FOR TODDLERS IT'S A
WONDER FOR AND FOR INSTANCE IT'S
A ONE TO THREE WERE CONSIDERED A
TITLE -- FIVE ORGANIZATION AND I
ALSO FORGOT TO TELL YOU THAT NOT
ONLY DO I SERVE ELEVEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS I EMPLOY OUR
ORGANIZATION EMPLOYS A HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE PEOPLE THAT'S
QUITE A BIT.
WE HAVE LOTS OF EXPERIENCE OVER
THE LAST THIRTY FIVE YEARS IN
BUILDING AND RENOVATING SCHOOLS
JUST THIS LAST YEAR THROUGH
PRIVATE DONATIONS OF BEING ABLE
TO PAY FOR THE RENOVATIONS WE
OPENED UP OUR NEW A SCHOOL.
AND WITH IN A DAY IT WAS FULL
AND MOST OF THOSE STUDENTS CAME
FROM.
OUR EXISTING PART DAY BECAUSE
THOSE FAMILIES NEEDED FULL DAY.
AND SIBLINGS BECAUSE WE DID WE
DO SERVE TO A TWO YEAR OLDS OVER
THERE.
SO I WON'T GET INTO ALL OF THE
EDUCATIONAL COMPONENTS BECAUSE
MY COLLEAGUE OVER HERE DID
MENTION ALL OF THAT BUT JUST SO
YOU KNOW OUR PROGRAMS.
THE CURRICULUM IS RESEARCH BASED.
ALL THE WAY FROM BIRTH TO AGE.
FIVE AND WHETHER OR NOT THE
STUDENTS ARE IN A PROGRAM FOR
THREE HOURS OR TEN HOURS THEY
GET THE SAME PROGRAM ACTUALLY
THEY GET MORE BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEY'RE ALL DAY.
AND THEY GET MORE NUTRITIOUS
MEALS AS WELL.
ANOTHER UNIQUE ASPECT THAT WE
HAVE.
CREATED AND THIS IS ALSO THROUGH
A PRIVATE GRANT THAT WE RECEIVED.
THROUGH THE SAN DIEGO SOUND
FOUNDATION WHICH I'M I'M HOPING
ALL OF YOU HEARD THAT IN OUR
COUNTY -- THE FOUNDATION
RECEIVED AT THIRTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO LOOK AT
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IN OUR
IN OUR COUNTY AND I'M ONE OF
FOUR AGENCIES THAT BENEFITTED
FROM THIS.
FROM THIS GRANT IN ITS TO LOOK
AT WAYS TO EXPAND AS WELL AS
PROVIDING SUPPORT SERVICES SO --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT -- HEAD
START PROGRAM HAS IS -- OUR
FAMILY LIAISONS BUT OUR STATE
FUNDING DOESN'T PAY FOR THAT SO
WE WERE ABLE TO CREATE.
TO A POSITIONS WERE FAMILY
LIAISONS.
AND EARLIER SOMEBODY WAS TALKING
ABOUT WE ARE TIME OF THE EARLY
IDENTIFICATION SO OUR LIAISONS
AS WELL AS OUR HIGHLY QUALIFIED
STAFF ARE CURRENTLY.
IDENTIFYING THESE CHILDREN EARLY
AND IF THEY HAVE NEEDS WE'VE
CREATED A PARTNERSHIP WITH OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WHERE -- MOM AND DAD OR AN UNCLE
OR GRANDMA WHOEVER'S DROPPING
OFF THE CHILD AT SIX THIRTY IN
THE MORNING.
CAN NOW GO TO WORK AT TEN
O'CLOCK A BUSTLE COM FOR SOME OF
THESE CHILDREN BECOME UP TAKEN
TO THE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICT
BRING THEM BACK CHILD GETS LUNCH
THAT.
AFTERNOON PLAY MOM PICKS THEM UP.
FIVE BY [inaudible]
THIRTY AND DIDN'T MISS A BEAT
DIDN'T MISS DIDN'T MISS WORK SO
THIS PRO THESE PROGRAMS THESE
FULL DAY YEAR ROUND PROGRAMS FOR
BIRTH THROUGH.
FIVE OUR ALLOWING CHILDREN TO
LEARN AND PARENTS TO EARN.
AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT --
ALL OF THIS EXPANSION
[inaudible]
SO -- I'M NOT SURE IF YOU WANT
TO KNOW MY RECOMMENDATIONS BUT
HERE I AM AFTER THIRTY FIVE
YEARS.
UP.
IN OUR OPINION WE BELIEVE THAT
ALL UP BEFORE WE SERVE EVERY
FOUR YEAR OLD IN THIS STATE.
WE NEED TO SERVE ALL CHILDREN
BIRTH THROUGH FIVE WITH THE
PEROT PRIORITY GIVEN TO WORKING
FAMILIES [inaudible]
OF WE HAVE A VERY SUCCESSFUL
CURRENT MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM.
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT PROGRAMS AND
THE TITLE FIVE PROGRAMS.
ARE THE PROGRAMS THAT OFFER THE
HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS FOR THE
CHILDREN WHERE -- RESEARCH TO
SAYING THAT IF CHILDREN ARE IN
THESE PROGRAMS.
THEY ARE -- GOING TO BE.
READY FOR KINDERGARTEN.
WE STILL DO NEED TO TAKE CARE OF
THE CHILDREN SO PARENTS CAN GO
TO WORK AND SO THE MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS VERY IMPORTANT.
SO AGAIN OUR PRIORITY IS BIRTH
THROUGH.
FIVE OF WE ALSO STRONGLY
STRONGLY SO -- RECOMMENDED THAT
YOU CONTINUE WITH THE HIGH
QUALITY EDUCATIONAL QUALITY
STANDARDS NEVER LOWER THE
STANDARDS TO SERVE MORE CHILDREN.
EVER.
THAT THAT'S I THINK IS -- WOULD
BE A CRIME TO OUR TO OUR
STUDENTS -- WE NEED TO INCREASE
RATES IN ORDER TO GET TO RATE
WAGE PARITY WITH CANDOR KEEP CAN --
TEACHERS FOR ALREADY EXISTING
QUALIFIED STAFF.
THEY ARE ALREADY PROFESSIONAL
THEY'RE ALREADY CORRECT
CREDENTIALED.
AND WE NEED TO STOP PAYING
POVERTY WAGES THESE PROGRAMS.
ARE PROGRAMS THIS THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TITLE FIVE
CENTERS.
ARE BEING SUBSIDIZED ON THE
BACKS OF THE PROFESSIONAL
TEACHERS WHO ARE ACCEPTING LOW
WAGES.
AND I'M THE ONE THAT TOLD YOU
THAT I'VE LOST STAFF TO COSTCO
BECAUSE THEY PAY MORE.
AND THEY OFFER BENEFITS AND
THAT'S THAT'S JUST NOT FAIR FOR
OUR CHILDREN.
AND ONE LAST THING WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT.
I DO NOT BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD
BE SPENDING TEN MILLION DOLLARS
ON ANOTHER PLAN WHEN IT CAN BE
GOING TO INVESTMENTS FOR A
HIGHER WAGES.
SO THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A LOT OF FOOD FOR THOUGHT THERE
I WOULD ASK YOU FROM THE NON LA
PERSPECTIVE.
ABOUT THE ISSUE OF THE NUMBER OF
DAYS YES THAT WOULD THAT WE
SERVE -- KIDS IN THESE PROGRAMS
SELF.
OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE A LITTLE BIT
MORE LEAN AND MEAN.
THAN A SCHOOL DISTRICT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
AND SO HOW IS IT THAT -- CBO
SICK AND CAN FIGURE IT OUT.
BUT SWELLED MAYBE HAVE A TOUGH
WEEK I THINK THE THE ANSWER IS
THEY'VE ALREADY FIGURED IT OUT
BECAUSE SERRA JUST MENTION.
THAT.
SHE RECEIVED FUNDING REQUESTS
FOR A HUNDRED AND NINE MILLION
DOLLARS. TO EXPAND INFANT
TODDLERS WE WE APPLY FOR THOSE
GRANTS DOT I GET THAT HAVE YET I
MEAN THE NUMBER OF DAYS.
THE THE DAYS THE CALENDAR DEAL
WE'RE NOT HONEST WHAT WERE THE
THE FULL DAY PROGRAMS ARE NOT
NECESSARILY ON A SCHOOL DISTRICT
PROPERTY SO WE TAKE EVERYTHING
IT'S A IT'S A IT'S A SCHOOL
WHERE WE TAKE CARE OF THE
CUSTODIAL THE INSURANCE.
THE FOOD WE HAVE KITCHENS ON
SITES WE TAKE CARE OF EVERYTHING
BUT I TELL YOU SERVING BUT THE
NUMBER AGAIN 200- AND THIS ARE
YEP WORKER BUT EVEN FIFTY DAYS
YEAH WE ALSO HAVE LIKE IS THAT
WE DO HAVE A PARTNERSHIP WITH
TWO SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHERE WE
HAVE.
OF THE PART DAY PROGRAMS WERE
WERE A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS.
THOSE CHILDREN ONLY GET THREE
HOURS THEIR BAG OPEN MORE FOR
THE FULL DAY IF YOU IF YOU
LOOKED AT CHULA VISTA SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR SAN DIEGO AND YOU
CAN YOUR AREA AND I'M SURE THEY
HAVE THE SAME.
THEY'RE CLOSING THEIR FULL DAY
PROGRAM SEEM ISSUES WE HERE AT
OUR WEST CONTRA COSTA SO ARE
THEIR WAGES.
DIFFERENT ARE THERE YEAH AND IF
IT'S DIFFERENT YEAH WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE THERE YOU WALK ME
THROUGH THE ISSUES SO.
SO SCHOOL DISTRICTS SALARIES ARE
BASED ON CONTRACTS AND THEY HAVE
THE SAME BENEFITS SO I THINK IN
SAN DIEGO UNIFIED THE PACKED.
A CAREER KAREEM IF HE'S STILL
HERE I THINK IT'S ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS AS A
BENEFIT PACKAGE AS A NON PROFIT
AND THE CBO.
LIKE I SAID INSTEAD OF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUBSIDIZING.
THE SALARIES NOBODY IS AND SO WE
HAVE TURNED OVER AND WE PAY
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR WITH NO BENEFITS WAS AT THE
HEART OF THE ISSUE IS THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE NOT PAYING COSCO
WAGES.
RIGHT NO THEY YEAH YEAH THAT'S A
POINT PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
WAGES WE HAVE THIS DILEMMA WERE
IT SQUEEZES -- THE BUDGET TO
MAKE IT AFFORDABLE FOR THOSE
NINE HUNDRED FORTY CALENDAR DAY
SELL RIGHT SO.
DO YOU RECOMMEND THAT THAT THAT
WE DO DODD WELL THANK YOU SURE
WE HAVE THE L. A.'S HATE LOWER
WELL ADEQUATELY.
NO.
NOTHING WE NEED WE HAVE HOW DO
WE FIX THIS ISSUES TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
ELLIE AIDS CAN ALSO HAVE A
FINANCIALLY VIABLE YEAR ROUND OR
DO WE I I DON'T KNOW THE DATES
YEAH I DON'T KNOW IF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS CAN BE USABLE THE I'M
NOT GOING TO SPEAK FOR THEM BUT
I DON'T THINK THAT'S THE
BUSINESS UP THERE IN IS TO DO
ALL.
DAY YEAR ROUND CHILD CARE.
SO I DON'T I I DON'T KNOW BUT I
IN OUR TOWN THE A LOT OF THE
MARK ARE CLOSING THE FULL DAY
AND THEY'RE KEEPING THE PART DAY.
MORE COST EFFECTIVE -- BUT THEY
ALL ARE THEY ARE ALSO
SUBSIDIZING THE SALARIES FOR US
WE I WAS ON THE RATES COMMITTEE.
AND THAT WHITE PAPER REAR
CLEARLY SAYS HOW WE CAN SOLVE
THE RATES ISSUE SO THAT OUR
TEACHERS COULD EVENTUALLY GET TO
THE SAME LEVEL OF KINDERGARTEN
SALARIES.
SO THAT'S WHERE I WOULD TO A
THAT'S WHERE.
I WOULD PUT THE MONEY RATES
FIRST.
AND THEN SLOTS AND FACILITIES
TOGETHER IN.
I NOT MAKE YOU THINK IF HE HAD
THE RATE REFORM WITH THE HIGHER.
RATE YOU'D BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE THE THE NUMBER OF DAYS THAT
ELEAZAR.
YES FROM MY ORGANIZATION WE PUT
IN A REQUEST FOR SEVENTY THREE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS I HAVE THE
FACILITIES READY TO GO.
LITTLE BIT A RENOVATION AND WE
PUT IN FOR FOUR HUNDRED STATE
PRESCHOOL STUDENTS FULL DAY YEAR
ROUND.
OKAY SO THAT'S WELL THE FULL DAY
PROGRAM IS HIGHLY NEEDED PARENTS
ARE NOT LOOKING FOR YOU.
AND WE HAVE A LONG WAY AT LEAST.
SO I BELIEVE THAT.
DISTRICTS NEED FULL DAY PROGRAM
IS JUST A NUMBER OF DAYS AND IF
WE LOOK AT THE LAW THE LAW IT
SAYS THAT YOU CAN NEGOTIATE.
THE NUMBER OF DAYS YOU CAN
PROVIDE.
SO INSISTENT ON THOSE TOMORROW
FOUR TO SIX DAYS.
IT'S IT'S THAT'S WHY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE NOT LOOKING.
FOR THE CRACKED BECAUSE THERE IS
NO SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT CAN
PROVIDE THAT DOES NOT IN THE
BEST IT CAN PROVIDE HISTORICALLY
TO ONE DAYS.
YEAH THE ACT AN **** SALARIES MY
THAT'S A JOB THAT PAID YOU KNOW
JUST LIKE ANY OTHER TEACHER LIKE
A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER IT DEPENDS
ON YOUR QUALIFICATION BECAUSE
THEY HAVE THEIR CREDENTIAL AND
THEY HAVE THE AC UNITS.
SO THEY'RE HIGHLY PAID THE
PROBLEM THESE ALL THE MONEY THAT
WE GET FROM THE STATE GOES
TOWARDS SALARIES AND BENEFITS.
AN INDIRECT COSTSO YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO BUY -- TO
SEND THEM A PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT THE KRS FUNDING.
COMES IN AND THAT'S WHAT WE'LL
BE USING TO BUY MATERIALS ARE
ALSO TO DO PT'S.
THAT'S HOW AND BEEN ABLE TO DO
THAT [inaudible]
OKAY.
SO WITH THAT WHAT WOULD A
DIFFERENTIAL.
PHOEBE APPROPRIATE FOR ELEAZAR
TO PROVIDE THAT THIS SUMMER.
YEAH.
I THINK THAT.
IT DOESN'T REALLY MAKE SENSE TO
TO HAVE.
THE PARTICIPANTS.
BE WITH YOU FOR TEN MONTHS AND
THEN -- GO ACROSS THE STREET TO
THE CBO FOR THE OTHER TWO MONTHS
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE.
YOU KNOW ONE YEAR LATER WHEN
KIDS ARE IN KINDERGARTEN OR T.
K..
YOU DON'T HAVE THE FOUR YEAR YOU
DO THAT THAT THIS ORDER NUMBER A
DAY YEAH WE SELL WE HAVE FULL OF
FOOD AND A FULL WILL NOT TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SIX DAYS NO I MEAN
I TOSS MY POINT.
SO ONE YEAR LATER.
THE PARENTS ARE DEALING WITH
THAT THE THAT THE ISSUE OF
HAVING THIS ORDER NUMBER DAY BUT
ALSO YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
BENEFITS.
ARE YOU PREPARING KATE TO TO
REDUCE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP ARE
YOU PROVIDING DAYCARE SO YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE BENEFITS SO
IF YOU'RE GOING TO PROVIDE.
YOU KNOW LIKE.
A RIDGES THAT SHIPMENT GAP I DO
ALSO LEAD TO PROVIDE -- HE'S
WITH THE KINDERGARTEN READINESS
SKILLS THEN YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
IT IT'S IS A DAYCARE BY YOU WANT
OR IS THE DO YOU WANT THE KIDS
TO BE REDEEMED.
BY THOUGHT GREAT SO HAVE TO
WEIGH THE BENEFITS GET.
AS THE GOOD QUESTIONS THANK YOU
SOMEONE MEMBER LIMóN.
THANK YOU AT WHAT.
YOU'VE BROUGHT UP A LOT OF THE
BOTH OF YOU AND IN PREVIOUS
PANEL -- HAVE BROUGHT UP A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT GO HAND IN
HAND THE STATE HAS CLEARLY MADE
AN INVESTMENT -- I GET IT NOT
ENOUGH -- ON THE NUMBER OF SPOTS
BUT WE'VE ALSO NOW IDENTIFIED
THAT THERE'S GREATER SUBSTANTIAL
CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN IN TERMS OF WHETHER IT'S
DAY LONG THE TRAINING IS IT
SYSTEM WIDE OR YOU KNOW -- AND I
SAID A WORD THAT I ACTUALLY
DON'T KNOW IF THEY COULD EXIST.
IS THERE A SYSTEM -- STRUCTURE
IN PLACE NOW TO HAVE THE WORK
FORCE HAVE A LARGER STATEWIDE
CONVERSATION ABOUT ALL OF THESE
ELEMENTS RELATED TO SPACE.
RELATED TO THE THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FACILITIES
RELATED TO DAY LONG NOT THE LONG
THE TRAINING THE WORK FORCE I
MEAN.
I AM VERY CONCERNED THAT.
WE INVEST IN THE NUMBER OF SPOTS.
AND WE FIND OURSELVES NOW WITH
THE CHALLENGE THAT WE DON'T HAVE
ENOUGH PROVIDERS BECAUSE AS
YOU'VE FOR CHILD CARE AS YOU'VE
SAID.
COSTCO PAYS MORE -- AND TO WORK
WITH A LITTLE HUMAN BEING IS
MUCH HARDER -- THEN YOU KNOW.
OTHER JOBS -- IN SO WHAT SYSTEM
OR STRUCTURE EXIST IS IN PLACE
AT THE MOMENT TO ADDRESS THIS.
WELL I I THINK THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION JUST CAME OUT WITH A
REPORT THAT.
GIVES US ALL THE ANSWERS ON HOW
WE MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT
INVESTING IN EARLY EDUCATION.
FROM NOW ON THE CURRENT MIX
DELIVERY SYSTEM -- IT IS WORKING
FOR WORKING FAMILIES EXCEPT FOR
THE FAT AND AND THE TITLE FIVE
PROGRAMS WHICH WERE BOTH TITLE
FIVE PROGRAMS A SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND CBO -- SO THOSE ARE THE ONES
THAT ARE ARE EDUCATING THE
CHILDREN.
THE ISSUE IS -- RATES TO
INCREASE [inaudible]
THE WAGES.
OUR STAFF THEY THEY ARE
ACCEPTING LOW WAGES BUT THEY ARE
THEY ARE CREDENTIALED AND
PROFESSIONAL MANY OF THEM MOST
OF THEM THE MAJORITY OF MY
TEACHERS HAVE THEIR BACHELOR'S
DEGREES.
SO YES WE DO ANNUAL PAT OF A
PROFESSIONAL GROWTH -- WE ARE
PART OF THE Q. R. S. SYSTEM
WHICH IS OF VERY EXCELLENT
RATING SYSTEM THAT -- IF YOU GET
TO A FOUR FIVE YOU ARE THAT'S A
QUALITY PROGRAM THAT THESE
CHILDREN ARE IN.
WHICH IS WHICH IS WHAT.
OTHER RESEARCH IS SAYING THEY
NEED TO BE IN.
SO INCREASE IN THE RATES AND
THEN FACILITIES AND THEN SPOTS.
OKAY WELL FOR ME AS I STILL
BELIEVE THAT IF YOU GUYS REALLY
WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON WE
NEED TO GO.
AND ASK PEOPLE WHO ARE REALLY IN
THE FIELD.
BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN DOES ME YOU
RECITE CHEESE FROM DOES ASK IN
THE FEW PEOPLE WHO NEED TO
ACTUALLY GO AND MEET WITH PEOPLE
WHO ARE REALLY DOING THE JOB
BECAUSE THEY'LL BE ABLE TO GIVE
THE FACTS WHAT'S REALLY
HAPPENING.
THAT'S AND I THINK YOU RAISE AN
IMPORTANT AT PEACE TO A I KNOW
CERTAINLY THIS YEAR THERE IS A
CONVERSATION BEING HAD IN THE
LEGISLATURE -- THROUGH A BILL --
THAT WOULD DO THIS HOW DO WE GET
THE WORK FORCE AT THE TABLE IN A
MORE SYSTEMIC WAY I THINK THAT
AT YOU KNOW WHAT ECHOES IN MY
MIND IS -- SOMETHING THAT I
THINK WILL BE REPEATED.
ON MORE THAN JUST THIS OCCASION
IN THIS HEARING WHICH IS THAT
CHILD CARE WORKERS MAKE LESS
THAN ACOSTA WORKER -- AND I A
HOPE AND THAT AS WE HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION WE CAN ALSO -- WE
CANNOT IGNORE THAT THE WORK
FORCE HAS GOT TO BE AT THE TABLE
WE CANNOT IGNORE THAT WE CAN
INVEST ALL KINDS OF MONEY -- IN
SPOTS BUT IF WE DON'T HAVE A
WORK FORCE THAT CAN KEEP UP WITH
THE DEMAND AND THE NEED WE WERE
FAILING OUR KIDS.
WE ARE FAILURE KIDDING AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT IS --
UNBELIEVABLY IMPORTANT I THINK
WE'VE HEARD A NUMBER OF REASONS
THAT THIS ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE
WORK FORCE ITSELF THIS IS ABOUT
WHAT'S GOOD FOR KIDS -- AND WE
HAVE A MAJOR QUESTION IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO ASK DO WE JUST
WANT CHILD CARE OR DO WE WANT
THESE KIDS TO BE READY FOR
KINDERGARTEN AND FOR SCHOOL --
AND THAT THOSE ARE NOT THE SAME
THING AND THOSE ARE ABSOLUTELY
NOT THE SAME THING -- I THINK WE
ARE CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO DEMAND
A GREATER WHICH IS TO PREPARE
OUR KIDS FOR KINDERGARTEN AND
FOR SCHOOL -- AND IN THE ONLY
WAY TO DO THAT IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A WORK FORCE THAT'S
READY THAT'S WILLING THAT AT THE
TABLE TO HELP US.
I DO YOU KNOW SOLVE SOME OF
THESE ISSUES THAT ARE GREATER
THAN THE LEGISLATURE THAT WE
WON'T BE ABLE TO COVER ANY
HEARING WE WON'T BE ABLE TO
DETERMINE -- WHAT THE NEEDS ARE
WHAT THE IMPACT LOOKS LIKE
BETWEEN A HALF -- TO FOR THE
FULL DAY -- WITHIN THE REGIONS
OF CALIFORNIA -- SOME YOU KNOW
AS WE HEARD.
I THINK.
YOU KNOW THE CHAIR BUT THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE -- TALK
ABOUT THAT THE BIGGEST NEED IS
IN LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES -- FOR
FULL DAY PRESCHOOL A FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN.
WE HAVE TO START EVEN BEFORE
THAT HOW YOU KNOW WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO ADDRESS THAT SO I HOPE
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE WILL DO
THAT -- I I KNOW THAT I FOR ONE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THESE
CONVERSATIONS GO HAND IN HAND
AND NOT ISOLATE THE
CONVERSATIONS I'M A BUT THEY
HAVE TO GO HAND IN HAND BECAUSE
IF WE DO AN INVESTMENT AND WE
DON'T HAVE THE WORK FIRST THAT'S
ABLE.
AND HAS THE CAPACITY TO KEEP UP
WITH THE DEMAND OR NEED -- I I
DON'T THINK WE ARE SERVING --
THE KIDS THAT CALIFORNIA KIDS
THAT OUR FUTURE AND THE KIDS
THAT DESERVE AT TO BE FULL SERVE
TO THE FULLEST IN THE STATE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT WAS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I KNOW YOU
HAVE TO GO WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA
TALK ABOUT THE NEXT IN THE WORK
FORCE -- AGENDA ITEM BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT THAT TO PROFESSIONAL EYES
WORKFORCE I'M I'M FULLY SUPPORT
THAT AND WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT LEGISLATION BUT THE OTHER
PIECE OF OF OUR THREE BILL.
PACKAGE WHICH IS HANNAH HAND
WITH HIS PROPOSAL WHICH I KNOW
YOU SUPPORT AS WELL.
IS IS TALKING ABOUT A
PROFESSIONAL IN THE WORK FORCE
AS FAR AS COMPENSATION AND AND
MAKE SURE IT'S NOT JUST IN AND
OUT IT'S NOT JUST COSCO WAGES
IT'S AN OUT FOR AGES.
AND SOME OF THE WORKERS QUALIFY
LITERALLY FOR THE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY'RE SERVING.
THE KIDS AND SELL JUST MAKES YOU
SCRATCH YOUR HEAD.
AND IT'S MAKE IT'S MAKING SURE
THE PROGRAMS ARE -- ARE VIABLE
AND BRINGING UP THE QUALITY
STANDARDS AND SO PART OF OUR
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION IS ALSO
PART OF A LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE TO
LOOK AT HOW WE CAN STREAMLINE
AND SIMPLIFY.
THE RATE STRUCTURES BUT ALSO
RAISE THE RATES AS WELL AS
IMPROVE QUALITY AND I THINK THAT
WILL GO A LONG WAY.
IN HELPING THE WORK FORCE --
NOTE.
HELP IN THE WORK FORCE NOT EARN
POVERTY WAGES AND MAKE IT AND
NOT HAVE SO MUCH TURNOVER.
IMPROVE QUALITY BUT ALSO MAKE
THE PROGRAMS MORE VIABLE SO THEY
DON'T HAVE TO TURN MONEY BACK TO
THE STATE IS RESIDENTS WE TALKED
HALF HOUR ABOUT. THREE THOUSAND
SLOTS UNLESS YOU HAVE THIS THIRD
PIECE THE FIRST PIECE DOESN'T
QUITE.
PENCIL OUT JUST SIMPLE
MATHEMATICS ABSOLUTELY -- SO SO
THIS IS AS AS YOU SAID EARLIER
IS AS EXCITING THAT WERE HIT IN
MARCH IS A POOR MARCH.
MARCH MARCH MARCH.
WE ARE NEVER IN MARCH TALKING
ABOUT TEN THOUSAND IS LOTS ROW
IS NOT TALKING ABOUT IT MAY
REVISE AND WE JAMMED IN THE
BUDGET AFTER THE GOVERNOR COMES
OUT HIS BUDGET SAID TO BE AT
THIS POINT.
WE HAVE A GOVERNOR LEANING IN ON
THIS ISSUE AND TALKING ABOUT
THESE INVESTMENTS AT THIS POINT
THE BUDGET PROCESS IS REALLY
EXCITING -- I KNOW WE'RE TRYING
TO SORT OUT THE DETAILS AND MOVE
PIECES HEARING HERE AND THERE
BUT I THINK THAT WE ARE
CERTAINLY PLEASE THAT WE ARE.
AT THE POINT IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS WHERE WE ARE RIGHT WE
ARE WITH WHERE WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THIS UP.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT -- WE'RE
GONNA HOLD OPEN OF COURSE BUT
WANTED TO GET THE INPUT FROM
PEOPLE ON THE GROUND AS FAR AS
WHAT'S NEEDED TO DO -- THESE
EXPANSIONS IN CALIFORNIA SO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY AGAIN THIS ISSUE NUMBER TWO
AS FAR AS THE PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION IS IS INFORMATIONAL
THIS POINTS AND WILL HOLD THIS
ISSUE OPEN.
SO ISSUE NUMBER THREE IS THOUGH
GOVERNOR'S FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
ONE TIME INVESTMENTS FOR
FACILITIES WORK FORCE AND
PLANNING SO SPRING UP AGAIN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
BELIAU AND DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION [inaudible]
RIGHT
.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN SERRA BURNER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
AND I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE
REST OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSALS FOR EARLY LEARNING AND
CHILD CARE WHEN IT COMES TO
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS.
ON FEES FURTHER PROPOSALS.
ROUND OUT THE OTHER.
THE OTHER PART OF THE PACKAGE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS FOR
EARLY LEARNING IN CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS THIS FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION INVESTMENT IN.
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS IN
CHILDCARE INCLUDES TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A STRATEGIC PLAN THE
STRATEGIC PLAN WILL BUILD UPON
ALL OF THE REST OF THE GREAT
RESEARCH THAT HAS BEEN DONE BY
OTHER ENTITIES.
IN ADDITION TO FILLING IN SOME
GAPS OF DATA AND KNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS ABOUT
THE CHILD CARE SYSTEM AS WELL AS
PROVIDE SOME ACTION WILL STEPS
FOR THIS ADMINISTRATION TO GUIDE.
THEIR DECISION MAKING PROCESS IN
THE FUTURE.
THE QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS ALSO
INCLUDE TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FEES DOLLARS WILL BE
USED TO HELP MOVE CHILD CARE AND
EARLY LEARNING PROFESSIONALS
ALONG THEIR PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT.
CONTINUE ON TO HELP TAKE CARE OF
THEIR EDUCATIONAL NEEDS AS
THEY'RE MOVING UP THE CAREER
LADDER.
AND LASTLY THE LAST TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IS
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE AWARDED
COMPETITIVELY.
TO OUGHT TO NON LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT ARE
SERVING SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE
PROGRAMS -- AND WILL BE USED FOR
AT NEW CONSTRUCTION OR
RETROFITTING EXISTING BUILDINGS
THANK YOU.
A FAIR CORTEZ WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
I'LL BE SPEAKING FROM THE SAME
HAND OUT I WAS I SPOKE FROM
EARLIER -- AND THIS TIME ALL
START ON PAGE ELEVEN OF
PROVIDING JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THE WORK FORCE
FACILITY ISSUES IN PLANNING ON
THAT THE GOVERNOR IS PROPOSING.
I'M SO CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
WORKERS MEETS OR AN EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THESE VERY BY THE
PROVIDER AND THE POSITION THAT
THE EMPLOYEE HOLDS -- UNTIL WE
DON'T HAVE A TON OF INFORMATION
ABOUT PROVIDER ABOUT FACILITIES --
CHILDCARE FACILITIES BUT FROM
OUR CONVERSATION IN THE FIELD --
WE HAVE TO READ COMMENTS WITH WE
WE THINK THERE'S THREE COMMON
FACILITY ARRANGEMENTS THIS WOULD
BE AT LEAST A SUBSIDIZED RATE
WHERE THERE'S A PROVIDER --
WORKING WITH THE PUBLIC ENTITY
AND GIVING OF THE PROVIDER --
GIVING THE PROVIDER SUBSIDIZE
REACHES ONE DOLLAR FOR THE YEAR
TO POP THE FACILITIES ON THAT
LAND OF PROVIDERS ALSO LEASE AT
MARKET RATES SO THEY'RE PAYING --
THEY'RE PAYING THIS MARKET RATES
AND THEN THEY ALSO OWN COULD
THERE EITHER PAYING A MORTGAGE
OR THEY PAID OFF THEIR MORTGAGE.
ON PAGE TWELVE A WE OUTLINE
SEVERAL OF THE PLANNING EFFORTS
THAT HAVE HAPPENED -- IN PRIOR
YEARS AND ALSO SOME THAT IS
FORTHCOMING ALL JUST HIGHLIGHT --
TO TWO OF THESE THE FIRST IS THE
THE FIRST BULLET IS THE BLUE
RIBBONS COMMISSION THE ASSEMBLY
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION ON EARLY
EDUCATION EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION.
THEY BEGIN MEETING IN MARCH
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND RECENTLY
RELEASED A DRAFT SET OF
RECOMMENDATIONS ON IMPROVING THE
SYSTEM.
A LITTLE ALSO HIGHLIGHT ON THE
THIRD BULLET WHICH IS THE PRE
SCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT THE
STATE WAS RECENTLY ORDERED
FEDERAL FUNDS-- TO DO SOME
PLANNING EFFORTS OF FOR CHILDREN
BIRTH THROUGH AGE FIVE AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO
PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOTABLE IN
PLANNING EFFORTS THE HAVE A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT AND A STRATEGIC
PLAN -- PAGE THIRTEEN HIGHLIGHTS
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ALREADY WENT THROUGH THIS SO
WE'LL SKIP ON TO PAGE FOURTEEN
FOR WE HAVE OUR ASSESSMENT ON
THESE.
PROPOSALS A ONE THING WE WE KNOW
IT IS THERE IS A LACK OF
INFORMATION AND SOME OF THESE
AREAS -- AND THE STATE'S LACK OF
DATA MAY RESULT IN THE STAVING
UNABLE TO PRIORITIZE FUNDS AND
USE THESE FUNDS IN A IN A TARGET
WAY.
I WANT EXAMPLES WITH THE WORK
FORCE PROPOSAL -- THEY DO THEY
DO INTEND TO INCREASE
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT OF
WORKERS BUT IT'S BUT ARE THE
DATA DO WE DO HAVE IS HARD TO
IDENTIFY THE GEOGRAPHIC REGIONS
WHERE.
SOME OF THE WORKERS DON'T HAVE
THE THE EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT
THAT THIS THIS WHAT ON WHATEVER
STATE WHATEVER GOAL THE STATE
WOULD WANT TO SET.
WITH REGARD TO FACILITY
PROPOSALS WE DON'T HAVE
INFORMATION ON WE DON'T HAVE
INFORMATION ON FACILITY
ARRANGEMENTS AND THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES THAT PROVIDER SPACE.
AND WE ALSO THINK THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S -- STRATEGIC PLAN THE
TEN MILLION PROVIDED FOR
PLANNING PURPOSES IS DUPLICATIVE
OF RECENT EFFORTS -- AND
FORTHCOMING EFFORT AND WOULD
LIKELY BE REDUNDANT OF SOME OF
THE SOME OF THE WORK THAT IS
CURRENTLY DONE.
OR IN PROGRESS.
MOVING ON THE PAGE FIFTEEN WE
HIGHLIGHT OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND WE SUGGEST THAT THE STATE OF
COULD SET ASIDE SOME FUNDING.
SO CREATE A NEW A NEW ACCOUNT A
CHILD CARE IMPROVEMENT A COW AND
THE STATE IN THIS ACCOUNT COULD
PUT MORE OR LESS FUNDING AND
THEN THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION --
AND WE DO SUGGEST THAT INSTEAD
OF FUNDING THE TEN MILLION
DOLLAR PLANNING THAT THE STATE
OF SPECIFIED TO SPECIFIC STUDIES
ONE IS ON BETTER UNDERSTANDING
FACILITY ARRANGEMENTS AND THE
OTHER WOULD.
WOULD BETTER UNDERSTAND A
FAMILIES.
WITH BETTER UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS
OF THE CHILD CARE NEEDS OF
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES -- AND AND
THEN ONCE THE STATE HAS BETTER
INFORMATION WITH THE FORTHCOMING
INFORMATION ON FROM THE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT THERE'S ALSO A A
SURVEY COMING OUT FROM OF A
SERVING WORKFORCE -- FIRST
BECAUSE EDUCATE WORKFORCE --
EDUCATION -- WHAT'S WE HAVE ALL
THOSE STUDIES AT THE STATE COULD --
DESIGN A VERY TARGETED AND A
VERY TARGETED ONE TIME FUNDING
PROGRAM.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
GOOD MORNING MA'AM MY NAME IS
KIND JACKSON ON BEHALF OF STATE
SUPERINTENDENT TONY THURMOND.
THE SUPERINTENDENT IS GRATEFUL
THAT THE GOVERNOR IN ADDITION TO
IS THE STORK INVESTMENT IN
ACCESS IS ALSO PROPOSING SOME
MUCH NEEDED INVESTMENTS IN OUR
EARLY LEARNING CARE SYSTEM.
WE ARE HAPPY TO SEE THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S RECOGNIZING THE NEED
FOR INTENTIONALITY AS WE EXPAND
ACCESS TO EARLY LEARNING CARE.
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITMENT OF
RESOURCES TO FURTHER EXPLORE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE WAYS TO SERVE OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS.
THE DEPARTMENT IS BIG ALREADY
BEGUN MUCH OF THIS WORK USING
FEDERAL PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT
GRANT FUNDS AND IS DEDICATED
STRATEGIC PLANNING PROCESSES AS
A PART OF THAT GRANT.
THE GOVERNOR STAFF IS HEAVILY
ENGAGED IN THIS PDG STRATEGIC
PLANNING PROCESS AND THAT WORK
IS ALSO BUILDING UP.
UPON THE WORK OF THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSIONS DRAFT REPORT AND
OTHER RECENT REPORTS.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WILL TAKE
[inaudible]
TAKE.
THE PROPOSAL WILL TAKE WHAT WE
HAVE DONE THROUGH THE PDG
STRATEGIC PLANNING PROCESS AND
GO DEEPER INTO THE
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES IN SEVERAL
KEY AREAS.
WE ALSO APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S
WISDOM IN RECOGNIZING THAT
TACKLING ISSUES AROUND
FACILITIES AND THE WORK FORCE
WILL BE ESSENTIAL TO SUPPORTING
INCREASE ACCESS INTO ENSURING.
THE QUALITY OF SERVICES ARE SUCH
THAT CALIFORNIA'S EARLY LEARNING
CARE SYSTEM CAN PROVIDE RICH
LEARNING EXPERIENCES RESPONSIVE
INTERACTIONS IN A SAFE AND
ENGAGING ENVIRONMENT.
AT THIS TIME I WILL NOW TURN
OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE SERRA NEVER
MORGAN AND SHE WILL GO DEEPER
INTO FACILITIES AND WORKFORCE
PROPOSALS.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS MY MY COLLEAGUE
MISTER JACKSON MENTIONED WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT GOVERNOR
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS AND
FACILITIES AND WORK FORCE.
AND HIS DESIRE FOR
INTENTIONALITY AS WE EXPAND THE
SYSTEM.
BEFORE I DIVE INTO THE WORK
FORCE AND FACILITIES I WANT TO
QUICKLY MENTION THAT I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE ON THE PRESCHOOL
DEVELOPMENT STRATEGIC PLANNING
PROCESS.
AND HIGHER HOW WE'RE TYING THAT
INTO THE BLUE RIBBON BUT I'M IN
A REALLY FOCUS MY REMARKS ON THE
WORK FORCE AND THE FACILITIES.
AS I MENTIONED ON THE LAST PANEL
TACKLING FACILITIES IN WORKFORCE
ISSUES WILL BE ABSOLUTELY
ESSENTIAL TO SUCCESSFULLY EXPAND
QUALITY EARLY LEARNING CARE AND
PROMOTE THE CHILD OUTCOMES
NEEDED. TO ADDRESS THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AS WE DIVE INTO THE WORK FORCE
ISSUES WE KNOW THAT THE
RESPONSIVENESS OF CHILD ADULT
INTERACTIONS IN THE EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE ENVIRONMENTS
ARE MAJOR PREDICTOR OF CHILD
OUTCOMES.
SO FOCUSING ON THOSE ADULTS
THOSE EARLY EDUCATORS AND
PROVIDERS IS ACTUALLY THE MOST
CRITICAL PART OF ANY SORT OF
EXPANSION.
WITH THAT WE WILL ALWAYS SAY
THAT BEFORE WE DIVE INTO THEIR
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND SO ON
HIGHER ED.
PORTIONS OF DEGREES THAT WE HAVE
TO FOCUS ON THAT COMPENSATION
AND ENSURING THAT THERE
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED RESEARCH
TELLS US THAT 58% OF CHILD CARE
WORKER FAMILIES.
PARTICIPATE IN ONE OR MORE
PUBLIC INCOME SUPPORT PROGRAMS
THESE TEACHERS MAKE A FRACTION
OF WHAT KINDERGARTEN TEACHERS
MAKE AND SAID THEY THEMSELVES
DON'T HAVE THE MONEY AND SUPPORT
TO GET THE COURSE WORK AND
TRAINING NEEDED.
WE ARE SO GRATEFUL THAT THE
GOVERNOR HAS RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF IMPROVING QUALITY
BY INCREASING THE KNOWLEDGE AND
COMPETENCIES OF THE WORK FORCE.
WERE ALSO GRATEFUL THAT IT%
RECOGNIZES THAT THEY WILL NEED
FINANCIAL SUPPORT IN ORDER TO BE
SUCCESSFUL WITH THAT.
SO AS WE DIVE AND WE HAVE A LOT
OF LESSONS LEARNED OVER THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS FROM A LOT OF THE
QUALITY PROJECTS THAT WEHAVE
FIND DEAD.
THROUGH OUR CCD AFTER A CHILD
CARE DEVELOPMENT FIND QUALITY
PROJECTS WE HAVE SOMETHING
CALLED AB TWO TWELVE OR THE
CHILD CARE RETENTION PROGRAM AND
THERE'S ALSO BEEN SOMETHING THAT
FIRST CALIFORNIA'S FUNDED IN THE
PAST FIRST FIVE CARES. THREE
THOSE WORKFORCE EFFORTS AS WELL
AS OUR QUALITY COUNTS CALIFORNIA
QC SEE QUALITY RATING
IMPROVEMENT SYSTEM MARK WE'VE
LEARNED LESSONS THAT WE WOULD
LIKE TO KEEP IN MIND AS WE MOVE
FORWARD.
AND I WILL STRESS OVER AND OVER
THAT BEING INTENTIONAL AND
ENSURING THAT SUPPORTS FOR THE
WORK FORCE -- ACTUALLY COR SO WE
LEARNED ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADVISERS IN CARES WHAT WAS
SUCCESSFUL PART FOR PARTICIPANTS
WAS IT THAT DAY MATT WITH AN
ADVISER TWICE A YEAR WHO HELPED
THE MAP OUT AN INTENTIONAL
PROFESSED ARE LEARNING JOURNEY.
AND ADVISE THEM ON WHAT
TRAININGS AND COURSE WORK TO
TAKE THIS ALSO HELP THEM FILL
EXTREMELY VALIDATED IN THEIR
PROFESSION AND ACTUALLY IN THE
RESEARCH THEY SHOW THAT THE
ADVISER AND THAT VALIDATION WAS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN ANY OTHER
PART.
OF THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SUPPORTS.
HAVING COURSE WORK THAT DEVELOPS
KNOWLEDGE AND COMPETENCIES IS
ALSO KEY SINCE SO MUCH OF
PROGRAM QUALITY DEALS WITH
IMPROVING ADULT CHILD
INTERACTIONS.
THAT COURSE WORK NEEDS TO REALLY
INCLUDE A STRONG PRACTICE AND
SKILL BASE COMPONENT THAT'S BEST
PHONE TO PROMOTE TEACHER
KNOWLEDGE AND COMPETENCIES.
EMBEDDED VIDEO COMPONENTS WERE
EDUCATORS CAN TAKE VIDEO OF
THEMSELVES ON THE FLOOR WITH THE
CHILDREN AND THEN RECEIVE
SPECIFIC FEEDBACK ON THEIR
INTERACTIONS HAS BEEN FOUND TO
BE SUCCESSFUL AND ACTUALLY
CHANGING PROVIDER PRACTICE.
ENSURING LINKED COURSES UNTIL
ONE OF THE TOP AREAS FOR EARLY
EDUCATORS GETTING THEIR CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT GETTING AN A
A OR A BA.
IS THAT I'M GENERAL ADD
REQUIREMENTS ARE MAINLY THE MATH
AND ENGLISH COURSES WE HAVE
FOUND THAT LINKING MATH OR
ENGLISH COURSES TO CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AS A SUCCESSFUL
STRATEGY FOR HELPING THEM.
THERE'S ALSO THE POWER OF
COHORTS AND APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS.
AS PART OF EFFORTS CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTED COURTS IN THE PAST OF
INDIVIDUALS.
TO ACHIEVE DEGREES WE'VE EVEN
HAD FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
GO THROUGH AND GET BACHELOR'S
DEGREES WHEN THEY'VE BEEN
PARTICIPATING IN A COHORT
PROGRAM.
THESE COVERT MODELS HAVE ALSO
BEEN SUCCESSFULLY INTEGRATED
INTO APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THAT INTEGRATE IN AND BAD HIGHER
EDUCATION COURSE WORK WITH ON
THE JOB TRAINING THAT EARLY
EDUCATORS NEED TO DEVELOP THIS
STRONG COMPETENCIES.
AND THEN IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE -- COURSE WORKS ARE
AVAILABLE TO A DIVERSE WORKFORCE
CORE WHEN WE THINK ABOUT
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE SUPPORTS ARE
AVAILABLE IN LANGUAGES OTHER
THAN ENGLISH.
DURING NONTRADITIONAL TIMES AND
ARE HOLDING COMMUNITY LOCATIONS
ON INCLUDING THEIR WORK SITE OR
IT'S SOMETHING LIKE THE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL.
REALLY FOCUSING ON SUPPORTS
AROUND TO A LANGUAGE LEARNERS
HOW TO HAVE INCLUDES A PRACTICE
SAYS.
ADDRESSING ANTI BY S. AND SOCIAL
EMOTIONAL AND TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE REALLY LOOK AT WHO OUR
CHILDREN ARE AND SUPPORT THAT
WHOLE CHILD.
AS WE LOOK TOWARDS EXPANSION WE
REALLY NOTE THAT WILL HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO FOCUS ON THIRTY
THOUSAND NEW CHILDREN IN STATE
PRESCHOOL.
AND FINDING OUT WORKFORCE AND
ENSURING RETENTION THROUGH
ADDRESSING A COMPENSATION REALLY
IS KEY AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT OUR CURRENT
DATE ON THE WORK FORCE IS NOT AS
DETAILED AS WE'D LIKE SO WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
BUT WE WILL ALSO SAY THE NEEDS
ARE SO URGENT AT THIS VERY
MOMENT THAT WE WOULDN'T WAIT TO
INVEST IN OUR WORKFORCE WE KNOW
THAT WE CAN DO THINGS RIGHT NOW
THAT WOULD MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE.
SPEAKING ABOUT DATA BRINGS US TO
OUR FINAL PART AT THIS IN NOT TO
DO ANYTHING YOU ALSO HAVE TO
INVEST IN SOME STATE LEVEL
SYSTEMS.
THE BUILDING OUT DATA SYSTEMS TO
CAPTURE MORE OF THAT WORK FOR
STATE AT ITS CORE.
PROVIDING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND SUPPORT TO WORKFORCE
PROGRAMS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL SO
THAT THEY CAN HAVE THINGS LIKE
COMMUNITIES OF PRACTICE TO SHARE
LESSONS LEARNED AND SUCCESSFUL
STRATEGIES.
AND THEN WORKING WITH A THAT THE
INSTITUTES OF HIGHER ED TO
REALLY MAKE SURE THAT THAT WE
HAVE BETTER ALIGNED PRE SERVICE
EXPECTATIONS THAT WE HAVE
CAñADA PROPERTY PREPARATION
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT TO
CALIFORNIA'S WORK FORCES.
AND FOCUS MORE ON THE
COMPETENCIES AND THE SKILLS
VERSUS THEORETICAL KNOWLEDGE.
CELL FROM NOT ONLY OF INTO THE
FACILITIES PERSON WERE ALSO
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THE WISE
INVESTMENT ENSURING THAT
FACILITIES ARE AVAILABLE AS
FACILITIES AND AVAILABILITY OF
CARE OR INTER TWINED ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
SAID TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF OUR
CAPACITY CHALLENGES CALIFORNIA
HAS ABOUT SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
CHILDREN AGES BIRTH.
THREE TWELVE THAT IS THE RANGE
THAT WE ADDRESS AND ARE
SUBSIDIZED EARLY LEARNING CARE
SYSTEM.
OF THOSE CHILDREN WE ESTIMATE
ABOUT FOUR POINT FOUR MILLION
ARE 68% LIVE IN FAMILIES WHERE
THE PARENTS ACTUALLY NEED CARE.
OF THE CHILDREN NEEDING CARE
ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR MILLION OF
THEM ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
CARE THAT SUBSIDIZED BECAUSE
THEIR INCOME IS THAT 85% OF THE
STATE MEDIAN INCOME OR LOWER.
SAID THAT AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
THAT WE ONLY HAVE ACCESS FOR
UNDER A MILLION CHILDREN AT A
TIME.
SAID JUSTIN THE SUBSIDIZED EARLY
LEARNING CARE WORLD WE HAVE TWO
POINT FOUR MILLION CHILDREN
ELIGIBLE AND YET WE ONLY HAVE
CARE SITES. FOR NINE HUNDRED
NINETY THOUSAND WE KNOW THAT ONE
OF THE FACTORS IS FACILITIES.
AS FACILITIES HAVE DROPPED OVER
THE CAT PAST COUPLE YEARS AND AS
WE'VE ADDRESSED ISSUES AND LACK
OF ACCESS.
AREAS SUCH AS FAMILY CHILDCARE
GROWTH HAS -- RETRACTED AND
DEALING AND SUPPORTING
FACILITIES AND THE WORK FORCE
CAN HELP US EXPAND THE ACCESS TO
CARE THAT IS NEEDED FOR OUR
FAMILIES.
WE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR THE
FACILITIES EXPANSION WITH THE
EXPANSION OF STATE PRESCHOOL
SLOTS.
SAID THAT AS WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD IN WHO GETS THE
PRESCHOOL THOUGHTS EXPANSION
THEY ALSO ARE TYING IT TOGETHER
WITH SOME FACILITY SUPPORT.
KEEP IN MIND THAT THERE'S ALSO
ONGOING INFANT TODDLER NEEDS AND
I NEED TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF OUR
SITES ARE FULL INCLUSION SPACES
SAID THAT WE ARE SUPPORTING
CHILDREN ACROSS THE SPECTRUM.
AS WELL AS INCLUDING SITES
ACROSS THE CITING TYPES OF MIXED
DELIVERY AS WELL AS ALLEY AYE.
I'M AS WE NAVIGATE THESE ISSUES
THERE ARE SOME THINGS TO
CONSIDER AROUND GIVE TO PUBLIC
FUNDS.
WELL WE'LL HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
FUNDS ARE USER MEETING --
KEEPING WITH PUBLIC TRUST AND
THAT THE FUNDS CONTINUE TO
BENEFIT SAID SIZE CHILDREN FOR
AT LEAST TEN YEARS AFTER I GET
THEIR GRANT IS AWARDED.
WE ARE CURRENTLY EXAMINING HOW
OTHER SIMILAR PROGRAMS DO THIS
SUCH AS CHARTER SCHOOLS HEAD
START AND OTHER STATES.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD THE SYSTEM
OUT AN INCREASE ACCESS FOR
CALIFORNIANS CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY OUT THERE WE GOT.
YES I READ ONE MORE HERE.
I'LL START WITH THE WITH THE
QUESTIONS AS FAR AS FACILITIES
AYE AYE.
FULL SUPPORT THAT WE NEED TO
INCREASE.
RESOURCES FOR FACILITIES FOR
ABOUT THE LA A AND THE A AND THE
NON ELLIE I JUST HAD ONE
QUESTION IS A TECHNICAL ISSUE
THAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
WITH OUR PROPOSAL. FOR
FACILITIES.
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S MORE COMMON
TO GET TO GIVE FACILITIES MONIES
TO TO GOVERNMENT ENTITIES SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND SO FORTH ALL.
MOST LIKELY BE AROUND FOR THE
LONG HAUL.
SO.
AND I KNOW WE HAVE THIS
REVOLVING GRANT PROGRAM WHICH
HAD SON -- HOOK ON THE OTHER
LINE HE HAD TO PERFORM IS THERE
ANY CONCERN AT ALL FOR FOR
GIVING GRANTS -- TO NON ELLIE A
ENTITIES FOR FACILITIES AND
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'LL.
BE AROUND DOWN THE ROAD AND WHAT
TYPE OF INSURANCES THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S A
WISE USE OF PUBLIC.
THE PUBLIC BUDGET BUDGETING.
ABSOLUTELY WE CERTAINLY WANT THE
FACILITIES -- MONEY TO BE USED
IN A WAY THAT IS GOING TO HELP
THE REGIONAL.
AND THE REGIONAL PROVIDERS THE
MOST THE ONES THAT NEED.
THE MOST HELP AND THERE IS SOME
MECHANISM WITHIN THE TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE THAT ACCOUNTS FOR
SOME ACCOUNTABILITY FOR GIVING
THE MONEY TO THE NON ELLIE GAYS
WHICH IS THAT IT IS.
BEING PROVIDED OVER FIVE YEARS
WITH IN APPROXIMATELY EQUAL
AMOUNTS AND SO THE IDEA BEHIND
THAT.
IS TO PUT OUT SOME OF THE MONEY
RIGHT NOW AND THEN BE ABLE TO
REASSESS HOW IT'S BEING ABSORBED
INTO THE SYSTEM AND TAKING INTO
ACCOUNT.
IF CERTAIN NON LEDS ARE ABLE TO
TAKE IT MORE EASILY THAN OTHERS
AND ADDRESS THOSE LOOK CAPACITY
ISSUES OVER TIME YEAH.
I GET THAT I KNOW IT'S ROUGHLY
FIFTY MILLION A YEAR FOR EACH
POT SO.
LET'S SAY I'M A PROVIDER AND I
DID AROUND LIKE ROBIN LANE FOR
THIRTY YEARS DOING IN SAN DIEGO
AND YOU GIVE THEM THE GRANT TO
EXPAND YOUR RELATIVELY CONFIDENT
THAT.
THEY'RE GONNA DO YOU KNOW WHY
SEE WHAT HAPPENS UP MY BRAND NEW
PROVIDER WHO LIKE ALL OF US AND
GET A STATE PRESCHOOL BRANDT
GRANT.
OR CONTRACT TO SERVE YOU KNOW
YOUNG YOUNG YOUNGSTERS IN MY
COMMUNITY AND THEN TWO YEARS
LATER LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S
NOT FOR ME.
WE WE PUT THAT MONEY OUT AND AND
SHOULD WE BE CONCERNED ALSO WE
HAVE ANY.
YOU KNOW THE TYPE OF STRINGS
ATTACHED TO MAKE SURE THAT IS IT
A GOOD USE AND A RESPONSIBLE USE
OF AB OF SCARCE PUBLIC DOLLARS.
PLEASE RESERVE YOUR DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WE'VE ALSO HEARD
CONCERNS SIMILAR TO THIS FROM
OTHERS AND WE'RE LOOKING -- TO
KIND OF EXPAND SOME OF THE
ACCOUNTABILITY SECTIONS IN THE
COMING MAY REVISION.
LA A A GROUP BROUGHT THE WITH
THE LA -- ARE JUST THAT BECAUSE
MISERABLE MORGAN -- MENTIONED
EARLIER I THINK THERE ARE SOME --
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT HAVE SOME
SIMILAR TO THAT YOU COULD USE OF
POTENTIALLY MODELS A BIG PART OF
IT DEPENDS ON THE FACILITY
FUNDING IT'S FLEXIBLE SO
SOMETHING LIKE A RENOVATION
MIGHT BE SOMETHING DIFFICULT TO
ADDRESS BUT WE DO HAVE. FOR
EXAMPLE THERE ARE SOME OF BOND
FUNDING FOR CHARTER SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION I BELIEVE THERE ARE
SOME PROVISIONS THERE THAT -- I
THINK IF THE THE CHARTER SCHOOL
CLOTHES DOWN TO THAT FACILITY
WITH THAT.
WOULD BE LIKE A FIRST CALL FOR
IT TO GO TO THE THE DISTRICT
THAT THE AND THE NEIGHBOR TO
THERE MIGHT BE SOME MECHANISM
THAT THINK THEY'RE DEPENDING ON
THE THE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
THESE FACILITY FUNDING OR USE WE
MIGHT HAVE TO COME UP WITH.
OTHER MODEL THIS ONE WORKS MORE
IF THE FUNDING IS FOR A NEW SITE --
BUT THERE ARE OTHER WAYS BUT WE
DO THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
ISSUES THAT YOU'LL WANT.
TO THINK ABOUT AND MAKING SURE
THAT THERE ARE SOME WAYS TO
ENSURE THAT.
IF A PROVIDERS NO LONGER GOING
TO OPERATE THE YOU CAN.
TAKE CONTROL TAKE CONTROL BACK
OF THE FACILITY OR FIND WAYS TO
GET FROM THE FUNDING.
YEAH I THINK THAT'S A A GOOD
NOTION I'VE THOUGHT ABOUT THAT
SAME PIECE AS WELL WITH OUR
PROPOSAL IS TO MAKE SURE
SOMETHING DOES GO WRONG.
THAT IF IT GOES BACK TO THE
PUBLIC -- ENTITY FOR THE PUBLIC
GOOD.
I WANTED TO ASK ABOUT THAT THE
THE WORK FORCE.
I THINK AS WE TALKED ABOUT
EARLIER IN ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN
THE MULLIN SAID THIS IS YOU KNOW
GREATLY NEEDED. TO TO IMPROVE
THAT THE QUALITIES THAT
STANDARDS AND EDUCATION.
LEVEL OF OUR WORK FORCE AND
HOPEFULLY HAND IN HAND WITH THAT
COMES YOU KNOW HIGHER
COMPENSATION -- AND IS IT IS IT
IS IT IS YOUR NOTION TO BE OPEN
ENDED SO.
SO THIS COULD BE AN INDIVIDUAL
GOING -- TO STRUCTURED PROGRAM
AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR AT CSU
OR THE COULD BE -- I GET YOU
KNOW IT.
ANON CREDENTIAL PROGRAM IN IN IN
OTHER TYPE OF WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT WHAT SPECIFICALLY --
DO YOU HAVE IN MIND HERE.
THE WORKFRCE DEVELOPMENT
DOLLARS ARE MEANT TO HELP CHILD
CARE AND EARLY LEARNING
PROFESSIONALS MOVE ALONG THE
EXISTING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT CONTINUUM.
SO THAT CAN INCLUDE THOSE TYPES
OF CLASSES ON THE VARIOUS HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS THAT
WOULD HELP THEM MOVE ALONG.
THAT CONTINUUM SO IT'S OPEN
ENDED SO THAT IT WOULD
NECESSARILY HAVE TO ENROLL IN
YOUR LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR
HIGHER INSTITUTION THERE CAN BE
OTHER.
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
STATE WIDER -- REGIONALLY BASE
THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS.
CERTAINLY THE GOAL IS TO IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF PROGRAMS BY
FOCUSING ON THE WORK FORCE SO
WHATEVER SORT OF TRAINING THAT
THEY WOULD NEED TO HELP THEM
MOVE ALONG THAT THAT WOULD
QUALIFY.
AND YOU'RE OPEN TO IT GOING TO
THE INDIVIDUAL.
AND FOR THE ENTITY THAT GETS
THAT THAT [inaudible]
STATE CONTRACTS. FOR THE
PROVIDER HOW WOULD THAT WORK
LOGISTICALLY.
THE MONEY GOES OUT IN GRANTS TO
LOCAL PARTNERS AND THEN THE
LOCAL PARTNERS WILL DETERMINE
WHICH PROVIDERS AND WITHIN THE
PROVIDERS WHICH INDIVIDUALS
WOULD RECEIVE.
THAT FUNDING IN ORDER TO GET THE
TRAINING THAT THEY NEED.
SO THE PROVIDER COULD GIVE IT TO
SOMEBODY TO ENROLL IN A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
PROGRAM TO GET THERE.
THE C. CREDENTIAL AND THEY PAY
THEIR TUITION AB A STIPEND HOW
THAT ACTUALLY HOW WOULD THAT
WORK I KNOW WE HAVE THE OTHER
PROGRAMS YOU MENTION THAT.
CARES AND AB -- TWO TWELVE ARE
YOU THINKING ABOUT THE SAME
LINES AS WHAT WE'VE DONE BEFORE
IN THE PAST OR WOULD IT BE MORE
FLEXIBLE NOW.
YES THERE HAVE BEEN.
THERE HAVE BEEN A MULTITUDE OF
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THAT HAVE GONE THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO WE
IMAGINE IT WOULD GO OUT VERY
SIMILARLY.
AND THEN IF IF WE ARE TRYING TO
RAMP UP I KNOW THAT'S THE
GOVERNOR'S DESIRES IN THE NEXT
THREE YEARS.
I KNOW THIS IS. FOR FOR EARLY
LEARNING CHILD CARE PROGRAMS AND
PRE K. STATE PRE K. PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS BUT SPECIFICALLY
FOCUSING ON PRESCHOOL IF WE DO
WANT TO WRAP UP AND SERVE ALL.
AS YOU SAID EARLIER -- INCOME
ELIGIBLE LOW INCOME FOUR YEAR
OLDS WITHIN THE NEXT THREE YEARS --
DO YOU THINK THAT THIS IS ENOUGH
MONEY WHEN YOU LOOK AT IT IT'S
REALLY FIFTY MILLION A YEAR OVER
FIVE YEARS.
OR SHOULD WE THINK ABOUT.
PUSHING IT UP FOR THE NEXT. TWO
YEARS IN OTHER WORDS IT IS --
AND IS THERE NOT INFRASTRUCTURE
IN PLACE TO MAKE THOSE LOFTY
GOALS A REALITY.
THESE WORKFORCE DOLLARS ARE JUST
ONE PIECE OF A LOT OF QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE YET TO BE ANSWERED
ABOUT.
HOW THE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
ALIGNS WITH THE OTHER EXPANSION
PROPOSALS THAT WE HAVE SO WILL
WE WILL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION THE FUTURE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
QUESTION MISTER MARKETING NOW
AND THEN I'LL LASTLY ON ON THE
PLAN.
THE GOVERNOR'S PLAN WE WE
APPRECIATE THE LONG TERM
PLANNING ESPECIALLY IF YOU LOOK
AT THE UNIVERSAL -- ASPECT IN
THE FINANCING PIECE THAT'S THERE
YOU KNOW THE RENTAL WE'VE BEEN
TRYING TO SOLVE THIS THERE'S
BEEN A COUPLE BALLOT MEASURES ON
THIS.
THE LAST -- TEN YEARS AND IN
CALIFORNIA AND SO I THINK THAT'S
AN IMPORTANT PIECE JUST WANTED --
IT'S TO ASK -- HOW THIS COULD
POTENTIALLY COORDINATE WITH THE
WORK THE ASSEMBLY TO SPENT TWO
YEARS WORKING ON OUR BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION?
AND THEIR THEIR OTHER EFFORTS AS
WELL SO -- I KNOW THE LAST --
PANELISTS MENTIONED HEY THAT'S
TEN MILLION DOLLARS WE COULD USE
RIGHT NOW FOR FOR QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT SO -- HOW DO YOU
RECONCILE THAT YOU WANT THIS TO
BE VALUABLE BUT ALSO --
RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT OF PLANNING
HAS BEEN HAS BEEN DONE IN IN IN
IN RECENT MEMORY AS PLEASANT AS
RECENTLY AS RIGHT NOW WITH OUR
ASSEMBLY PLANT.
CERTAINLY WE ABSOLUTELY IN
KNOWLEDGE THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN
DONE BY A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ENTITIES INCLUDING THE ASSEMBLY
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION'S FORTHCOMING A NEEDS
ASSESSMENT A STRATEGIC PLAN FROM.
THE PRESCHOOL DEVELOPMENT GRANT
AND THE WAY WE LOOK AT IT IS
THAT WE DEFINITELY KNOWLEDGE
ALSO THAT THERE ARE GAPS OF THE
DATA KNOWLEDGE THAT WE NEED --
THE LA -- HAS ALSO A LOOK AT
SOME OF THEM IN THEIR REPORT AND
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
INFORMATION THAT WE WANT TO BE
ABLE TO COMPILE IN THIS REPORT
ALL THESE OTHER DIFFERENT PIECES
OF RESEARCH.
AND IT GOES A LITTLE BIT FURTHER
TO THERE ARE A LOT OF GREAT
POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS THAT HAVE
COME OUT OF THESE REPORTS AND WE
WANT TO HAVE A STRATEGIC PLAN.
THAT WILL PROVIDE ACTIONABLE
STEPS IN A IN A REAL PLAN TO ACT
UPON.
GOD THESE POLICY RECOMMENDATIONS
AND SORT OF LINK THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS WITH.
A STRATEGY -- IN SIMILAR TO WHAT
YOU SAID EARLIER TO FUNDING IS A
REALLY BIG -- AS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO LOOK AT
AS WELL.
WE WOULD BE VERY INTERESTED TO
LOOK AT A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT WE CAN.
IMAGINE A A FUNDING STREAM THAT
WOULD REALLY WORK FOR ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS INCLUDING
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING STREAMS AND
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS SO
THOSE ARE THE MANY DIFFERENT.
THINGS THAT WE WANT THE
STRATEGIC PLAN TO ACCOMPLISH
OKAY THANK YOU [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YOU'RE LOOKING.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE WILL HOLD
THIS ISSUE OF OPEN AND
APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION.
WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE ISSUE NUMBER.
FOUR OTHER EARLY EDUCATION
PROPOSALS AND WE DO HAVE SOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE COMING AND SHARING THEIR
PROPOSAL SO.
IF YOU'RE WATCHING YOUR FEAR
STAFF IS WATCHING NOW IS THE
TIME TO COME DOWN HERE. TO SHARE
YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON YOUR
PROPOSALS ON EARLY EDUCATION AND
AGAIN WE'RE NOT FUNDING BILLS
HERE WERE THAT'S FOR THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT A
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY IDEA TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THE STATE BUDGET --
NOW NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
SO -- SO WITH THAT IS THE KIND
OF THE CATCH ALL ISSUE -- ITEM
SO WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE LA
JOH THIS ORDER.
K. L. A. L. -- FIRST FIVE THE
CHILD CARE RESOURCE CENTER AND
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD CAL
COALITION AND THEN A PARENT'S
PERSPECTIVE AND THEN PUBLIC
COMMENT.
THERE CORTES LA -- ALSO BE
SPEAKING FROM THE HANDOUT THAT'S
BEING DISTRIBUTED TO YOU RIGHT
NOW -- I WAS ASKED TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE CHILD CARE
AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS I'M SO
STARTING OFF ON PAGE ONE I KNOW
YOU DO IT A TIME OUT REAL QUICK
WE DO HAVE A FEW OF OUR MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WANT TO JUST --
COMING SECOND YOU COME SIT OVER
HERE.
READING.
AND THEN THIS RACE IS GONNA JUMP
IN RIGHT HERE NOW YOU CAN.
AND WE HAVE A A FEW OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT ARE GOING TO BE --
COMING IN RIGHT NOW AND THEN
WE'LL GET BACK TO THE PANEL.
THANK YOU.
WELL I AM SO SORRY I HAD TO
INTERRUPT SERRA.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE A CALL
TONIGHT YES.
SO PROUD OF HER SO SO PROUD OF
DOCTOR SERRA.
WITH THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS BUDGET REQUEST
TODAY I'M PROUD TO ADVOCATE FOR
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. TO BE UTILIZED
FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE SLOTS.
WELL ESTABLISHED RESEARCH SHOWS
THAT HIGH QUALITY EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION PROGRAMS
EQUIP YOUNG CHILDREN WITH THE
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL AND COGNITIVE
SKILLS THEY NEED TO BE READY TO
ENTER KINDERGARTEN.
AND HAVE A BRIGHT FUTURE. FOR
THE MORE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROGRAMMING
PARTICULARLY CHILD CARE PROGRAMS
PROVIDING NECESSARY SUPPORT FOR
STATES WORKING FAMILIES.
HOWEVER FOR WORKING FAMILIES
CHILD CARE IS AN ACCESSIBLE FOR
MANY WORKING FAMILIES CHILD CARE
IS INACCESSIBLE DIFFICULT TO
FIND OR SIMPLY TOO EXPENSIVE.
CALIFORNIA FACES A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF CHILD CARE AND LOW
INCOME WORKING FAMILIES ARE
IMPACTED BY THIS SHORTAGE THE
MOST.
RECENT DATA INDICATES AT ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION CHILDREN ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR STATE SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE BUT DO NOT RECEIVE IT
DUE TO THE LACK OF ACCESS IN OUR
STATE.
THAT MEANS EIGHT OUT OF NINE
CHILDREN WHO ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIZED CARE ARE NOT
RECEIVING IT.
WHILE I COMMEND THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET WHICH PROVIDES
PLENTY OF INVESTMENTS FOR EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION PROGRAMS.
CHILDCARE SUBSIDIES ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE EXISTING
PROPOSAL.
LEAVING CHILD CARE OUT OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION INVESTMENTS
AND EXPANSION WILL MEAN THAT THE
LOWEST INCOME WORKING FAMILIES
WILL STILL NOT TO BENEFIT IT'S
STILL NOT BENEFIT.
FROM EXISTING AND PROPOSED STATE
INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA.
THIS IS WHY I STRONGLY URGE
STRONGLY URGE STRONGLY URGE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE TO APPROVE THIS
REQUEST.
OF ONE BILLION DOLLARS TO BE
UTILIZED FOR GENERAL AND
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT CHILD CARE
SLOTS.
BECAUSE OUR FAMILIES DESERVE
ACCESS TO THE GREATEST SOCIO
ECONOMIC EQUALIZER.
THAT THAT WE CAN PROVIDE.
AND HIGH QUALITY CHILDCARE IS
THAT EQUALIZER.
I WANT TO THANK DONNA SNARE
JUROR WHO IS HERE --
REPRESENTING THE CHILD CARE
RESOURCE CENTER AND MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING
ME TO SPEAK ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC.
OKAY WE WE HEAR THE REQUEST LOUD
AND CLEAR THANK YOU FOR í
REQUEST THANK YOU YES THANK YOU
WE HAVE THAT ON THE LIST OKAY
WANT TO BRING UP ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RUBIO FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN.
MISTER CARTY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE HERE I'VE BEEN FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO SERVE WITH US CULTURE
OF THE ASSEMBLY -- BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILD
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND I KNOW
THAT WE SHARE OF A COMMITMENT TO
MAKING THE BUDGET INVESTMENT
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THE
COMMISSION'S BOLD VISION OF
EXPANDING ACCESS TO QUALITY EAZY
E..
I'M NOT TRYING TO INFLUENCE YOU
IN ANYWAY -- I'D LIKE TO URGE
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF A BY THE
PROPOSAL TO ENSURE THAT MORE
FAMILIES WITH INFANTS AND
TODDLERS HAVE HIGH QUALITY
FAMILY CENTERED CHILD CARE.
AS A FORMER TEACHER I KNOW THAT
WHAT HAPPENS BEFORE CHILDREN
ENTER KINDERGARTEN DURING THOSE
EARLY YEARS.
OF RAPID BRAIN DEVELOPMENT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO THEIR ABILITY TO
SUCCEED IN SCHOOL AND IN LIFE.
I TWO YEAR OLD FROM FAMILIES AND
POVERTY ARE ALREADY SIX MONTHS
BEHIND THEIR PEERS AND LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT HIGH QUALITY INFANT
TODDLER.
AND OUT CARE CAN CLOSE THE
RATING IS GAP FOR THOSE CHILDREN
BEFORE IT BECOMES AN ACHIEVEMENT
GAP -- AS A SINGLE MOTHER I KNOW
THE OF THAT AFFORDABLE CHILDCARE
IS CRUCIAL TO SUPPORTING
FAMILIES WE HAVE A CRISIS RIGHT
NOW IN TERMS OF ACCESS. TO
AFFORDABLE INFANT AND TODDLER
CHILD CARE.
MY ROPOSAL WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO EXIST TO
EXISTING CHILD CARE CENTERS AND
FAMILY CHILD CARE HOMES TO REACH
HIGHER STANDARDS.
BASED ON PROVEN EARLY HEAD START
MODEL.
FIND THE WHAT SUPPORT FAMILIES --
FAMILY SUPPORT SKEWS ME FINDING
WITH SUPPORT FAMILY SUPPORT
WORKERS. TO HELP PARENTS HEALTH
AND DEVELOPMENT SCREENINGS
BETTER TRAIN TEACHERS AND
CONNECTIONS -- TO WELL CHILD
HEALTH AND DENTAL CARE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT THIS KIND OF
COMPREHENSIVE WHOLE CHILD THE
WHOLE FAMILY APPROACH TO CHILD
DEVELOPMENT.
DEVELOPMENT HAS THE BIGGEST
IMPACT ON CHILDREN IN POVERTY.
I ALSO PROPOSED EXPANDING
QUALITY FAMILY CENTERED CHILD
CARE TO TWENTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL INFANTS AND TODDLERS
LIVING IN HIGH NEED.
COMMUNITIES I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH MY COLLEAGUES AND
THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AS WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
MORE SUBSIDIZED CHILDCARE SLOT
FOR A CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES.
AND ALSO LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITHOUT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
FIRST PARTNER WHO INDICATED
THEIR COMMITMENT -- TO THIS
POPULATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION OUR PRIOR PANEL
TALKED ABOUT THE NEED.
NOT JUST FOR STATE PRESCHOOL IN
THREE OR FOUR YEAR THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLD FOR INFANT AND
TODDLER PROGRAMS AND FOR
EXPANDED ROB AROUND WHICH YEAR
ARE PROPOSING.
ON TODAY BUT IT'S GOING TO BE A
LITTLE TOUGH TO THE CUSTOMER
SELECT YES SO YOU MAKE YOUR BEST
SHOT OVER THE PROBES COMMITTEE
BUT HERE YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
YOUR OVERALL BUDGET VISION SO
RIGHT NOT THAT.
OKAY THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MULLIN WAS TO TALK TO US ABOUT.
FACILITIES RESERVE YES HERE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY WOMEN RUBIO.
RADIUS AND AGUILAR CURRY AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS UP WE'RE
PARTNERING ON THIS ISSUE I'M
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED ON THE
FACILITIES PIECE OF THIS --
MISTER CHAIR AS MANY OF YOU KNOW.
DUE TO PERSISTENT UNDER FUNDING
AS A STATE WE SERVE LESS THAN 3%
OF INFANTS AND TODDLERS IN
LICENSED CARE FACILITIES.
I AM VERY ENCOURAGED AS ARE MY
COLLEAGUES -- BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S COMMITMENT TO OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS AND AS
PROPOSAL TO DEDICATE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FIVE MILLION TO BUILD UP
OUR CHILD CARE INFRASTRUCTURE.
CITING RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE
ASSEMBLY SPEAKER SO BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION A REPORT BY THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT ON EARLY
LEARNING FACILITIES.
I AM SEEKING TO ALLOCATE THESE
FUNDS TO THE CALIFORNIA CHILD
CARE FACILITIES REVOLVING FUND
WHILE THE REVOLVING FUND IS
SEVERELY UTILIZE THE INTENT WILL
BE TO LEGISLATIVE WE CONVERT THE
REVOLVING FUND INTO A GRANT FUND.
FOR CHILDCARE FACILITIES I HAVE --
ALSO RECEIVE SOME ENQUIRIES --
AS TO THE NEED FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AMONG PROVIDERS AND
SMALL AGENCIES AND APPLYING
COORDINATED FUNDING AND PROJECT
MANAGEMENT AND THE CAPACITY.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
TO RENDER THAT ASSISTANCE I
BELIEVE THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
WILL PROVIDE AMPLE TIME TO HAVE
POLICY DISCUSSIONS ON HOW TO
QUICKLY AND EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTE
THE FUNDS.
SO WE CAN BUILD THE FACILITIES
NEEDED TO CARE FOR OUR YOUNGEST
LEARNERS WHILE THEIR BRAINS ARE
STILL AT THE PEAK OF DEVELOPMENT.
AND MISTER CHAIR AS AS SOMEBODY
WHO WHAT DID A PROJECT ON LOCAL
INVESTMENT IN CHILD CARE WHICH
WAS A FACILITIES PROJECT IN SAN
MATEO COUNTY BACK IN THE
NINETIES -- CLEARLY WE HAVE NOT
SOLVED THIS PROBLEM AS WE SIT
HERE -- IN TWENTY NINETEEN BUT
HOPEFULLY -- WITH THIS
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP IN THE
LEGISLATIVE -- LEADERSHIP GROUP --
THAT IS PASSION ABOUT THIS ISSUE
WECOULD FINALLY SEE THE
BREAKTHROUGH THAT WE'VE ALL BEEN
HOPING FOR SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
FEDERATION WESTERN CHAIR AND
AGAIN THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES.
THANK YOU AND WE DID SPEND THE
PRIOR -- OUR TALKING ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC ISSUE.
AND YEAR -- PROPOSAL -- CAME UP
AND SO I THINK THAT'S SOMETHING
YOU WILL BE CONSIDERING GREAT
PICTURE [inaudible]
APPLICATION [inaudible]
OKAY.
RIGHT I THINK THERE MAY BE ONE
MORE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON HER WAY
BUT IN THE INTERIM WE CAN.
CERTAINLY GO BACK TO YOUR
PRESENTATION.
GREAT THANK YOU MAY HAVE TO STOP
YOU AGAIN BUT THAT'S ABOUT IT
JUST LET ME KNOW -- SO RESUMING
ON PAGE -- ONE THE STATE SHOWS
THE THE CALIFORNIA SUBSIDIZE
MANY CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS SO THE TOP ONE IN THE
BOTTOM LINE IS CAL WORKS CHILD
CARE TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN --
SLOTS ARE AVAILABLE IN THESE TWO
PROGRAMS FOR ALL ELIGIBLE
CHILDREN THE MIDDLE TO PROGRAMS
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT A GENERAL
CHILD CARE IN STATE PRISONS YOU.
TOO I GOT BOMBARDED WITH PAPER
JUST A MOMENT AGO SO WHAT WHAT'S
THAT CAN HOLD UP WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE SURE.
SO THIS IS -- OVERVIEW LITTLE
CHILD THE SCHOOL PROGRAMS -- SO
WE'RE ON PAGE ONE AND IT'S A
SQUARE WITH THE UP WITH FOUR
PROGRAMS LISTED YES YES.
OKAY SO SO THAT THE THE TOP AND
THE BOTTOM PROGRAM ARE PROGRAMS
WORSE AUTHOR AVAILABLE FOR ALL
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN -- INTO SERVE
ADDITIONAL CHILDREN IN THESE
PROGRAMS THE STATE WOULD HAVE TO
CHANGE ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENT
THE MIDDLE TO PROGRAMS WHICH IS
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM AND
GENERAL CHILD CARE AND STATE
PRESCHOOL THESE ARE.
THESE ARE REFERRED TO AS CAPP
PROGRAMS WERE SLOTS ARE LIMITED
BASED ON ANNUAL BUDGET
APPROPRIATION.
I'M SO SO SERVE ADDITIONAL
CHILDREN IN THESE PROGRAMS THE
STATE WOULD HAVE TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS IN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET.
I'LL MOVE ON TO IS PAGE -- TWO
THIS IS A CALIFORNIA SERVES AN
ESTIMATED FOUR HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND CHILDREN IN ALL
THE CHILD CARE AND PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS THAT THE STATE RUNS.
AND THE SHOWS THE BREAKDOWN.
OF CHILDREN SERVED.
I'M MOVING ON TO PAGETHREE THE
STATE PROVIDES FOUR POINT SEVEN
BILLION IN CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL FUNDS THROUGH A MIX OF
FUN SOURCES AND THESE CAN BE
BROKEN DOWN SIMPLY INTO STATE
FUNDS AND FEDERAL FUNDS.
THE TO FUND SOURCES FOR STATE
FUNDS WOULD BE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND THE
OTHER SOURCES NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
AND THE FEDERAL FUNDS SOURCES
ARE THROUGH CHILDHOOD CHILDCARE
DEVELOPMENT PLAN AND CANIFF
TEMPORARY ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY
FAMILIES.
MOVING ON TO PAGE FOR THE STATE
FUNDS PROGRAMS IN DIFFERENT WAYS
AND THESE CAN BE BROKEN DOWN
INTO VOUCHERS DIRECT CONTRACT
AND LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA.
A VOUCHER PROGRAMS IS WHERE THE
STATE GIVES THE FAMILY A VOUCHER
AND THE VOUCHER AND FAMILIES CAN
SEND THEIR CHILDREN TO A VOUCHER
BASED CENTER -- HE A CHILD CARE
HOME OR FIFTH OR RECEIVE FAMILY
FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR CARE IN THE
STATE RELIES ON SOME REGIONAL
AGENCIES TO ADMINISTER THAT WORK.
DIRECT CONTRACTS IS WHERE THE
STATE.
CONTRACTS DIRECTLY WITH THE
PROVIDER THAT WOULD BE A CENTER --
AND THEY ARE THEY HAVE THEY MAKE
A CONTRACT AGREEMENT TO SERVICE
SPECIFIC SET OF CHILDREN.
AND THE FAMILIES WOULD GO
DIRECTLY TO THOSE -- TO THOSE
PROVIDERS TO RECEIVE THE CARE.
I WILL NOTE THAT THE VOUCHERS
RECEIVE THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE
AND THE DIRECT CONTRACT RECEIVE
THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATE
WHICH WILL GIVE MORE CONTACTS AS
WE GO TO THE NEXT PAGE.
SO PAGE FIVE SHOWS HOW READ
COULD VERY BASED ON IF A
PROVIDERS FUNDED THROUGH THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE OR THE
SCANNER REIMBURSEMENT WE AND WE
ALSO PUT IN THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA JUST TO GIVE YOU
SOME.
SOME CONTEXT OF THE ENTIRE
SYSTEM -- SO THESE VERY BY
PROGRAM SETTING AND BY AGE SO
THIS FIRST -- THE FIRST TWO
LINES GOING DOWN ON THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATES OF THESE ARE THE
PROGRAMS AND JUST TO GIVE SOME
COMPARISON -- THE INFANT THESE
ARE THESE ARE THESE ARE THE
AVERAGE FOR THE REGIONAL MARKET
RATES OF THE THESE RATES ARE
BASED ON ON THE COUNTY -- THAT
THE PROVIDER IS SERVING SO WE'RE
SO.
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATES BASED
ON A SURVEY THAT'S DONE EVERY
OTHER YEAR WE'RE CURRENTLY USING
THE TWENTY SIXTEEN SURVEY AND
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SURVEY WILL
BE AVAILABLE AT THE THE RESULT
IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN SURVEY
WILL BE AVAILABLE ON FOURTH
COMING.
IN THE NEXT MONTH OR SO -- THE
SO THE SECOND GROUP.
THE SECOND SHE WANT -- VEGAS THE
THIRD AND THE FOURTH LINE ARE
THE STANDARD REIMBURSEMENT RATES
AND THIS IS SET -- THIS IS SET
BY THE ANNUALLY BY THE STATE --
IN RECENT -- IN THE LAST BUDGET
THERE WAS RECENTLY AN
AUGMENTATION TO THIS BUT THIS IS
A CONSISTENT RATE ACROSS ALL
ACROSS ALL PROVIDERS AND IT'S
VERY BASED ON SETTING -- AND AGE
GROUP.
AND THAT CONCLUDES MY REMARKS
BUT I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS.
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I FORGOT HIS NECK SO JUST GO
AHEAD OF ME YEAH.
ERIN TOLD ME TO GO FIRST.
GOOD MORNING DONNA SNARE INJURE
IT WITH THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER AND I'M HONORED TO BE
HERE -- AS A REPRESENTATIVE THE
OF THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
COALITION WHICH IS A PARTNERSHIP
OF THIRTY FIVE EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION ADVOCATES ADVOCACY AND
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS WERE
WORKING TOGETHER. TO SECURE
ACCESS TO HIGH QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S LOW INCOME CHILDREN
AND FAMILIES AND I THINK YOU'VE
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO VISIT.
WHEN WE HAVE OUR MEETINGS AND
THERE'S QUITE A QUITE A GROUP?
THAT WE PULL TOGETHER SO.
I'M LIKE EVERYONE ELSE WE ARE
VERY ENCOURAGED BY THE BOLD
INITIATIVES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL AND I THINK IT'S
VERY CLEAR THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION UNDERSTANDS THE
VALUE OF EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES -- I'D
ALSO SAY THAT THEY HAVE
REFERENCE VERY SPECIFICALLY THAT
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE IS A TWO
GENERATION APPROACH PARTICULARLY
EFFECTIVE WITH FAMILIES WHO ARE
IN POVERTY.
AND ACCESS TO THESE SERVICES CAN
MAKE A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE TO
THE FAMILY'S LIFE LONG
TRAJECTORY AND THE SUCCESS OF
THE CHILD IN SCHOOL.
SO I'M WE REALLY FIRMLY BELIEVE
THAT KIDS DO BETTER WHEN THEIR
FAMILIES DO BETTER AND WE LIKE
THAT APPROACH SO THAT FITS IN
WITH A LOT OF THE DISCUSSIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD.
I'M WE BELIEVE THIS BUDGET
STARTS TO CLOSE THE OPPORTUNITY
GAP FOR FAMILIES OF COLOR AND
MAKE SMART INVESTMENTS TO ENSURE
OUR SYSTEM CAN BRING STABILITY
AND CONTINUITY TO OUR MOST
VULNERABLE FAMILIES.
WE CONSIDER THIS BUDGET TO BE A
STARTING POINT AND I THINK WE'VE
BEEN REASSURED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT THEY SEE IT
THAT WAY TOO SO WE SEE THIS IS A
A PATH FORWARD.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT WE REALLY
HAVE PUT TOGETHER A WHOLE CHURCH
THE WHOLE SYSTEM WHOLE FAMILY
WHOLE CHILD APPROACH LOOKING AT
MULTIPLE FACETS THAT WE THINK
ARE IMPORTANT.
AS WE LOOK AT INVESTMENTS IN THE
SYSTEM.
FIRST AND FOREMOST AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GOMEZ REYES ELOQUENTLY
STATED -- WE'VE GOT A REAL GAP
IN ACCESS AND IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT CHILD CARE BE
AVAILABLE FOR CHILDREN ZERO TO
THREE WHERE THE UNMET NEED IS
THE GREATEST AND LARGELY IS
STILL MISSING.
WE NEED MORE CHILD CARE SPACES
FOR THIS POPULATION TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF FOR WORKING
FAMILIES AND TO ENSURE THAT OUR
YOUNGEST CHILDREN RECEIVE A SAFE
AND NURTURING CARE ENVIRONMENT.
I THINK I'M MANY NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN THROWN ABOUT BUT THE ONE
THAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH
MOST IS THE ELIGIBILITY HAVE
FAMILIES THAT ONLY ONE IN NINE
ELIGIBLE CHILDREN IS CURRENTLY
RECEIVING SERVICES.
AND WE REALLY THINK THAT WE
CAN'T WAIT FOR A PLANNING
PROCESS TO START TO MAKE HEADWAY
ON GETTING SERVICES FOR THOSE
FAMILIES.
I WE'RE ALSO VERY FOCUSED ON THE
IDEA OF REIMBURSEMENT RATE
REFORM I THINK YOU HEARD MANY OF
THE CONCERNS ABOUT.
THE COMPLEX AND VARIED A DEAL
MADE A PAUSE [inaudible]
NO.
BY THE POINT BUT YOU GO HEAD
OKAY.
I'LL KEEP GOING I'M SO I WE'VE
BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON THE
PROPOSAL TO LOOK AT REFORMING
THE REIMBURSEMENT RATE SYSTEM
WHICH I'M GOING TO DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE AARON GABLE.
WERE ALSO VERY FOCUSED ON THE
ISSUE OF THE SHORTAGE OF
FACILITIES AND WE KNOW IT'S ONE
OF THE BARRIERS TO DELIVERING AN
EXPANDING ACCESS TO EASY
PROGRAMS WHICH YOU'VE HEARD
QUITE A BIT ABOUT.
WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT WORK
FORCE AND PRIORITIZING CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS AND TEACHERS WHO
PLAY A CENTRAL ROLE IN THE
CHILD'S LIFE.
I THINK WE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
LEARNING IN OUR EARLIER PANELS
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT
FOR VERY YOUNG CHILDREN.
SAFE NURTURING AND CONSISTENT
PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL AND
CHILDREN LEARN THROUGH
RELATIONSHIPS AND THROUGH
ATTACHMENT.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
STRENGTHENED THE EARLY CHILDHOOD
CONTINUE -- IN ALL CARE SETTINGS
WHETHER THAT BE A FAMILY FRIEND
AND NEIGHBOR A FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER.
A TITLE TWENTY TWO LICENSE
CENTER OR TITLE FIVE CHILDREN
ARE IN ALL OF THESE SETTINGS AT
DIFFERENT POINTS IN THEIR LIFE
AND DEVELOPMENT.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
ADDRESS THAT WHOLE CONTINUE ON
WHEN WE LOOK AT WORK FORCE SO
THAT THERE ARE ALWAYS RECEIVING
THE BEST QUALITY CARE WE CAN
GIVE.
I'M I HAD TWO THINGS I WANTED TO
ADD BEFORE I CLOSE ONE WE REALLY
ENCOURAGE -- THE THE COMMITTEE
TO TAKE A LOOK AT THE FEDERAL
CHILD CARE AND DEVELOPMENT BLOCK
GRANT FUNDING WHICH WAS EXPANDED
LAST YEAR.
THE A DECISION IN LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET WAS TO ALLOCATED AS ONE
TIME FUNDING AND CONDITIONS HAVE
CHANGED AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AN
ADDITIONAL MONEY HAS BEEN ADDED
TO THAT FUND.
AND IT HAS BECOME VERY CLEAR TO
US IN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
FEDERAL ADVOCATES.
THAT THIS IS ON GOING MONEY AND
WE NEED TO ADD WE NEED TO
ALLOCATE IT THAT WAY SO WE
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOUR STAFF TO
TAKE A DEEPER LOOK AT THAT.
AND THAT COULD BE MONEY THAT
WOULD BE IMMEDIATE AVAIL
IMMEDIATELY AVAILABLE TO SERVE
MORE CHILDREN.
AND LASTLY WITH RECENT REPORTS
ISSUED BY THE BLUE RED AND
RIPPING COMMISSION OUT EARLY
EDUCATION.
AND THE GOVERNOR MAKING IT CLEAR
THAT THIS IS A TOP PRIORITY WE
WE KNOW THIS IS TIME TO ROLL UP
OUR SLEEVES AND GET TO WORK.
AND WE STAND AS PARTNERS READY
TO WORK WITH ALL OF YOU AS YOU
LOOK AT THE BEST WAY FORWARD TO
BUILD A COMPREHENSIVE SYSTEM
THAT SUPPORTS CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILIES AND THEIR CHILDREN.
OKAY THANK YOU BEFORE WE GET TO
ERIN GAVE THE ONE THAT HAD
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY.
JOIN US TO PRESENT TO US ABOUT.
THE BUDGET IN DC GREAT THANK YOU
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR MY TARDINESS --
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS IN HIS
JANUARYBUDGET PROPOSAL
GOVERNMENT NEWSOME PROPOSED TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR
THE CHILD CARE AND EDUCATION
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
I'M EXCITED ABOUT THIS
INVESTMENT BECAUSE IT RECOGNIZES
THE CRITICAL ROLE CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS IN TEACHERS HAVE IN
CREATING A SAFE AND REACHING
ENVIRONMENT IN CALIFORNIA'S
YOUNG CHILDREN.
MY PROPOSAL TAKES INTO ACCOUNT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM AB TWO
TWELVE AND THE CALIFORNIA EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION WORKFORCE
WORKING GROUP.
MY PROPOSAL CALLS FOR IMPROVING
AND EXPANDING OUR CHILD CARE%
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT SYSTEMS
BY FUNDING.
QUALITY COUNTS CALIFORNIA TO
ENSURE PROVIDERS HAVE ACCESS TO
QUALITY IMPROVEMENT SUPPORT --
THE CUT CHILD CARE INITIATIVE
PROGRAM WHICH HELPS CHILDCARE
PROVIDERS GET LICENSED.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS TO HELP
GROW OUR CHIP CHILD CARE
WORKFORCE AND STIPENDS LIKE THE
AB TWO ONE TWO TWO TWELVE WORK
FAR SCRIPT WORKFORCE GRANTS.
ALL OF THESE COMPONENTS ARE
ESSENTIAL IN SUPPORTING CHILD
CARE PROFESSIONALS IT TO ENTER
THE WORK FORCE AND ADVANCE IN
THEIR CAREERS.
QUALITY EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS RELY ON SKILL SKILLED
AND DEDICATED ADULTS THAT WORK
WITH OUR YOUNG CHILDREN.
I APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR
PROPOSING AN INVESTMENT IN OUR
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
WORKFORCE.
I BELIEVE MY PROPOSAL WILL
ENSURE THAT ALL CHILD CARE
PROFESSIONALS HAVE ACCESS TO
APPROPRIATE TRAINING.
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
ONGOING SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU AND WE SPENT THE LAST --
PANEL TALKING ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL AND HOW IT RELATES TO
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT RIGHT
HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTS ALL OF
YOUR TESTIMONY SAY MEANS A LOT
TO ALL OF US THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OKAY BACK TO YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AARON GABLE
ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA I'M YOUR STATE
COMMISSION ON EARLY CHILDHOOD
AND ALSO THE YOU SEE COALITION
WE WOULD JUST WANT TO ALIGN
OURSELVES WITH ALL OF THE
REMARKS FROM OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
FROM THE C. COALITION.
SO I HAVE BEEN ASKED -- TO TO
GIVE YOU A FIVE MINUTE OR LESS
TALK ABOUT -- WHY CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT HEALTHCARE FUNDING
SYSTEM IS A MESS?
AND HOW IT SHOULD BE RENOVATED
TO STABILIZE OUR CHILD CARE
FIELD AND TO MAKE MORE SENSE IN
GENERAL OKAY.
SO I'M PART OF THE PAIN Là.
FIVE MINUTES YES BY -- AT A TIME
SO I'M PRETTY YOUR PAPER BUT
APARTMENT IF YOU LOOK FOR THE
THE THE COLOR GRAPHS -- FIRST I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHILD
CARE SINGLE RIGHT WORK GROUP WHO
TOILED FOR OVER A YEAR. TO
PRODUCE THE RECOMMENDATIONS
ESPECIALLY OUR CO CHAIRS IN A
BOOTH THE FROM EVERY CHILD
CALIFORNIA AND ON THIS YEAR AND
FOR FOR THE CHILD CARE RESOURCE
CENTER.
AS WELL AS THE GOING PRICE GROUP
WHO SUPPORTED ALL OF OUR EFFORTS --
I HAVE CIRCULATED TO YOU THE
FRUIT OF THEIR WORK WHICH IS THE
TWENTY TWO PAGE DOCUMENT IN THE
BOMBARDMENT OF PAPER UP THERE --
WHICH GOES INTO VERY GREAT JOB
ON THE PROBLEMS OF OUR CURRENT
FUNDING SYSTEM THE PRINCIPLES
BEHIND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS AS
WELL AS GREAT DETAIL ON OUR
PROPOSAL.
WHICH WE ARE CALLING THE CHILD
CARE STABILIZATION FORMULA.
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS A
BIFURCATED REIMBURSEMENT RATE
POLICY. ONE SYSTEM THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE IS BASED ON A SURVEY
OF PRIVATE MARKET CHILD CARE
COST IN EACH COUNTY.
AND FUNDS ARE ABOUT YOUR BASED
CHILDCARE PROGRAMS NAMELY ARE
CAL WORKS TO JUST ONE THREE
THREE AND OUR ALTERNATIVE --
PLACEMENT PROGRAM.
THEN WE HAVE A SECOND SYSTEM
WHICH IS THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE WHICH IS AN
ARBITRARY AMOUNT OF FUNDING PER
CHILD SET IN STATUTE.
THE FUNDS EVERY TITLE FIVE CHILD
CARE CENTER THE SAME AMOUNT
ACROSS THE STATE.
BOTH FUNDING RATES FLOW TO THE
LOCAL CHILD CARE AGENCIES BE A
CONTRACT FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
pAN APPLE TO APPLE COMPARISON TO
MY FIVE MINUTE TIME LIMIT.
I WILL FOCUS ON HOW THE CURRENT
RATE SYSTEM IMPACTS THE HOW THE
CURRENT PROPOSAL IMPACTS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAM AND ITS FUNDING BUT I
WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT OUR
PROPOSAL DOES SPAN THE ENTIRE
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE SYSTEM
UNIFORMLY.
THE FIRST GRAPHIC YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU.
IS A VERY SIMPLISTIC
REPRESENTATION OF HOW THESE TWO
ON A LINE SYSTEMS OF RATES
CURRENTLY WORKS.
ON THE LEFT YOU HAVE A RANGE FOR
THE REGIONAL MARKET RATE THE RMR
WHICH IS UNIQUE TO EACH COUNTY
BASED ON THE RATES PRIVATE
PROVIDERS ARE CHARGING PARENTS
IN THAT COUNTY.
THE CURRENT REGIONAL MARKET RATE
BASED ON A MARKET SURVEY
CONDUCTED IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
THAT'S WERE OPERATING ON AND
WE'RE GONNA SEE PROVIDERS
EARNING BETWEEN FORTY SEVEN
DOLLARS AND ALMOST EIGHTY
DOLLARS PER DAY.
DEPENDING ON THE COUNTY AND ITS
COSTS.
ON THE RIGHT YOU HAVE THE AMOUNT
PER CHILD THAT THE CHILD CARE
CENTERS MEETING TITLE FIVE
STANDARDS RECEIVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
SYSTEM CALLED THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE OR THE S. R.
R..
AFTER FIVE YEARS OF CONCERTED
EFFORT BY THIS BODY AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE TO RAISE
OUR FUNDING RATES THE PER CHILD
S. R. OR RATE REGARDLESS OF
COUNTY.
REGARDLESS OF REQUIREMENT OR
PROVIDER COST IS STILL ABOUT TWO
DOLLARS LESS THAN THE LOWEST
COUNTY REGIONAL MARKET RATE.
CURRENT RATES ARE AN ADEQUATE AS
YOU'VE HEARD FROM MULTIPLE
PANELISTS TODAY AND THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS TO MEET THE BASIC
REQUIREMENTS FOR HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS.
PARTICULARLY ACUTE AND ARE HIGH
AND MODERATE COST COUNTIES.
AND AND WE'RE HEARING MANY MANY
STORIES IN SACRAMENTO LOS
ANGELES AGAIN DIEGO AND THE BAY
AREA.
IT IS KEY TO REMEMBER THAT THE
LICENSED OR MORE FUNDED PROGRAMS
ARE REQUIRED TO MEET TITLE
TWENTY TWO STANDARDS.
THAT'S OUR OUR FUNDED PROGRAMS
REQUIRED TO MEET ADDITIONAL
TITLE FIVE STANDARDS THE KYRIE
INCREASED COSTS.
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT OF THESE
ADDITIONAL TITLE FIVE
REQUIREMENTS ARE LOWER ADULT TO
CHILD RATIOS WHICH ARE KEY TO
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS YOU HEARD
FROM SERRA NOVEL MORGAN
REGARDING AT TRIAL TEACHER
INTERACTIONS.
INCREASE STAFF EDUCATION
INCREASED TRAINING INCREASE
FACILITY REQUIREMENTS AND CHILD
ASSESSMENT REVIEW.
ALL IMPORTANT RESEARCH TESTED
ASPECTS TO A QUALITY LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT.
ANDADEQUATE FUNDING FOR TITLE
FIVE STANDARD PROGRAMS OR EVEN
MORE CUTE FOR SCHOOL BASED
PROGRAMS AS YOU HEARD EARLIER
WHERE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
FORCED TO USE THEIR GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS TO MAKE UP A SHORTFALL
FOR BASIC OPERATING COSTS.
SHORTCOMINGS IN THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE ALSO EXIST MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE SYSTEM RELIES ON
HISTORIC SNAPSHOT APPROACH WHICH
IS ALMOST THREE YEARS OLD BEFORE
NEW SNAPSHOT IS AVAILABLE.
MAJOR COSTA BUSINESS CHANGES
SUCH AS RECENT CHANGE THE
MINIMUM WAGE ARE RISING HEALTH
CARE COSTS ARE UNABLE TO BE
CAPTURED IN SUCH A AN OLD --
SURVEY SYSTEM.
THE SURVEYS ALSO ALLOW TO
CAPTURE MARKET FAILURE.
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS IN DEEP
POVERTY COMMUNITIES CAN ONLY
CHARGE WITH THEIR MARKET WITH
THEIR NEIGHBORS ARE ABLE TO PAY.
THIS MARKET FAILURES AVERAGED
INTO THE SURVEY'S RESULTS.
SO CALIFORNIA NEEDS A SINGLE
REGIONALI STATE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE SYSTEM FOR CHILD CARE
PRESCHOOL AND EARLY LEARNING
SERVICES THAT ONE COMPENSATES
ALL TEACHERS AND PROVIDERS FOR
THE TRUE COST OF PROVIDING CARE.
WHERE THE SQUEEZE THAT WAS
DISCUSSED EARLIER MY PREVIOUS
PANELISTS?
THE TO RECOGNIZE THE COST OF
MEETING EXISTING VARYING QUALITY
STANDARDS INTENDED TO DRIVE
CHILD OUTCOMES INTENDED TO
PREVENT THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
AND THREE STABILIZE THE ABILITY
OF THE STATE'S MIXED DELIVERY
SYSTEM TO PROVIDE QUALITY EARLY
LEARNING OPTIONS.
THIS SINGLE REGIONALI STATE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION SERVICES WOULD ONE
ENSURE THAT POLICY MAKERS CAN
BETTER UNDERSTAND CARE FUNDING
LEVELS AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
I'M NUMBER TO THE PARENT
COMMUNITY MEMBERS UNDERSTAND THE
DIFFERENCES IN THE PROGRAMS AND
THEIR OPTIONS.
AND THE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY OPTIONS
THAT THEY MAY WANT ACCESS.
TO AND THREE THE MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM IS MAINTAINED AS ONE
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION SYSTEM
SERVING VARIOUS PROGRAM MISSIONS
WHICH ARE KEY.
BUT FUNDING THAT IS ADEQUATE TO
ACHIEVE THE SHARED SYSTEM
MISSION OF SUPPORTING WORKING
PARENTS AND THRIVING CHILDREN.
THIS KEEP TWIN MISSION MUST BE
PROTECTED THROUGH ALL OF OUR
FUNDING POLICIES.
SIGNIFICANTLY WE CAN LIKE WITH
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA CREATE A FORMULA FOR
CHILD CARE FUNDING BUT AS A
DRIVER FOR THE CHILD AND SYSTEM
OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT.
THE SECOND GRAPHIC YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU IS A VERY SIMPLE
DEPICTION OF OUR CONCEPTS.
WE ARE RECOMMENDING THAT YOU
MAKE IMPORTANT CHANGES TO THE
REGIONAL MARKET SURVEY.
AND ALIGN THE ENTIRE CHILD CARE
FUNDING SYSTEM TO A SINGLE
TIERED REIMBURSEMENT RATE
STRUCTURE THAT USES THIS REVISED
REGIONAL MARKET RATE AT THE BASE.
TITLE TWENTY TWO STANDARDS WOULD
EARN THE REVISED OR A MORE LEVEL
IN THEIR COUNTY WE'RE CALLING
THE BASE RATE.
AND PROVIDERS MEETING ADDITIONAL
TITLE FIVE STANDARDS WOULD EARN
THEIR COUNTIES BASE RATE PLUS AN
ADDITIONAL QUALITY ADJUSTMENT
FACTOR FOR THEIR INCREASED
REQUIREMENT COST.
OUR GROUP CALCULATED THIS
ADJUSTMENT FACTOR CONCEPT BASED
ON THE BIGGEST COST DRIVERS THAT
ARE DIFFERENT BETWEEN TITLE
TWENTY TO ENTITLE.
FIVE WE BELIEVE THIS CALCULATION
IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT IF WE
EVER WANT TO CREATE INCENTIVES
FOR HIGHER STANDARDS FOR ALL
PROGRAM SETTINGS.
THE THIRD GRAPHIC YOU HAVE.
THEN EXPLAINS THE IMPLEMENTATION
DESIGN OF OUR PROPOSAL.
OTHER THAN EXPECT THE STATE TO
ABSORB THE COST OF THIS NEW RATE
SYSTEM IN ONE YEAR WE ARE
PROPOSING THAT LIKE WITH A LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
THE STATE USE THIS NEW
METHODOLOGY TO CREATE TARGETS
EACH YEAR BY CONTRACT IN BY
COUNTY.
THEN EACH YEAR THE BUDGET ACT
WOULD PROVIDE FUNDS FOR RATE
INCREASES AS THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION SOFFIT.
AND THESE INCREASES WILL BE
DISTRIBUTED EQUITABLY TOWARDS
EACH TARGET.
RATHER THAN A FLAT INCREASE TO
ALL AS WE CURRENTLY DO WITH COLA.
THAT MEANS IMPLEMENTATION TOWARD
THESE NEW RATE TARGETS ARE
WITHIN THE CONTROL THE BUDGET
PROCESS EACH YEAR BASED ON
AVAILABLE RESOURCES.
THAT ALSO MEANS THAT IN A RATE
INCREASE HERE COUNTIES WE GET AN
INCREASE THE DISPROPORTIONATE TO
THEIR DISTANCE TO THEIR FUNDING
TARGET.
THUS HIGH COST COUNTIES WHO
START MUCH FURTHER AWAY FROM
THEIR TARGET WE GET A LARGER
SHARE IN A SINGLE YEAR RATE
INCREASE THAN THEIR LOWER COST
COUNTERPARTS.
BUT ALL BOATS WOULD CONTINUE TO
RISE TOGETHER.
SO THE FINAL DOCKING YOU HAVE IN
FRONT OF YOU IS A POLICY ONE
PAGER WHICH CONTAINS ALL THE
DETAILED RECOMMENDATIONS TO
ACHIEVE THESE GOALS IN STATUTE.
THESE CHANGES TO THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE DESIGN THE CREATION
OF NEW TARGETS FOR THE ENTIRE
SINGLE FUNDING SYSTEM WOULD
REPRESENT TOGETHER THE CHILD
CARE STABILISATION FORMULA.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH THE MORE IT'S AS A PARENT I
KNOW YOU HAVE A GREAT NAME SO.
IMAGINE MY NAME'S JACQUELINE
GETS HOME OKAY WELCOME GOOD
MORNING EVERYBODY I'M A LITTLE
NERVOUS SO BEAR WITH ME IS MY
FIRST TIME DOING THIS AND I
THINK YOU OFFER GIVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY STORY
WITH YOU -- I'M JACQUELINE THE
TONE I'M A MEMBER OF PARENT
VOICES CONTRA COSTA.
MY TWO YEAR SOME MATTHEW HAS
BEEN ON A WAIT LIST FOR YEAR.
I HAVE A TWELVE YEAR OLD
DAUGHTER WHO HAS ALSO BEEN ON
THE WAIT LIST AND I NEVER
RECEIVED THAT CALL.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK FOR FAMILIES
ON THE WAITING LIST TO HELP YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT IT MEANS TO WAIT.
WAITING FOR CHILDCARE MEAN
CHILDHOOD DREAM SHATTERED.
I ALWAYS WANTED TO OWN MY OWN SH
SALON MY DREAM CAME TRUE LAST
YEAR AND I HELD ON FOR IF TO IT
FOR NINE MONTHS.
UNTIL I HAD TO CLOSE IT BECAUSE
I COULDN'T AFFORD CHILDCARE.
IT MEANS HAVING TO QUIT A SECOND
JOB THE SEC THE CONSTANT FEAR
THAT MY THIRD JOB IN THREE YEARS.
ONE I'M REALLY GOOD AT AND HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO BUILD A CAREER
MAY SLIP FROM ME BECAUSE I CAN'T
AFFORD CHILDCARE.
BEING ON A WAIT LIST MEANS MEANS
SPENDING THREE TO FOUR HOURS PER
DAY COMMUTING BETWEEN MY HOME IN
ANTIOCH. TWO IN AFFORDABLE AND
FLEXIBLE FACT EXCUSE ME FLEXIBLE
CHILDCARE PROVIDER TWENTY
MINUTES AWAY AND THEN TO WORK IN
THE CITY OF OAKLAND.
IT MEANS NOT BEING ABLE TO
AFFORD A RELIABLE CAR IN
DEPENDING ON PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION AND OVERSEE GET
ME BETWEEN THREE PLACES.
THERE'S ALSO LOTS OF TIME TO
SPEND WITH MY CHILDREN WHO ARE
MISSING OUT ON MY PRESENCE.
IT MEANS HAVING TO MISS OUT ON
MY KIDS SCHOOL AND SPORTS
ACTIVITIES AND TELLING MY
DAUGHTER I HAVE TO MISS ANOTHER.
BRING YOUR LOVE ONE TO LUNCH DAY
BECAUSE IT'S IMPOSSIBLE FOR ME
TO ATTEND IT ON MY LUNCH BREAK.
IT MEANS LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK BUT ALSO PUSHING OUT
SOME BILLS AND CONSTANTLY
WORRYING.
BEING ON A WAIT LIST HAS MADE ME
FEEL HOPELESS FRUSTRATED AND
STRESSED IT MEANS LOSING SLEEP
BECAUSE I'M IN A CONSTANT PANIC.
NOT KNOWING IS THE HARDEST PILL
TO SWALLOW TOO MANY OF US
FAMILIES THE WAITING LIST IS
REALLY THE NO HOPELESS I'VE
RECENTLY LEARNED ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET AND
HEARD YOU ALL DISCUSSING IT.
IT LEAVES ME HEARTBROKEN THAT
THERE'S NO CHILD HERE BEFORE
YOUR KID IS FOUR YEARS OLD.
OF THE CHILDREN ON THE WAIT LIST
86% OF THEM ARE CHILDREN OF
COLOR MATTHEW IS ONE OF THEM.
THE ODDS ARE STACKING UP AGAINST
HIM AS AN AFRICAN AMERICAN BOY.
BUT I AM HERE BECAUSE I DON'T
WANT HIM TO GET LOST IN THE DATA
AND THE STATISTICS.
HAVING CHILD CARE ASSISTANCE
IMPACTS BOTH THE CHILD AND THE
PARENT FOR MY SON IT WOULD HELP
HIM TO HAVE ADVANCEMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ONCE HE STARTS
SCHOOL.
AND IN AN ENVIRONMENT THAT
ENHANCES HIS SKILLS AS A PARENT
I WOULD BE ABLE TO SPEND MORE
TIME WITH MY KIDS WITHOUT HAVING
TO WORK SUCH LONG HOURS TO
COMPENSATE FOR CHILDCARE.
IT WOULD HELP ME CATCH UP ON MY
BILLS AND HELP ME ADVOCATE
ADVANCE AT MY MY JOB FOR THE
CITY OF OAKLAND THAT PROVIDES
BENEFITS.
MY EMPLOYER SEES HOW HARD I WORK
I AM PROVING TO BE ONE SOMEONE
THAT WANT THEY WANT TO SUPPORT
IT'S AFFORDABLE.
CHILDCARE THAT WILL EITHER MAKE
OR BREAK ME. TO WAIT FOR CHILD
CARE IS AN EMOTIONAL ROLLER
COASTER FOR THE PARENT AND THE
CHILD.
IT SHOULD BE AVAILABLE FOR
WORKING PARENTS THAT NEED THE
ASSISTANCE IF THINGS GET SO BAD
DO I REALLY NEED TO LOSE ANOTHER
JOB OPPORTUNITY. FOR MATTHEW AND
ALL HIS PEERS WE ASK THAT YOU
INVEST ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN.
CHILD HERE FOR THE NEXT THREE
YEARS SO THAT THIS HIS CHILDHOOD
YOU HIS CHILDHOOD DREAMS CAN BE
EVEN BIGGER THAN MINE.
OUR CHILDREN ARE OUR FUTURE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU.
I DON'T HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
THIS PANEL NOT THAT I'M NOT
INTERESTED BUT I HAVE NOT
ENGAGED IN THIS.
TOPIC FOR FOR A WHILE WE CAN BE
ON IN HEARING WHAT WENT OVER
ABILITIES BUT I DO ACTUALLY
MAYBE A LOS ONE QUESTION.
FOR FAIR AND GABLE ON ON THE
PROPOSAL FOR THAT.
REASON BASED REIMBURSEMENT --
REFORM -- STREAMLINING AND
INCREASING THE THERE WERE THE
RATE STRUCTURE.
WHAT'S THE AND I KNOW ALL
DEPENDS ON HOW FAST YOU DO IT.
WHAT'S THE ROUGH -- DOLLAR
AMOUNTS OVER THE OUT YEARS AND
AND HOW MUCH -- WOULD BE NEEDED --
IF YOU DID LET'S SAY A FIVE YEAR
IMPLEMENTATION.
ON THIS SO OUR OUR COST
ESTIMATES -- WOULD OF COURSE
WHICH WILL NEED TO BE ADJUSTED
WHEN WE SEE THE NEW ARE AMMAR
SURVEY LATER THIS SPRING BUT ARE
ARE AT COST ESTIMATES THIS
POINTER BETWEEN FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION AND TWO S. SEVEN
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE TOTAL PACKAGE
FOR THE EXISTING SYSTEMS OF
COURSE THAT WOULD BE IMPACTED IF
YOU ADDED INCREASED SERVICES
THIS YEAR AS WE ARE ALL HOPING
TO SEE HAPPEN AS WELL -- OUR
HOPE IS THE NAY ADDITION TO THE
CALL OF THIS YEAR THAT THERE CAN
BE A SIGNIFICANT DOWN PAYMENT
TOWARDS THIS NEW RATE
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM.
SO IDEALLY YOU KNOW IF YOU'RE
PUTTING IN ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR OVER A
FIVE YEAR.
PERIOD WE CAN MAKE SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS.
AND IS THAT AMOUNT TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE RATE INCREASES
OVER THE PRIOR YEARS THAT IS
THAT TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
THAT.
I WE WERE ACTUALLY VERY
HEARTENED TO SEE THAT WITH THE
INFANT TODDLER ADJUSTMENT FACTOR
CHANGES THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED LAST YEAR ALMOST ALL OF
OUR PROPOSALS.
IN THE INFANT TODDLER RATE SPACE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN ACCOMPLISHED
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF VERY HIGH
COST COUNTIES SO MOST OF THE
COST YOU SEE HERE IN THIS
PROPOSALS ACTUALLY FOR A RIGHT
SIZING THE PRESCHOOL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
AND THEN JUST TO CLARIFY YOU
SAID THIS EARLIER BUT THIS WOULD
BE FOR ALL OF THE CALIFORNIA
FUNDING YOU SEE PROGRAMS
CORRECTIVE FROM INFANT TODDLER
PROGRAMS GENERAL CHILD CARE AND
STATE PRESCHOOL CORRECT CORRECT
AND FOR ABOUT YOUR BASED
PROGRAMS THERE IS THAT BENEFIT
ACROSS THE SYSTEM BECAUSE OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS.
ARE RIGHT SIZING -- SOME SOME.
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS WITHIN THE
REGIONAL MARKET RATE AS WELL.
AND AND NOT TO SAY YOUR YOUR
YOUR FORMULA.
AND THE CHARTS HERE ARE NOT
ENOUGH IN PLAIN ENGLISH.
LAURIE YOUR TWENTY THREE PAGE --
SUMMARY.
BUT YOU KNOW WE SPENT THE
EARLIER PART OF TODAY TALKING
ABOUT ACCESS.
AND THE THE TOUGH TIMES THAT THE
ELEAZAR ARE HAVING PROVIDING
THESE PROGRAMS AND THE FACT THAT --
YES REALLY WERE SQUEEZING OUT
FAMILIES.
THANK YOU JUST TESTIFIED TO
THANK YOU.
AND THE FACT THAT OUR WORK FORCE
IS AN ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED AND
CAN MAKE MORE WORKING AT IN AND
OUT BURGER AND COSCO.
SO IT IN IN IN PLAIN ENGLISH HOW
WITH THIS.
ALL OF THIS IMPACT THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT WE TALKED ABOUT FROM.
NINE TO TEN THIRTY ABSOLUTELY.
ADEQUATE PER CHILD FUNDING THAT
MEETS THE COST WE EXPECT FOR
BOTH CHILD OUTCOMES THAT PREVENT
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP BUT ALSO TO
BE DURING THE HOURS FOR PARENTS
NEED TO WORK.
IS ABSOLUTELY KEY IF WE DO NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE PER CHILD FUNDING
RATES WE DO NOT HAVE PROVIDERS
WERE ABLE TO PROVIDE CARE FOR
CHILDREN AND TO MOVE THE DIAL
FOR THEM IN A CHIU GENERATIONAL
APPROACH IT'S IT'S A VERY
FUNDAMENTAL.
ISSUE AND SO WE SEE AS YOU'VE
HEARD FROM US FOR MANY YEARS --
WE SEE REIMBURSEMENT RATES AS
KEY TO ACCESS EXPANSION NOT AT
THE EXPENSE OF ACCESS EXPANSION.
AND BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S AT THIS
INCREDIBLE HISTORIC CHAPTER OF
CONTEMPLATING NOT WHETHER TO GET
TO UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL BUT HOW
TO GET TO UNIVERSAL PRESCHOOL
IT'S REALLY KEY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE ARCHITECTURE.
THAT THE FUNDING DRIVERS ARE
MAKING SURE WE GET THERE IN A
WAY THAT IS GOING TO IMPROVE
CHILD OUTCOMES YEAH SO THIS IN
THIS IMPACTS.
ACCESS -- THE QUALITY OF THE
PROGRAMS AS WELL AS MAKING SURE
WE TAKE CARE OF OUR WORKFORCE
ABSOLUTELY YES AS I CAN -- TRY
FACTOR RIGHT THERE ABSOLUTELY
YES SO SIGN ME UP.
WE WILL HAVE TO MAKE THIS HAPPEN.
I'M A LOT OF TALK ABOUT BILLS
NOT.
THANK YOU FOR STAYING ON MESSAGE.
THAT'S WHERE THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OF COURSE SO THIS IS A
BUDGET PROPOSAL.
AND WE WE LOST THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE PEOPLE THERE OVER THERE
SO I I'M SURE WE'VE I'M SURE YOU
AND YOUR ADVOCATES HAVE TALKED
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ABOUT
THIS YEAH ABOUT THIS -- PROPOSAL
AND ANY ANY -- FEEDBACK OR
ANYTHING YOU SHARE WITH US NO NO
I I THINK WE WOULD JUST WANT TO
THANK THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
FOR YOU JUST PROVIDING SOME
BASIC FEEDBACK DURING OUR
PROCESS AND DELIBERATIONS AS A
WORKGROUP THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES THE
LA -- THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ALL I LISTENED AND AND
CONTRIBUTED IN DIFFERENT WAYS TO
OUR DELIBERATIONS IN OUR
THINKING AND WE REALLY.
APPRECIATED IT BECAUSE THEY KNOW
THE BACKGROUNDS THE SYSTEMS
BETTER THAN ANYBODY.
AND AGAIN I DON'T WANT TO REPEAT
THIS BUT YOU KNOW I'M SUPER
EXCITED ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND AND WE'VE BEEN ON
THIS QUEST FOR A FEW YEARS AND
PEOPLE BEFORE ME HAVE BEEN
PUSHING THIS BUT WE COME THE
REALIZATION THAT.
IT'S NOT ONE OF THE OTHER IF YOU
WANT THIS TO WORK IT'S NOT JUST
LOTS IT'S TALKING ABOUT THE SELL
THESE AND AND RATES IN THE WORK
FORCE SO I THINK.
THIS -- TIES OUT ALL TOGETHER IN
A PACKAGE OF SO IF YOU WANT TO
DO FOR EXAMPLE STATE PRESCHOOL
EXPANSION AT TEN THOUSAND SLOTS
PER YEAR.
ABSENT THIS AND THE FACILITIES
IT WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT -- TO
TO ACHIEVE SUCCESS AND SO I
THANK YOU FOR HELPING PUT THIS
TOGETHER AND I ALSO WANT TO KNOW
TOO THAT -- THAT THAT DOESN'T
MINIMIZE THE DESIRE THAT THAT
YOU OUTLINED AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- GRAY S. AS FAR AS AND
RUBIO THE NEED FOR PROGRAMS. FOR
FOR YOUNGSTERS BEFORE THE AGE OF
THREE AND FOUR SO THANK YOU AS
WELL [inaudible]
OKAY.
I WITH THAT WE'RE GOING -- TO
BRIEFLY GO TO ISSUE NUMBER
[inaudible]
FIVE LATE.
TO COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WE
WE WE HAD DISCUSSED THIS IN THE
HIGHER EDUCATION PROPOSAL.
A PAST FEARS FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND THEY WERE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHERE THE BEST PLACE
TO PUT IT WE LOVE THE IDEA.
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MAKE
IT ALL WORK AND SO WE WANT TO
WORK TOGETHER HOW THE AT THE
OUTSET THAT AS YOU KNOW.
WE DID SOMETHING LIKE THIS LAST
TWO YEARS IN THE BUDGET SO IS
WHEN TO MAKE SURE WE WE FOCUS ON
WHAT -- IS THAT IT IS WORKING
AND SO ENOUGH ALLOWED DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO BRIEFLY OUTLINE --
THEIR PROPOSAL AND THEN HAVE THE
LA GO AND SEE IT COMMISSION --
ADDRESSES AS WELL THANK YOU
HELLO AGAIN LEASE EMERGENCY WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE -- SO AS
YOU MENTIONED THE NINETEEN
TWENTY GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES A PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
FIFTY MILLION ONE TIME NON
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
TO SUPPORT.
PILOT PROJECTS AND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCIES
AND PHILANTHROPIES TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS FOR INCOMING
KINDERGARTNERS.
THESE ACCOUNTS ARE GENERALLY
OPEN WITH INITIAL CONTRIBUTION --
SEED MONEY FROM SPONSORING
ORGANIZATION SUCH AS GOVERNMENTS
NONPROFITS PHILANTHROPIC
PHILANTHROPIC FOUNDATIONS AND
BUILD ASSETS OVER TIME THROUGH
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM THE FAMILY
FRIENDS THE CHILD.
AND THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INCENTIVES -- COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS ARE DESIGNATED FOR AN%
INDIVIDUAL CHILD AND CAN BE USED
TO PAY FOR COLLEGE RELATED
EXPENSES SUCH AS TUITION ROOM
AND BOARD.
BOOKS -- SUPPLIES EQUIPMENT AND
OTHER RELATED FEES.
THIS PROPOSAL AIMS TO SUPPORT
ENCOURAGE OF FAMILIES TO BUILD
ASSETS FOR THEIR CHILDREN POSTED
AS SECONDARY EDUCATION.
ADDITIONALLY THE COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNT PROGRAM IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION'S TO
GENERATION EFFORT. TO PROMOTE
EQUITY IN THE STATE BY A NUMBER
ONE PROMOTING FINANCIAL LITERACY
TO CULTIVATING A COLLEGE GOING
IDENTITY AMONG BOTH STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES.
AND THREE LEVERAGING RESOURCES
FROM MULTIPLE SOURCES TO ASSIST
IN MAKING POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION ATTAINABLE WITHOUT I
CONCLUDE MY REMARKS AND WALK
MANY QUESTIONS OKAY.
THANK YOU LA A BE THINKING WITH
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
ALL THIS IS ASPEN FINASTERIDE
OVERVIEW OF COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNTS OF CONTEXT FOR THIS
CONVERSATIONS PLACE THE
SERGEANTS HAS HAVE JUST
DISTRIBUTED GET ANOTHER HAND OUT
TO YOU THAT WE WILL BE SPEAKING
FROM.
YOU'LL SEE THE TOP OF THE FIRST
PAGE OF THIS HANDOUT THAT
FEDERAL LAW ALLOWS FOR A
SPECIFIC TYPE OF COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNT CALLED THE FIVE TWENTY
NINE PLAN.
PARENTS CAN OPEN UP ONE OF THESE
ACCOUNTS ON BEHALF OF A STUDENT.
AND THE FUNDS THAT INVEST IN
THIS ACCOUNT WILL TEND TO GROW
OVER TIME.
THE MAJOR TAX ADVANTAGE OF FIVE
TWENTY NINE PLAN IS THAT THE
EARNINGS ON THOSE INVESTMENTS
ARE NOT TAXABLE AS LONG AS THE
STUDENT USES THE FUNDS.
A QUALIFIED EDUCATION EXPENSES
AS THE PART OF FINANCE HAS
DISCUSSED.
NEARLY EVERY STATE ADMINISTERS
THE FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN.
AND AS YOU KNOW IN CALIFORNIA
FIVE TWENTY NINE PLAN IS CALLED
SCHOLAR SHARE.
ADMINISTERED FROM WITHIN THE
STATE TREASURER'S OFFICE AND
THERE ARE CURRENTLY OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND OPEN
ACCOUNTS.
PERIODICALLY SCHOLAR SHARE
OFFERS MATCHING CAMPAIGNS TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION COURAGE
FAMILIES OPEN ACCOUNTS.
CURRENTLY THROUGH THE END OF THE
TWENTY NINETEEN CALENDAR YEAR.
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES TO OPEN AN
ACCOUNT.
QUALIFY FOR UP TO TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS IN MATCHING
GRANTS.
IF YOU TURN THE PAGE YOU'LL SEE
THAT THERE ARE ALSO BEEN A
NUMBER OF LOCAL EFFORT SOME OF
WHICH YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR WITH.
TO INCREASE PARTICIPATION
COLLEGE SAVINGS.
THE FIRST AND LARGEST OF THESE
PROGRAMS WAS LAUNCHED IN SAN
FRANCISCO IN.
TWENTY ELEVEN CURRENTLY SAN
FRANCISCO OPENS A COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT AUTOMATICALLY
FOR EVERY KINDERGARTEN AND THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MAKES AN INITIAL DEPOSIT OF
FIFTY DOLLARS.
IT ALSO OFFERS ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVES FOR FAMILIES TO
CONTRIBUTE.
SINCE THE LAUNCH OF THIS PROGRAM
SEVERAL OTHER LOCAL GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES HAVE LAUNCHED COLLEGE
SAVINGS PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS DO VARY WIDELY IN
TERMS OF HIS ELIGIBLE FOR THEM.
BUT THE PROCESS IS TO ENROLL
WHETHER THAT'S AUTOMATIC ARE
OFTEN FOR EXAMPLE.
AND ALSO WHAT INCENTIVES IN
PLACE FOR FAMILIES TO CONTRIBUTE
FUNDS.
YOU'LL RECALL THAT IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN LEGISLATURE
CREATED A PROGRAM CALLED EVERY
KICK COUNTS TO SUPPORT THESE
LOCAL EFFORTS.
IN PREFABRICATED SO PROVIDES
GRANTS TO LOCAL ENTITIES THAT
ARE WORKING TO INCENTIVIZE
FAMILIES PARTICULARLY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. TO CONTRIBUTE TO
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS.
THIS DID NEED COMMISSION
ADMINISTERS THIS PROGRAM AND
RECOGNIZING THAT THEY'LL BE
PROVIDING AN UPDATE ON IT I'LL
KEEP OUR COMMENTS IN THIS BRIEF
AND CONCLUDE OUR OVERVIEW.
BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
STATE COMMISSION.
GOOD MORNING DAVID O'BRIEN OF
THE CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION -- HAPPY TO PROVIDE A
BRIEF UPDATE ON THE EVERY KID
COUNTS PROGRAM SAYS MY COLLEAGUE
FROM THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE.
NOTED IN TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTEEN
THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
THE BUDGET ACT PROVIDED A LITTLE
UNDER THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
ONE TIME FUNDS FOR THIS TO NAY
COMMISSION. TO PROVIDE ON A
COMPETITIVE BASIS TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER ELIGIBLE
ENTITIES THAT OPERATE COLLEGE
SAVINGS PROGRAMS THE FUNDS CAN
BE USED -- FOR A FEW DIFFERENT
SPECIFIC PURPOSES AMONG THEM
TOPPING UP THE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS
TO PROVIDE INCENTIVES -- FOR
FAMILIES -- PROVIDING -- OUT
REACH FUNDS TO MAKE FAMILIES
AWARE OF THIS OPPORTUNITY -- AS
WELL AS SOME INDEPENDENT
EVALUATION TO DO SORT OF BEST
PRACTICES AND SOME SHARING OF
THOSE BEST PRACTICES -- AMONG
THE ENTITIES SO WE USED TO
COMMIT A PROCESS KNOWN AS HER
PRESS FOR APPLICATIONS FOR THIS
PROGRAM WHEREBY WE PUT OUT A
STATE WIDE REQUEST TO ANY
ELIGIBLE ENTITY THERE IS AN
APPLICATION PERIOD.
A TOTAL OF NINE ENTITIES APPLIED
AND ALL WERE ELIGIBLEFOR LISTED
ON IN YOUR AGENDA ON PAGE.
TWENTY AND WE WERE NOT --
UNFORTUNATELY ABLE TO AWARD
EVERY ENTITY THE FULL AMOUNT THE
REQUESTED BECAUSE IT HAD TO BE
SCALED DOWN TO MEET THE THE TWO
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS THAT
WAS AVAILABLE.
AND THE FORMULA THAT WAS IN THE
STATUTE FOR US TO SORT OF
DETERMINE HOW MUCH EACH ENTITY
WAS GOING TO RECEIVE BUT LAST
WEEK ARE COMMISSION DID VOTE TO
APPROVE THESE RECOMMENDED
DISTRIBUTIONS.
SO WE HAVE HERE IN YOUR GENDER
ARE THE FINAL AMOUNTS THAT WE
DISTRIBUTED -- GOING FORWARD AS
A REALLY TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WE'RE OF COURSE AWARE
THEIR DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THIS
PROPOSAL AS WELL AS OTHER
LEGISLATION WHICH PER YOUR
INSTRUCTIONS ASSEMBLYMEMBER WILL
DISCUSS -- THAT -- MAY PLACE
SUCH A PROGRAM ON AN ONGOING
BASIS EITHER AT ANOTHER AGENCY
THIS TO MAKE COMMISSION AND WE
WERE BROUGHT UP AS A POSSIBILITY.
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THIS IN TERMS OF A
RECOMMENDATION FOR HAPPY TO
CONTINUE BEING PART OF THOSE
DISCUSSIONS AND WE CERTAINLY
FEEL THAT -- ENCOURAGING COLLEGE
SAVINGS IS BOTH.
OF OUR MISSION AND WORTH
DISCUSSING AS WE DISCUSSED Là
EFFORTS TO OVERHAUL AS THE
FINANCIAL AID SYSTEM SINCE -- AS
YOU KNOW VERY WELL THOSE
CONCEPTS UNDER DISCUSSION --
INVOLVE -- SOME EXPECTATIONS ON
PARENTS AND STUDENTS TO BRING
SOME FUNDS UP FRONT SO WE THINK
THAT HAVING THIS DISCUSSION
ABOUT COLLEGE SAVINGS FITS INTO
THAT DISCUSSION ABOUT
FINANCIALLY REFORM AS WELL.
AND HAPPY ANSWER QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU OUT I'LL JUST NOTE
THAT -- THIS IS THAT A PRIORITY
FOR THE ASSEMBLY AT WE WE FULLY
SUPPORT THESE COLLEGE SAVINGS --
ACCOUNTS AND THE NOTION THAT WE
SHOULD BE STEPPING UP AND DOING
THIS I THINK THE RESEARCH IS
CRYSTAL CLEAR.
WE KNOW THAT COLLEGE IS
EXPENSIVE WE KNOW THAT WE NEED
MORE YOUNG PEOPLE TO GO TO CALLS
FOR OUR ECONOMY DID TO SUCCEED
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE ON THE
TICKET TO THAT.
MIDDLE CLASS TODAY IS THE HIGHER
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH SHOWS IF
YOU HAVE A COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNT WITH.
YOU KNOW HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OR A THOUSAND DOLLARS
YOU STILL ABOUT SIX TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO GO TO COLLEGE BECAUSE
YOU SEE THE EXPECTATIONS BUILT
UPON HAVING YOUR NAME.
WAS SOME MONEY.
IN THE ACCOUNT WITH YOUR NAME
TALKING ABOUT COLLEGE IN THE
FUTURE SO.
I'M A BIG SUPPORTER THIS AND I I
TOLD THE COMMITTEES BEFORE BUT I
SAW THAT'S HOW SAN FRANCISCO
CREATE THEIR PROGRAM OVER A
DECADE AGO.
WHEN OUR THEN -- GOVERNOR WAS
MARE AND I WAS SO INSPIRED THAT
I LAUNCHED OUR OUR OUR OWN
PROGRAM HERE IN SACRAMENTO ABOUT
SEVEN YEARS AGO THE SACRAMENTO.
A KINDERGARTEN COLLEGE PROGRAM
AND I THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
HELPING COMMUNITIES AROUND THE
STATE STEP UP AND DO THIS SO I
APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR'S.
PROPOSAL -- JUST JUST ONE COPY
OUT IS THAT WE'VE KIND OF FIGURE
OUT HOW TO DO THIS I THINK IT
JUST WORK REALLY WELL WITH THIS
YOU NEED COMMISSION SO I THINK
THAT WE SHOULD TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT MODEL AS OPPOSED -- TO
REINVENTING THE WHEEL BECAUSE WE
WENT THROUGH A LOT OF YOU KNOW
BRAIN DAMAGE THE LAST TWO YEARS
TRYING TO FIGURE IT OUT SO LET'S
AND MAYBE THINK ABOUT HOW HOW
HOW WE ON A CRAFTED THAT -- THAT
PLAN GOING FORWARD BUT WITH THAT.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT USE OF
ONE TIME MONEY IN THE STATE
BUDGET.
SO THIS IS AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM
AS WELL NO ACTION TODAY.
AND WITH THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK TO THE OVERALL ISSUE OF
TODAY IS -- EARLY EDUCATION AND
THIS OF COURSE ANYBODY WANTS TO
TESTIFY ON THIS TOPIC AS WELL
WE'RE GONNA HIT HAVE -- PUBLIC
COMMENTS BEGIN NOW AND WE COULD
HAVE PEOPLE START LINING UP.
IN THE CENTER OF THE COMMITTEE
ROOM.
THE SUN WAS GONNA SNEAK OUT
[inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND I KNOW WE HAVE A LARGE --
GROUP OF INSPIRED INDIVIDUALS
WANT TO TALK ABOUT EARLY
EDUCATION AND THAT I I WANT YOU
TO TO ENGAGE AS WELL SO LOOK
FORTY PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
PLEASE TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENTS
TO ONE MINUTE OR LESS. ONE
MINUTE OR LESS PER INDIVIDUAL
THANK YOU.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING UP THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY I WE WANT TO ECHO THE
COMMENTS WAS SOMEONE ALONE.
AND THOSE OF OTHERS TODAY ABOUT
WORK FORCE AN ESSENTIAL NEED FOR
WORK FORCE THAT'S FUNDAMENTAL
THE CHILD CARE WE HEARD THAT IN
THE CONVERSATION AND WE THINK --
IF WE'RE GOING TO DO IT AND
ADDRESS CHILD CARE IN A
MEANINGFUL WAY WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE WORK FORCE AND THAT MEANS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WE URGE
THE SUPPORT OF HER.
PROPOSAL IN AB THREE SEVEN EIGHT
BUT WE ALSO THINK IT'S
CONSISTENT TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION HERE IN THE BUDGET
IS CONSISTENT WITH WHAT THE
GOVERNOR IS ASKING FOR FOR CHILD
CARE.
YOU CAN'T SERVE CHILDREN IF YOU
DON'T HAVE THE WORK FORCE WE'RE
LOSING WORKERS.
THERE AGING OUT WE HAVE LESS
THAN HALF THAN WE DID TEN YEARS
AGO AND THAT'S IN LARGE PART
BECAUSE OF NOT SUPPORTED THEY'RE
NOT FUNDED AND THEY'RE NOT AT
THE TABLE.
I'M INTO FOR A LOT OF MY TIME TO
OUR MEMBERS BEHIND US BUT I JUST
WANT TO SAY THAT -- WE WANT THIS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR FIFTEEN
YEARS TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION
WE'RE HAVING IT TODAY BUT WE
NEED TO INCLUDE THE WORKERS IN
THE CONVERSATION AND NOT JUST
LOOKING AT THE CHILDREN.
BECAUSE THEY SERVE THEM THEY
MAKE SURE THAT WE CAN CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND THE SERVER I
ALTERNATIVE HOURS THE SERVE THE
LOWEST INCOME CHILDREN THEY ARE
WHO WE NEED IN THIS CONVERSATION
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS DAN UP OR NOT A
ROLL BLISS IMA FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER.
IN THE CITY OF ALL IN PARK FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS I ALSO HOLD TO A.
A.'S AND A BACHELOR'S DEGREE.
PROVIDERS LIKE MYSELF CAN'T WAIT
ANY LONGER WE NEED THE RIGHT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING WITH THE
STATE TO IMPROVE OUR EARLY
EDUCATION SYSTEM FOR ALL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JUDY IS THE
MORE AT I DO TELL CARE IN
VICTORVILLE I'VE BEEN DOING IT
FOR NINETEEN YEARS AND I AM ALSO
A MEMBER OF IT AS HE I YOU LOOK
ON NINETY NINE CURRENTLY I FOR
FOURTEEN CHILDREN AND ELEVEN WHO
ARE SUBSIDIZED.
I'M AND I CURRENTLY HOLD A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE AND TWO
ASSOCIATES DEGREE ASSIST WHILE --
IN MY FAMILY -- TO FACILITY
CHILDREN ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
RESEARCH BASED CURRICULUM FORMAL
ASSESSMENTS AND EARLY
INTERVENTION WHEN NEEDED.
I ALSO PROVIDE EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES TO COMMUNITY TO MY
COMMUNITY CURRENTLY WITH TWO
STAFF MEMBERS.
STATUS ALSO ENCOURAGED TO OBTAIN
TRAINING ON A PREDICATION TO
MAINTAIN EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THIS IS AN ASSET TO
QUALITY CARE I BELIEVE IN MY
STATION AS A POSITIVE STEP
TOWARDS VALUE IN MY CAREER AS A
PROFESSION.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
HI MY NAME IS CATENA RICHARD ST
I'M A LICENSED CHILDCARE
PROVIDER IN HAYWARD CALIFORNIA
HAVE BEEN FOR THE LAST PAST
TWENTY YEARS -- MY CHILD CARE
ALSO PARTICIPATES IN THE CURE
HAS PROGRAM THE QUALITY COUNTS
I'M A FOUR STAR DAY CARE.
AND I'M HOPING THAT IN DOING THE
BUDGET THAT YOU'RE CONSIDERING
ALLOWING THE PUREST PROGRAM TO
BE ALLOWED TO EVERY CHILD CARE
LICENSE PROVIDER IN NOT JUST THE
ONES THAT RECEIVE SUBSIDY I DO
HAVE CURRENTLY.
ELEVEN SO THE PARENTS IN MY
PROGRAM AS WELL AS CASH
APPEARANCE WE ALSO DO A
CURRICULUM THERE WE ARE
EDUCATORS HERE.
AND YOU KNOW AS PROVIDERS WE DO
NEED A HIGHER PAY.
WE NEED TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING SO THAT WE
CAN ALSO LOOK FOR TO RETIREMENT.
VACATION SICK PAY SO THAT WE CAN
ONE DAY HAVE A FUTURE OF
THINKING ABOUT RETIREMENT WITH
DIGNITY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS CAROLYN CARPENTER
I'VE BEEN A FAMILY CHILDCARE
PROVIDER IN OAKLAND FOR TWENTY
NINE YEARS -- I AM ALSO A MEMBER
OF SEIU LOCAL FIVE TWENTY ONE I
CURRENTLY TAKE CARE OF TWELVE
CHILDREN AND IN MY ALMOST THREE
DECADES AS THAT REALLY CHAIR.
CARE PROVIDER I HAVE PROVIDED
CHECK HERE FOR MANY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES -- BUT CARING FOR OTHER
PEOPLES CHILDREN IT SHOULD MEAN
THAT I CAN'T PROVIDE FOR MY OWN
FAMILY.
AND PROVIDERS LIKE ME COULD NOT
CONTINUE DOING THIS IMPORTANT
WORK UNDER THESE CONDITIONS IT
IS TIME. FOR CHILD CARE FOR ALL
AND FOR ALL PROVIDERS TO EARN A
LIVING WAGE.
SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE AB
THREE SEVEN EIGHT BUILDING
BETTER EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
ACT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JULIE DONALDSON I
AM A MOTHER OF A SEVEN MONTH.
OLD CHILD BABY BOY I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF MY CHILD PROVIDER AND
HER FIGHT TO WIN COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING RIGHTS THANK YOU.
HI MY THE GORILLA REPRESENT LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND LOS ANGELES
COUNTY IS HOME TO AN ESTIMATED
THREE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVEN
CHILDREN FROM BIRTH TO FIVE
YEARS OLD RESIDING IN LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
OF WHICH 79% LACK ACCESS TO
SUBSIDIZE I MEAN IS THAT 93% OF
BABIES AND TODDLERS OF INCOME
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES COMPARED TO
THE 60% OF PRESCHOOLERS.
ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS SERVICES
THEREFORE IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE PROPOSALS.
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO EARLY
EDUCATION WE ARE WE ARE VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE REIMBURSEMENT
RATE REFORM PROPOSAL.
AND THE INCREASED LOTS IN
QUALITY FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS
PROPOSAL AND THE FACILITIES --
FUND PROPOSAL SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
EARLY CHILD CARE EDUCATION FOR
FAMILIES WORKING FAMILIES WHO
NEED THE SUPPORT OF SERVICES
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ON I AM
COMMUNITIES I'M WITH EARLY EDGE
CALIFORNIA WE APPLAUD AND
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL PROPOSED INVESTMENTS
AND BELIEVES BUDGETS THAT'S THE
RIGHT VISION FOR CALIFORNIA'S
EARLY CHILDHOOD SYSTEM.
HOWEVER WE STAND WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE ECT COMMUNITY
WHO BELIEVE THAT THE STATE CAN
AND SHOULD DO MORE FOR FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN.
WHO NEED SERVICE NOW
PARTICULARLY ARE NOT IN OUR
INFANT AND TODDLER CARE SYSTEM
WE BELIEVE THE STATE OUGHT TO
REFORM AND RIGHT SIZE OUR
REIMBURSEMENT SYSTEM IN WAYS
THAT ARE MORE REFLECTIVE OF
REGIONAL COSTS?
AND LAWS FROM APPROPRIATE
COMPENSATION OF THE WORK FORCE
FINALLY EARLY AGE BELIEVES THAT
AS THE STATE MAKES THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS WE
SHOULD ALWAYS HAVE OUR SIGHTS ON
IMPROVING QUALITY THROUGHOUT THE
SYSTEM.
THIS INCLUDES IMPROVING THE
STANDARDS IN SETTINGS IN WHICH
WE NURTURE CHILDREN AS WELL AS
IMPROVING WORK FIRST QUALITY BY
PROMOTING RIGOROUS
QUALIFICATIONS SUPPORTED BY FAIR
COMPENSATION AND MEANINGFUL AND
ONGOING PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHRIS FOR AMERICA --
HEAD START CALIFORNIA -- I THINK
THE WAY THAT WE SPEND OUR MONEY
IS REFLECTS OUR OUR PRIORITIES
AND OUR PRINCIPLES AND I WANT TO
DRAW ATTENTION TO JUST TWO OF
THE PRINCIPLES FROM THE RECENT
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION DROPPED
REPORT.
AND THE FIRST IS EQUITY AND THE
NEED TO REMOVE THE BARRIERS THAT
SEPARATE FAMILIES FROM
OPPORTUNITY INCLUDING POVERTY
HOMELESSNESS.
AND THAT IS PRECISELY THE
MISSION OF HEAD START.
PROVIDING A WHOLE CHILD TO
GENERATIONAL APPROACH TO
SUPPORTING THE CHILDREN WHO ARE
MOST AT RISK IN CALIFORNIA.
THE SECOND PRINCIPLE IS
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE ESSENTIAL
TO OUR EFFECTIVE MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM INCLUDING MAXIMIZING THE
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS LIKE CCD BG.
AND HEAD START -- SO WE ARE
URGING THE STATE TO DO IT TWELVE
OTHER STATES ARE ALREADY DOING.
TO INVEST IN HEAD START BECAUSE
IT PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR
MIX DELIVERY SYSTEM WE'VE
SUBMITTED TO THIS COMMITTEE ARE
BUDGET REQUEST FOR TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION.
FACILITY DEVELOPMENT FOR
INSTANCE IN TODDLERS AND OUR
RICH FOR HOMELESS FAMILIES AND
FINALLY IN THE SPIRIT OF ERIN
GABLES COMMENT OF RAISING ALL
THE BOATS ON THE WATER.
AS THESE BUDGET CONVERSATIONS
MOVE FORWARD STRONGLY RECOMMEND
MAKING EARLY CHILDHOOD
INVESTMENT ESPECIALLY IN THE
WORK FORCE AND FACILITIES
AVAILABLE TO ALL ENTITIES.
PROVIDING GOVERNMENT SUBSIDIZED
CARE THANKS.
WHEN MISTER CHAIRMAN TEMPLE
TERRACE CHILD THREE SIXTEEN LOS
ANGLES?
REFORM WANT TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE FOR
FOLKS IN PRIORITIZING ON THE
YOUNG FAMILIES AND YOUNG
CHILDREN.
SECONDLY I WANNA THANK BLUE
RIDGE REGION COMMISSION BECAUSE
THE DENTIST WONDERFUL WORK IN
THE RECOGNITION OUGHT TO BE
ADOPTED ME.
WE JOINED THE ECU COALITION AND
ALL ITS RECOMMENDATIONS AND AND
ASK YOU TO ADOPT IT.
WE ALSO SUPPORT.
THE COMMENTS OF THE PART OF
EDUCATION WHO TALKED ABOUT NOT
DELAYING THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT OF TWO OR FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND ALSO THEIR FACES ON THE
PRIORITIES OF WORK FORCED.
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BECAUSE WE
FIND THAT THE THE STUDIES FOUND
THAT IS THIS POURTANT TO HELP
PEOPLE GET THEIR AND TELL THEM
WHAT THE SCHOOLS DO WHAT THEY
HAND OUT WHAT.
USER MISSING AND SO ON TO GET
THIS SORT OF OCCASION TO GET
THEIR DEGREES AND TO BE RAISING
THE QUALITY MERELY SO.
PLEASE ADD THAT AS WELL.
AND FINALLY PLEASE DON'T COMBINE
THE FACILITY AND THE WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT INTO ONE POT.
BECAUSE DOWNSTREAM WE CAN'T
COMPETE WITH BUILDINGS PEOPLE
AND BUILDINGS ARE BOTH EXPENSIVE
AND YOU CAN'T GET THOSE YOU
SEPARATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LEE
LIKE A YOUNG THE VP OF
OPERATIONS A MISSION NEVER HEARD
CENTERS AND LEAD COORDINATOR OF
THE YOU SEE FACILITIES --
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SAN
FRANCISCO I AM -- FIRST OF ALL I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
WORKING FAMILIES AND OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS -- I AM ALSO
VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF ALSO
FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AND I'M HERE
TO ADVOCATE.
ON THE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE MILLION FOR FACILITIES --
AS AS A PRODUCT OF THE EARLY
HEAD START PROGRAM MYSELF --
BEING PART OF A A HARD WORKING
COMMUNITY BEING PART OF A HARD
WORKING FAMILY THAT NEVER HAD
REALLY GOOD ACCESS TO EDUCATION.
I AM A PRODUCT OF THE VERY --
PROGRAMS THAT WE'RE PUSHING
FORWARD AND I DO SEE THAT THE
GENERATION COMING BEHIND ME AT
THIS NOT HAVE THAT ACCESS.
I EVEN PERSONALLY AND MY FAMILY
I ALREADY SEE THE SET BACKS WITH --
THE YOUNGEST CHILDREN NOT HAVING
HAD ACCESS -- TO EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION -- BEING IN THE WAIT
LIST FOR YEARS AND NEVER HAVING
ACCESS TO THESE PROGRAMS SO WE
REALLY CAN'T TALK ABOUT HAVING
QUALITY.
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE PROGRAMS I
AND LEARNING OPPORTUNITIES
WITHOUT HAVING THE CONVERSATION
OF ADEQUATE SPACES AND
FACILITIES -- CBO'S ARE A
CRITICAL COMPONENT OF
COMMUNITIES AND PROVIDE THE TYPE
OF SERVICES THAT -- ARE TRULY
NECESSARY OF OF THESE
COMMUNITIES INNEED SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP AND
AND WOULD.
I ADVOCATE THAT YOU PLEASE PUSH
FORWARD ON THE TWO HUNDRED FORTY
FIVE MILLION THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH ASKED ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS HAVE A
SUPPORT ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO FUND INFRASTRUCTURE
COST TO ADD NEW CLASSROOMS BASIS
TO IMPLEMENT FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN WITH RECOGNITION
FOR HARDSHIP REQUIREMENTS FOR
SMALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE STAFF
COMMENTS ON PAGE FIVE TO
CONSIDER THE PORTION OF THE NEW
FUNDING FOR NEW FULL DAY
PROGRAMS AND COME TO PRIORITIZE
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS.
HAS ALSO SUPPORTS ADDITIONAL
PRESCHOOL SLOTS AND APPRECIATE
THE FUNDS PROVIDE FOR CHILD CARE
FACILITIES AND WORK FOR SPEAK
YOU.
CHAIRMAN MCCARTY THANK YOU FOR A
REALLY LISTENING TO US AND
HEARING THIS OVER ALL THE YEARS.
IT'S OUR TIME MY NAME IS LAW IN
LONG FROM FACES SF I'M A
REPRESENTATIVE C. C. E. L..
THE COALITION FOR EARLY LEARNING.
AND I WANT JUST TO REITERATE
THAT THE ADVOCACY IN THIS ORDER
HIGHER [inaudible]
ARMOR RATES -- WHAT THE ONE RATE
SYSTEM FIRST IS THE BIFURCATION?
PAY FOR QUALITY.
MORE SLACKS AND FACILITIES IN
TANDEM AND THAT WILL HELP US IN
THE NEXT THREE FIVE YEARS WE'VE
BEEN A STRUGGLE.
FOR A LONG TIME SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHT AND IT'S
OUR TIME NOW SO.
PLEASE PAY IT FORWARD TO THE
YOUNGEST LEARNERS OF OUR STATE
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'M SENDING ME
EVENTS WITH MISSION NEIGHBORHOOD
CENTERS AND SAN FRANCISCO.
AND I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT --
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE CHILDREN
ON THE WAIT LIST WE SERVE --
AROUND FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN SAN
FRANCISCO WITH HEAD START AND
EARLY HEAD START STACKED FUNDING
WITH CD E. FUNDING.
AND WE HAVE A WAIT LIST OF OVER
TWO HUNDRED CHILDREN FOR THE
INFANT AND TODDLER SLOTS THAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE OF SIXTY TWO
SLOTS.
AND WE HAVE -- APPLIED FOR THOSE
EXPANSION FUNDS AND WE'RE
WAITING TO HEAR IF THOSE IF WILL
WE WILL BE ACCEPTED FOR THAT
WERE READY WITH -- WITH NEW
FACILITIES TO BUILD TO BE ABLE
TO EXPAND THOSE SERVICES AND WE
NEED YOUR SUPPORT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THAT SUPPORT
IN THE COMING MONTHS THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MONICA WALTERS CEO
OF WE CHILDREN SERVICES IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION. FOR EARLY
LEARNING AND I WANT TO THANK YOU
AGAIN -- FOR THE WONDERFUL
PRESENTATION THIS MORNING AND
BEING ABLE TO HEAR -- FROM THE
VARIOUS PANELS I WANT TO REALLY
EMPHASIZE A FULL SUPPORT FOR
WHAT AARON GABLE PUT FORWARD IN
TERMS OF THE REGIONALIZATION OF
WHITE PAPER -- I BELIEVE THAT
THE REGIONALIZATION OF RATES --
WILL IN FACT REALLY SERVE.
TO FILL A LOT OF THE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE IN TERMS
OF COMPENSATION.
PRODUCING -- AND AN IMPROVING
AND RETAINING QUALITY OF THE
WORK FORCE.
AND ALSO -- ALLOWING MORE PEOPLE
TO MAYBE THINK ABOUT EXPANDING
SLOTS BECAUSE THEY CAN AFFORD TO
DO THAT WITH THE RATE THAT'S
COMMON THAT COMPENSATES THE WORK
FORCE -- AND IS ABLE TO ATTRACT
AND RETAIN.
QUALITY TEACHERS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MADAM
CONSULTANTS -- JEFF BARKER
REPRESENTING THE RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS --
THIS IS THE SYSTEM THAT MAKES
PROP NINETY EIGHT LOOK SIMPLE --
WE'VE TRIED TO FOCUS OUR EFFORTS --
WITH RESPECT TO ENSURING THAT --
ELLIE A PROVIDERS REMAIN PART OF
A MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM AND HAVE
THE ABILITY -- TO BLAND THE
MERRY AT FUNDING SOURCES THAT
ARE A PART OF THE SYSTEM -- WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF MUCH OF THE
DIRECTION OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL WERE SUPPORTIVE MISTER
CHAIR.
OF DID THE DIRECTION WITHIN THE
ASSEMBLY BLUEPRINT ARE THERE
SIMPLY BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION
AND AND YOU'RE ASSEMBLY BILL.
ONE TWENTY THREE AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE IS -- MONEY
DEVOTED TO PLANNING WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE CONVERSATION
CONTINUE ABOUT HOW TO MAKE ALL
OF THESE DIFFERENT TO SPIRIT
PIECES FIT TOGETHER IN A WAY --
THAT BEST MEETS THE NEEDS TO BE
MEETS THE NEEDS OF BOTH FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MICHAEL
HOLE SIZE ARE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE KERN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS I'LL BE VERY BRIEF ON
ISSUE.
ONE WE JUST WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION AND
SUPPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IN THE GOVERNOR FOR THE
PROPOSAL.
OF US SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR EXPANSION SO THAT
WE CAN PROVIDE A A FULL AND
COMPREHENSIVE KINDERGARTEN
PROGRAM FOR OUR OUR STUDENTS AND
WE WE URGE YOU -- TO CONFIRM
THANK YOU.
HI DENNIE MICHELETTI COLBERT
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION -- ALSO SUPPORTING
ALL THE COMB COMMENTS OF THE SEA
COALITION AS A MEMBER I WANT TO
TALK SPECIFICALLY ON THE
TECHNOLOGY OF FUNDING THAT'S IN
THE AGENDA.
THIS IS DESPERATELY NEEDED BY --
FIGHTERS AND CENTERS AND
CONTRACTORS TO BETTER SUPPORT
FAMILIES -- IT STARTED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THERE WAS A MOVE TO MOVE
TO DIGITAL SIGNATURES AND
ELECTRONIC CHECK IN IF KIDS IN
CENTERS AND THERE'S NEVER BEEN
ANY FUNDING TO HELP SUPPORT
THOSE MOVING FORWARD.
ADDITIONALLY -- MANY OF THE
COMMUNITY CONTRACTORS WANT TO
BEGIN ADDRESSING MANY OF THE
ISSUES THAT ARE IN YOUR THAT
BLUE RIBBON COMMISSION ONE OF
THOSE WE HAVE THE CENTRALIZED
WAITING LIST WHICH IS GREAT.
BUT AWAITING THIS IS DIFFERENT
THAN ACTUALLY DOING THE
ELIGIBILITY DATA AND SUPPORTING
THE TECHNOLOGY WILL BE ABLE TO
DO REAL TIME ELIGIBILITY -- OF
THE FAMILIES AS THEY PUT THEIR
NAMES ON THE LIST WE ASK YOU TO
REALLY SUPPORT THAT -- IN
REGARDS TO THE WORK FORCE WE'D --
ALSO ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
LOOKING AT THE PROVIDERS OF
SUBSIDIZE FAMILIES THE SAME WAY
AND VALUE THEM IN SOME OF THE
SAME WAY AS WE DO OUR PRIVATE
PAY. FOR INSTANCE A SUBSIDIZED
CENTER PROVIDER OR FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOME WHO HAS A SPACE
FOR A SUBSIDIZED FAMILY IF THE
FAMILY DOESN'T SHOW UP FOR ONE
REASON OR ANOTHER DURING THE
MONTH.
THEY'RE NOT PAID FOR THAT
ABSENCE WE PAY FOR SPACES WE
NEED TO VALUE THOSE PROVIDERS
AND LASTLY WE GREATLY VALUE --
INFANT TODDLER BE A FOCUS WE
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
UNDERSTAND FROM THE SUBSIDIZED
CITED THE FOR THE FIELD WE
SUPPORT FAMILIES.
AND SO WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE IN
OUR DATA -- THE MAJORITY OF OF
THE FAMILIES IN THE PROGRAM ARE
MORE THAN JUST INFANT TODDLERS
SO THERE'S A CHALLENGE IF WE
JUST PUT THAT FOCUS THERE THANK
YOU.
HELLO AMERICA PETERSON FROM
BANANAS AND ALAMEDA COUNTY THANK
YOU FOR SOMETIME TALK TODAY --
WELL WE APPRECIATE ALLTHE WORK
THAT THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ASSEMBLY IS DOING.
TO FURTHER THE NEEDS OF THE
CHILDREN IN OUR STATE I WORK AT
A AGENCY THAT HAS.
AND COUNTY THAT HAS THOUSANDS OF
CHILDREN ON THE WAITING LIST.
ARE CURRENTLY ON A PROGRAM OF
BANANAS WE HAVE OVER 60% OF THE
CLIENTS THAT WE SERVE ANA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS ARE
WORKING EVENINGS WEEKENDS.
SO THE DOORS TO THEM ARE CLOSED
WHEN THEY GO LOOKING.
SO -- STRONGLY URGING TODAY THAT
YOU SUPPORT THE NEED FOR MORE
SLOTS FOR ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM SO THAT THOSE DOORS CAN
BE OPENED THANK YOU.
HI TRACY PATTERSON CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATE SO FIRST
THANK YOU FOR THIS HEARING TODAY
I WANT TO ECHO SUPPORT FOR THE
EASY COALITION PACKAGE AS A PART
OF THAT COALITION WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
THE INCREASE LOTS AND RATE
REFORM AND APPRECIATE THE
PARALLELS THAT ERIN GABLES
PRESENTATION TIED TO THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA AND JUST
LIKE IN LCF OFF -- WE DO NOT
EXPECT SCHOOLS TO PAY FOR CHILD
NUTRITION OUT OF THOSE RATES WE
SHOULD NOT EXPECT CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO PAY FOR FOOD OUT OF
THEIR RATES.
AND WE NEED TO RE ESTABLISH A
SYSTEM THAT HAS CATEGORICAL
CHILD NUTRITION FUNDING RUNNING
ALONG SIDE THE RATES AND
AVAILABLE TO CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS TO SERVE FOOD AND FOR
KIDS AND CARE.
WE APPRECIATE YOU HAVE ALWAYS
SUPPORTED THIS REQUEST THE
ASSEMBLY HAS ALWAYS CHAMPIONED
IT'S PART OF THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION WE JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE TAKING A
HOLISTIC APPROACH THIS YEAR WITH
THE NEW ADMINISTRATION.
THAT WE MAKE SURE TO GET THIS
DONE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON BACK UPON WITH
FIRST FIVE LA -- LIKE MY
PREVIOUS COLLEAGUES STATED FIRST
HEAVILY SUPPORTS THE C.
COALITIONS BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
ADDRESSES ACCESS REIMBURSEMENT
RATE REFORM FACILITIES AND WORK
FORCE.
THERE'S A CRITICAL NEED TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO THOSE FAMILIES
AND CHILDREN MOST IN NEED AND WE
SUPPORT THE BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
THESE FAMILIES AND CHILDREN.
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE CHILD CARE
RATE STABILIZATION PROPOSAL TO
BETTER ALIGN OUR STAGE RATE
STRUCTURE TO TRULY COVER THE
COST OF CARE.
AND FINALLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH BOTH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AROUND THE PROPOSED
WORK FOR SOME FACILITY
INVESTMENTS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS GREG BOTH COVERAGE
ON A WITH COULD I GO -- HEY JUST
TO READ A SHORT STATEMENT FROM
ONE OF OUR PARENTS SHE COULDN'T
MAKE IT TODAY UNFORTUNATELY.
HELLO MY NAME IS THAT FOR STUDY
I HAVE TWO CHILDREN WHO ARE
ATTENDING COULD I GUESS CALL
SOMEONE CHILD CARE CENTER IN
OAKLAND.
MOTHER WITH AN ITALIAN IS FOUR
YEARS OLD I'M A SUN ONE CALL US
AT TWO YEARS OLD.
I WANT MORE FAMILIES HAVE ACCESS
TO GREAT CHAU CAT LIKE WE HAVE.
MY THREE CHILDREN HAVE
BENEFITTED IMMENSELY FROM THE
EARLY HEAD START PROGRAM.
I'M MOTOR TONYA RIGHTS WAY WHEN
THE SENDS OPEN TWO YEARS AGO BUT
IT DIDN'T STOP INFANTS SO I
FOUND A HOME BASED A CAP ONE
CALL US.
HI THERE WAS AN INCIDENT AT THE
DAYCARE THAT RESULTED IN A
HOSPITAL VISITS.
IT SHOOK MY CONFIDENCE AND I
DIDN'T FEEL LIKE A TRUST ANYONE
ELSE WITH MY SON SO I QUIT MY
JOB TO TAKE CARE OF HIM MYSELF.
NATALIA WAS FLOURISHING ACOSTA
MONTHS AND MAKING BIG STRIDES IN
A DEVELOPMENTS I ALSO DEVELOPS
WONDERFUL RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
TEACHERS AND SO FAST AND THE
SUPPORTING CAST OF A PROVIDED
EVERY CHILD.
IT WAS THIS THE GAVE ME THE
ABILITY TO TRUST IN SOMEONE ELSE
TO TAKE CARE OF ONE CALL US.
ON A ROAD IN WHEN HE WAS
SEVENTEEN MONTHS OLD AND I WAS
ABLE TO GO BACK TO WORK.
THE SUPPORT OFFERED BY TEACHERS
AND FAMILY ADVOCATES HAS BEEN
AMAZING BOTH IN TERMS OF HELPING
MY CHILDREN DEVELOP AND IN
PROVIDING ME WITH THE SKILLS AND
RESOURCES TO SUPPORT MY KIDS
INCLUDING HELP WITH PLACES TO
LIVE.
BOTH OF MY KIDS ABOUT WHAT HAVE
HAD HELP WITH SPEECH DELAYS.
THE TEACHERS ALSO HOW MAY HAVE
TIPPED SARCOMERE THE THINGS THEY
LEARN AT SCHOOL AT HOME.
I HAD YOU TO EXPAND HIGH QUALITY
PROGRAMS FOR INFANTS AND
TODDLERS TO MORE -- FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CATHERINE
OCCURRED ON ON BEHALF OF COPYING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER WERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE EASY COLLISIONS
BUDGET ASK AND ARE PARTICULARLY
EXCITED ABOUT THE PROPOSAL TO
ADDRESS THE COMPREHENSIVE NEEDS
OF THE WORK FORCE THANK YOU --
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS CINDY
CAMERA AND I'M A MEMBER OF BUT
INVOICES IN MARINE CHAPTER -- MY
HUSBAND AND I HAVE THREE
CHILDREN. ONE IS A YEARS OLD
DEAL ALL FOUR YEARS OR EIGHT
FOUR YEARS OLD AND TWO YEARS.
OLD WE HAVE BEEN WAITING ON THE
WE HAVE BEEN ON THE WAITING LIST
FOR THREE YEARS OR LONGER.
MY HUSBAND IS THE SOLE BREAD
WINNER IN THE FAMILY AND TRIES
TO PICK UP AS MANY HOURS AS HE
CANCEL WE CAN MAKE AND THEN
SMITH -- BUT HE SAID HI COSTS
COUNTY AND LAB LANDLORDS TO NOT
ALLOW A FAMILY OF FIVE THREE AND
TO LEAVE IN ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT.
SO MOST OF OUR INCOME GOES TO
PAY ACTIVATE FOR TWO BEDROOM
APARTMENT WE DO NOT HAVE A
SUPPORT SYSTEM OF FAMILY AND
FRIENDS THAT CAN HELP US ADDING.
TO THE ISOLATION WE FEEL IT'S
ESPECIALLY THE FEET DIFFICULT
BECAUSE MY FOUR YEAR OLD HAS A
SPECIAL NEEDS.
INCLUDING ARTICULATION FOR NO
LOGICAL DISORDER MEANS MAKE BUS
RECEPTIVE.
EXPRESSION LANGUAGE DISORDER AND
SPEECH DISTURBANCES.
HE'S A SPECIAL A SPECIAL NEEDS
CHILD AND NOW WILL THERAPY TWICE
A WEEK A WEEK.
I CAN BRING MY TWO YEAR OLD TO
THOSE APPOINTMENTS AND BECAUSE
SHE'S NEVER HAD CHECK ACTUALLY
EASING COFFEE THAN GOING TO A
PRINTER.
SO MY HUSBAND AND I TAKE DOORS
AT THE ANY THERAPY OR WATCHING
MY DAUGHTER.
BUT MY HUSBAND HAS A VEHICLE FOR
TO DO THAT SOMETIMES WE REALLY
CAN'T AFFORD THAT.
I ALSO SUFFER FROM POST PARTUM
DEPRESSION COMBINED WITH THE
PATIENT THE NEEDS TO BE WENT
MEDICAID.
BEING ON THE WAITING LIST HAS
THE LAY MY PLANS OF COULD BE MY
FAMILY.
I ATTENDED COLLEGE WITH DROP OUT
WHEN I WAS PREGNANT WITH MY
SECOND CHILD.
IF I HAD IT CHECK ARRESTING THEM.
I COULD HELP REALLY RELIEF MIGHT
BE ENOUGH FINANCIAL STRESS FOR
MY FAMILY.
MY CHILDREN AND MY HUSBAND COULD
HAVE MORE FOR ME.
I WOULD BE A HELP YOUR MOM
SOMEONE THAT WOULD WORK AND
THINK YOU KNOW MY MENTAL CAN
BECAUSE I KNOW I NEED IT.
I COULD TAKE CLASSES AND FINISH
AWARE STARTED YEARS AGO.
I WANT TO BE A ROLE MODEL FOR MY
CHILD AND SHOW THEM.
BUT MY GOAL IS TO HAVE MY
CHILDREN TO GET THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO LEARN.
AND TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN LIFE AND
BE OUR FUTURE BECAUSE THEY ARE
OUR FUTURE.
MY DREAM IS TO LOOK LIKE TO YOU
MIGHT THINK THE ICE AND STATE IT
TOOK ME A YEAR BUT I FINALLY DID
IT YOUR MOM IS HEALTHY AND HAVE
A DEGREE.
SO I PLEASE MAKE YOU TO INVEST
ONE BILLION IN CHECK -- FOR THE
NEXT THREE YEARS. TO PLEASE --
HELP THOSE IN.
WAITING LIST AND GIVE US MORE
VOUCHERS WE WANT TO BE HEALTHY
LOVING WORKING FAMILIES AND WE
NEED YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO AB MY NAME'S MOHNISH ERIC
AND I BROUGHT A STORY FROM THE
FAMILY AND THAT WITH PARENT
VOICES CONTRA COSTA.
IT'S A SUCCESS STORY IT WAS A
FAMILY WHO WAS ABLE TO GET ON AT
THE PROGRAM THROUGH VOUCHER.
AND THE THE DOWN SIDE OF IT IS
THAT THE WAY SHE GOT ON WAS AT
AT AT RISK SITUATION.
SO A LOT OF THE VOUCHERS ARE
GOING TOWARDS AT RISK OR CPS AND
SO A LOT OF OUR WORKING FAMILIES
ARE NOT RECEIVING -- CHILD CARE
AND THERE THEY NEEDED JUST AS
BADLY SO I JUST WANTED TO SHARE
THE STORY I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND
PASS IT OUT IF THAT'S OKAY.
PLEASE SAID THINK ABOUT PUTTING
SOME OF THAT MONEY INTO OUR WAIT
LIST WE HAVE ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION TWO MILLION CHILDREN I'M
SORRY WAITING.
GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS L.
SIGN I AM FROM -- PAM VOICES IN
NOW MONEY CHAPTER AND I'M ALSO --
JUST BABY YOU TO PLEASE INVEST
OF THE ONE MILLION DOLLAR FOR
THE FAMILIES ON THE WAITING LIST
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS MAHDI AND THE
PARROT PREPARE VOICES TO
FRANCISCO CHAPTER -- I JUST
MIGHT TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF MY
STORY.
I WHEN I WAS TURNED OUT MAYBE
FOUR MONTHS PREGNANT FIVE MONTHS
PREGNANT I PUT MYSELF ON THE S.
OF THREE C. WAITING LIST SO I
CAN RECEIVE CHILDCARE SUBSIDY.
BECAUSE I WAS WORKING THE JOB OF
MY DREAMS I LOVE MY JOB.
I WORK FOR JEWISH CASUAL
SERVICES WORKING WITH STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND THAT AT
THE FEWEST DE HELPING THEM GET
THEIR DREAM FIRST PAYCHECK JOB.
I WAS DOING MY JOB AND WENT
AROUND MY BABY WAS AROUND SIX
MONTHS MY NAME IS STILL NOT
CALLED FOR THE CHILD CARE --
SUBSIDY WAITING LIST THIS IS I
WAITED OVER A YEAR MEMBER I
APPLIED TO MY SECOND TRIMESTER
OF PREGNANCY.
AND WHEN MY CHILD IS AROUND SIX
MONTHS I THOUGHT I HEARD MY NAME
CALLED -- UNFORTUNATELY.
I WAS ABLE NOT ABLE TO GO BACK
TO MY JOB I DID APPLY FOR CAO
WORKS AT THAT TIME.
AND THEN THE COW WORKS TARGET
BENEFIT -- DIDN'T COME UNTIL TWO
MONTHS LATER SO I MISSED THE
MARK OF BEING ABLE TO MY BACK TO
MY JOB.
AND THAT DAY THEN I WOULD POST
REPORT BACK TO MY JOB I REALIZED
I WAS THE DEATH OF MY CAREER.
AND STILL NOT WORKING I AM STILL
ON CAL WORKS SO IF THERE WAS A
CHILD CARE WAITING LISTS LOT FOR
ME I WANT TO BE THE POSITION
THAT I'M IN.
CURRENTLY RIGHT NOW AND I'M A
SOLO PARENTS TO WHEN I'M NOT
WORKING IN THE HOUSEHOLD
NOBODY'S WORKING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE
INVEST ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR A
FAMILY CHILDCARE SLOTS NOW SO
THERE'S NOT ANOTHER PARENT WENT
UP LIKE ME.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS NAY JOAN ALLEN
WOULD -- I AM ALSO A SOLO
PARENTS I I'VE BEEN A SPECIAL
EDUCATION EDUCATOR FOR ABOUT
SIXTEEN YEARS AND ONCE I HAD MY
CHILD I HAD TO STOP WORKING --
AND SO NOW I AM ALSO WAITING TO
HAVE CHILD CARE AND I'M HOPING
THAT -- EVENTUALLY I CAN'T GET
CHILD CARE SO I CAN GO BACK TO
BEING AN EDUCATOR.
AND WE'VE BEEN TALKING ALL DAY
ABOUT -- WE WANT TO HAVE REALLY
GOOD EDUCATORS IN OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEMS AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE OUR CHILDREN ALSO BE
WATCHED I WANT MY CHILD TO HAVE
THE BEST EDUCATION THAT HE CAN
POSSIBLY HAVE WHETHER HE HAS
SPECIAL NEEDS OR NOT AND HE DOES
NOT.
BUT I DO HAVE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO
DO HAVE CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS AND SO JUST THINKING ABOUT
ALL THESE DIFFERENT OPTIONS WE
NEED THAT FINANCIAL HELP AND TO
GET US BACK INTO THE WORKFORCE
WHETHER I WANT TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL WHETHER I WANT TO BE ABLE.
TO GO BACK TO WORK AND SO I
REALLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO GET THIS
ONE BILLION DOLLARS FOR OUR
EDUCATION AND FOR OUR CHILDREN'S
EDUCATION MEANS.
AND SO I THINK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THIS AND I'M ALSO
WITH TRAIL -- PARENT VOICES BUT
I AM.
WAS ORIGINALLY FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I'VE WORKED IN LOW
INCOME -- COMMUNITIES ON
RESERVATIONS AND I'VE SEEN THE
DIFFERENCES.
IN OUR ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE OUR CHILDREN IN.
CARE AND SO I REALLY URGE THIS
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OF GOOD MORNING OR IS IT
AFTERNOON WHEN HE WAS MAYBE LOS
RAMMED ORGANIZER PARENT VOICES
FOR LIKE TWENTY THREE YEARS NOW
AND EVERY YEAR COME BACK AND ASK
FOR THE SAME THING.
BUT THIS YEAR WE HAVE A GOLDEN
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE WE HAVE A
GOVERNOR'S REALLY COMMITTED TO
ENDING CHILD POVERTY.
AND HOPEFULLY ALSO ENDING THE
POVERTY OF ARE YOU SEE EDUCATORS --
WHEN I FIRST STARTED WORKING
TWENTY THREE YEARS AGO?
BEFORE THAT IT WAS A STAY AT
HOME MOM FOR THREE YEARS I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT.
BECOMING A MOTHER WOULD MAKE ME
POOR I WENT TO LAW SCHOOL BUT
THEN IF YOU DON'T HAVE CHILD
CARE AND YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
FAMILY. TO HELP YOU YOU'RE ON
YOUR OWN.
US WILL WHEN I FIRST STARTED
WORKING I WAS SO HAPPY THEN THE
FIRST -- PAYCHECK CAME AND IT
WAS JUST ENOUGH TO PAY FOR
CHILDCARE I WAS SO DESPERATE SO
I CALLED A SUMMER SCHOOL TALK
LINE AND THEY SENT ME A CHECK BE
THE FIRST.
OF FAMILY FEE OR OR JUST THE
FULL FEE FOR FOR CHILD CARE FOR
MY DAUGHTER MY SON AT THE TIME
WAS ATING PRESCHOOL.
THEN MY PARENTS CAME FOR A VISIT --
AND THEY OFFERED TO TAKE THE
CHILDREN WITH THEM.
AND I HARD AND LONG SHOULD I
PULL MY SON OUT OF PRESCHOOL SO
THAT MY DAUGHTER.
COULD BE TAKEN CARE OF BOTH OF
THEM COULD BE TAKEN CARE OF BY
MY PARENTS.
AND I MADE A TOUGH DECISION.
UGH THEY THEY LEFT THE COUNTRY
AND EVERY TIME.
I SEE BABIES IN STROLLERS I
WOULD CRY AND JUST FEEL GUILTY
YEAH BUT I DON'T.
THE MY CHILDREN AROUND ME.
SO EVENTUALLY I WAS ABLE TO
RAISE ENOUGH MONEY TO BRING IT
BACK.
IN A PHONE UP THE SUCK TWENTY
QUALIFIED FOR CHILD CARE BECAUSE
I WAS.
IN IN THE OLD.
TEN BUT BUT THE WAITING LIST
THERE WAS NO -- CARE FOR INFANTS
THERE WAS NO SUPPLY AVAILABLE
AND I COULDN'T AFFORD TO PAY.
WHAT I HAVE BEEN BUT EVENTUALLY
THEY CAME BACK AND THAT THE
SAPPY ENDING AND I GOT SUBSIDY?
AND I WISH THAT -- FAMILIES
DON'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH THAT
AND I I REALLY URGE YOU THAT --
IN THIS TIME WHEN THIS FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD.
THAT WE COULD -- SOME HELP PUT
OUR MONEY WHERE OUR HEARTS ARE
AND AND MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN GET ACCESS CHILD CARE
AND THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M JENNIFER
CRAPPIE WITH PERRIN PLACES
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE IFTEEN
CHAPTERS OF PARENT VOICES ACROSS
THE STATE.
AND IN THE LAST SIX WEEKS I'VE
BEEN TRAVELING AROUND THE THE
STATE -- PROVIDING TRAINING AND
INFORMATION TO FAMILIES ABOUT
WHAT'S IN OUR GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AND AFTER YOU KNOW THEM SORT OF
HEARING THE INFORMATION ONE
THING WAS VERY CLEAR TO THEM
WHICH WAS THAT THERE WAS NO
FUNDING FOR THE THINGS THAT THEY
ACTUALLY NEEDED RIGHT NOW.
IN THE EARLY CHILDHOOD SPACE.
WHILE THERE WERE OTHER POLICIES --
INCREASED INCOME EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDITS PAID FAMILY LEAVEA
CAL GRANTS MANY OTHER WONDERFUL
POLICIES THAT WILL HELP THEIR
FAMILY.
IN THE EARLY CHILDHOOD SPACE.
THERE WAS REALLY.
NOTHING FOR THE FAMILIES ON THE
WAITING LIST.
AND THEY JUST DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
THAT.
AND I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW.
WE ARE LOOKING AT A A BUDGET
THIS YEAR THAT IS FINDING ABOUT
A LITTLE LESS THAN A THOUSAND
SPOTS FOR OUR WAITING LIST
FAMILIES -- THROUGH A P.
VOUCHERS.
AND I REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE TO YOU KNOW BLOW THAT
NUMBER.
UP BY [inaudible]
YOU KNOW. HUNDRED FULL IF IF IT
WAS MY BUDGET TO TO TO FIGURE
OUT -- BUT WHAT WHAT I DID OFFER
YOU TODAY WAS TO REALLY
IMPORTANT DOCUMENTS. ONE IS ARE
WAITING FOR CHANGE -- REPORT
THAT WE DID ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO
THAT PUTS A REAL FACE ON THESE
FAMILIES WHO ARE WAITING ON A
CHILD CARE WAITING LIST.
AS WELL AS AN ARTICLE FROM THE
HUFFINGTON POST THAT HIGHLIGHTS
ONE OF OUR MEMBERS FROM SMITH
CINEMA COUNTY AND I REALLY
ENCOURAGE YOU TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THESE TWO DOCUMENTS -- BECAUSE I
I JUST CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH THAT
EVERY YEAR THAT WE WAIT TO
INVEST IN THESE FAMILIES THESE
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION KIDS.
WHO ARE ON OUR WAITING LIST?
IS ANOTHER GENERATION OF KIDS
LOS THANK YOU THANK THANK YOU
AND I AS ONE OF THE I TRY TO
GIVE A LOT OF LEEWAY TO PARENTS
WHO CAME ALL THE WAY HERE TO
SACRAMENTO THIS IS YOUR STATE
CAPITOL.
BUT WHEN I MAKE SURE WE KEEP IT
TO ONE MINUTE WE HAVE TO MOVE ON
WITH THEIR HEARING THANK YOU.
THE CENTERS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION AND AS HE ARE YOU
CALIFORNIA WHEN I SAY WE ARE
VERY APPRECIATIVE.
OF THE DIALOGUE THAT WE HEARD
TODAY REGARDING THE INADEQUACY
OF WAGES WE'D LIKE THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER A COUPLE OF CONCERNS
WE HAVE AS THE COMMITTEE STARTS
TO THINK THROUGH WORK THROUGH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT -- ONE OF
THE CONCERNS WE HAVE IS THAT
ENSURING THAT THERE'S NOT A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL -- APPROACH TO ON
GOING EDUCATIONAL REQUIREMENTS
OR ANY ADDITIONAL PROFESSIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR EXISTING
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEES AND PARA
PROFESSIONAL EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
WORKING IN EARLY CHILDHOOD PUT
EDUCATION AND THAT THERE BE A
GRANDFATHERING CLAUSE. FOR ANY
SORT OF ON GOING EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS WERE ALSO CONCERNED
THAT THOSE EDUCATIONAL
ADDITIONAL REQUIREMENTS -- FOR
PROFESSIONAL BUT DEVELOPMENT BE
ACCOMMODATED IN A WAY THAT THEY
CAN BE UNDERTAKEN DURING WORK
HOURS AND PARTICULARLY THAT THEY
NOT BE PAID FOR OUT OF THE
EMPLOYEES POCKETS.
AS WE'VE HAD A LONG DISCUSSION
ABOUT WAGES ARE SORELY
INADEQUATE AND SO TO WORK CHOIR
ADDITIONAL EDUCATION THAT IS AT
A COST TO THESE EMPLOYEES WOULD
BE UNTENABLE REQUIREMENT IMPOSED
ON THEM -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR BUT
REALLY YOU ON BEHALF OF THE U.
D. W. ASKED ME LOCAL.
THREE NINE THIRTY THANK YOU FOR
THAT PANEL DISCUSSIONS TODAY I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SPECIFICALLY AS A PERTAINS TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE MOMS
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL AB -- THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT FOR COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS AS YOU'VE HEARD I
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
OF THE THE ONES THE PROVIDERS
MADE BEFORE ABOUT THE NEED TO
ENSURE A LIVING WAGE.
AND TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
TRAINING.
AS PART OF THE EASY COALITION I
WOULD ALSO LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
SLOTS AS WELL AS GETTING TO A
BETTER REIMBURSEMENT RATES SO.
LOOKING INTO MORE REFORM IN THAT
AREA.
AND WE ARE ALSO SUPPORTIVE OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY STE
PROPOSAL TO REQUIRE GUIDELINES
FOR THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
RETENTION SYSTEM THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MY NAME
IS JACKIE LONG TIME WITH GRACE
WITH AND WE MANAGED AND SHALL
PARTYING CAMPAIGN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF OUR WORK.
I'M HERE TO CONFORM TO THE
COMMENTS OF THE EASY COALITION
AS WELL AS PARENT VOICES AND CAP
BY MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
ACCESS -- IN OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
FROM ZERO EIGHT TO CHILDCARE
SLOTS -- SO I I WE KNOW THAT
BORN IN FIFTY THOUSAND CHILDREN
LIVE IN DEEP POVERTY EVERY
SINGLE DAY TODAY.
ON IN ABJECT POVERTY WE KNOW
THAT CHILD CARE CAN MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN LIFTING THOSE
FAMILIES UP AND OUT OF POVERTY
AS THEY SEEK EMPLOYMENT.
AS THEY ACTUALLY -- PIECEMEAL AT
TWO TO THREE JOBS -- TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE MAKING
ENDS MEET FOR THEIR FAMILY -- AS
ANOTHER HAT I AM AS YOU KNOW
IT'S ON THE BORDER OF A LOCAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND I AND WE
CREATED A SURVEY RECENTLY OF OUR
PARENTS AND CHILD CARE IS ONE OF
THEIR NUMBER ONE KIND OF
PRIORITIES AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT I WANT.
FOLKS TO KIND OF FOCUS AND THINK
ABOUT -- ABOUT ENCOURAGING AND
MORE INVESTMENT IN CHILDCARE
SLOTS -- LASTLY I ALSO -- WANT
TO SUPPORT THE IDEA ABOUT COULD
COLLEGE SAVINGS ACCOUNTS WHICH
YOU KNOW WITH SACRAMENTO AS A
BIG SUPPORT BY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE STILL
PREVENTS HE WITH TODAY GO WE
JOIN OTHERS IN APPLAUDING THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IN THE
PROGRESS TOWARDS PRESCHOOL FOR
ALL INVESTMENTS AND FACILITIES
INVENT INFRASTRUCTURE -- AND WE
JOIN OUR EASY -- COLLISION
COLLEAGUES IN ASKING FOR MORE ON
GOING -- SUPPORT FOR CHILD CARE
ACCESS AND FACILITIES AND WORK
FORCE AS WELL AS RATE REFORM.
I ALSO WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT
THE NEED PARTICULARLY FOR
INVESTMENT IT'S IN INFANTS AND
TODDLERS -- AND HIGH QUALITY
STICK FAMILY CENTERED SERVICES%
FOR THOSE CHILDREN -- SO REALLY
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO'S
PROPOSAL ON TO TO PROVIDE THAT
KIND OF COMPREHENSIVE SUPPORT
BASED ON ON THE EARLY HEAD START
MODEL TO ENSURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN ARE READY -- READY FOR
SCHOOL AND ALSO HAVE THE FULL
DAY FULL YEAR CARE THAT THEY
NEED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR PAMELA
GIVES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION I'LL BE VERY BRIEF
LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
REPRESENTATIVE. TO THE POINT SHE
MAY REGARDING THE NEED FOR SO
MANY CHILDREN WITHIN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FOR A SERVICES AND
PRESCHOOL AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION -- LASTLY -- I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THE ISSUE --
OF THE RECOMMENDATION BY THE LA --
TO DELAY -- GOING FORWARD WITH
THAT TWO HUNDRED FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FACILITIES FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WE KNOW THIS EXPANSION
ISN'T JUST STARTING THIS YEAR WE
KNOW THIS COMMITTEE.
HAS BEEN VERY FORTHCOMING AND
PROMOTING EXPANSION OF PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS FOR MANY YEARS AND SO
THE FACILITIES ARE NEEDED NOW.
ON WE DON'T WANT TO WAIT ON THAT --
WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A STRATEGIC
PLAN THAT CD IS WORKING ON THAT
WILL BE DUE IN DECEMBER.
NINETEEN SO WE FULLY SUPPORT THE
WORK THAT THEY'RE DOING BUT WE
THINK THE FACILITY SHOULD GO
FORWARD IN TANDEM.
AND WE WOULD BE THEN UTILIZING
WHATEVER RECOMMENDATIONS THEY
MAKE AT THAT POINT BUT TO
CONTINUE FORWARD WITH THE
FUNDING THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
IGNACIO CAR THAN US -- WITH ON
BEHALF OF YOUR E. W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS ARE INVALUABLE
VOICE AS OUR STATE TRIES TO
BUILD A STRONGER CHILD CARE
SYSTEM.
BUT FOR MANY YEARS CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES WHO NEED CARE THE MOST
AND PROVIDERS WHO CANNOT EARN A
LIVING WAGE DOING THE WORK HAVE
BEEN LEFT OUT.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BUILDING BETTER
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION ACT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
KAREN GABLE ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
APPLAUD GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S
POLICY VISION FOR UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL AND FOR FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN.
AND HIS STRATEGIC INVESTMENT OF
ROBUST ONE TIME FUNDS AND
NECESSARY WORK FORCE OF FACILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE TOWARD THESE
GOALS.
FURTHER WE SUPPORT THE EASY
COALITIONS AUGMENTATIONS TO THE
JANUARY BUDGET FOR CRUCIAL CHILD
CARE SERVICES AND INFRASTRUCTURE
POLICY.
ON THE LAST ISSUE COLLEGE
SAVINGS ACCOUNTS FOR FIVE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN IN DIALOGUE
WITH THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION
ABOUT THEIR PILOT WE STAND READY
TO PARTNER IN THEIR EFFORTS TO
EXPAND THE BEST PRACTICES.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND I DEBORAH
BROWN ON BEHALF OF A CHILDREN
NOW LIKE OTHERS BEFORE BEFORE ME
WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S AT AT IT SIGNALING
HIS STRONG COMMITMENT.
TO INCREASING ACCESS IN THE
QUALITY OF OUR EARLY EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND STARTING THE
CONVERSATION IN JANUARY OFF ON
THE RIGHT FOOT AND LIKE OTHERS
IN THE AT YOU SEE COALITION WE
ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S THAT
IT'S NOT ENOUGH AND WE DO NEED.
TO TO DO MORE AND SO WE'RE
APPRECIATIVE AND GRATEFUL OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR FOR THEIR
PROPOSALS TO REALLY MAKE THOSE --
STRONGER INVESTMENTS AND AND
AROUND ACCESS AND AND QUALITY IN
PARTICULAR AROUND AT THE NEED TO
ADDRESS A MORE ON FACILITIES --
INFANT TODDLER AT ACCESS AND
ALSO RATE REFORM -- AND AS WERE
MAKING STRIDES IN THESE
INVESTMENTS WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE INSURING WE'RE
PROVIDING OUR KIDS WITH A HIGH
QUALITY LEARNING PROGRAM INTO
THIS ALSO MEANS.
INCREASING PROFESSIONAL
QUALIFICATIONS THAT ARE
SUPPORTED BY -- AT THAT THAT THE
THAT RECEIVE SUPPORT TO MEET
THOSE QUALIFICATIONS AND ALSO
ARE COUPLED WITH HIGHER
COMPENSATION AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OTHER SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI CATIONS A WAY FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHILDCARE RESOURCE
AND REFERRAL NETWORK FIRST I
WANT TO GIVE EXTREME THANKS --
TO A WITNESS FROM THE ISSUE FOR
JACQUELYN FOR TAKING TIME OFF OF
WORK.
ON TO COME HERE AND SHARE HER
TRUTH.
THE NETWORK SUPPORTS THE EASY
EASY COALITION ASK -- BUT TODAY
I CAME WITH OTHER THOUGHTS IN
MIND BUT AFTER TODAY'S HEARING.
THIS IS WHAT I LIKE TO SHARE
WITH YOU I WANT TO REFERENCE THE
B. R. C. RECOMMENDATIONS -- AND
THE STRONG THEME THROUGHOUT THAT
ACKNOWLEDGESTHE ROLE OF
IMPLICIT BIAS PLAYED IN CREATING
OUR SYSTEM AND THE PERVASIVENESS
IN HARMING FAMILIES AND CHILDREN
PROVIDERS IN OUR CURRENT SYSTEM.
WITHOUT WINDS IF ONE WAS ONLY
LISTEN TODAY'S TESTIMONY -- FROM
THE HEARING TODAY WE WOULD ONLY
THINK THAT THE ONLY GOOD PLACE
FOR CHILDREN IS IN HIGH QUALITY
CENTERS.
UNTIL THE PANEL FOR ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR THE TONE TODAY HAVE BEEN
ELITIST AND PRIVILEGED IGNORING
THE IMPORTANCE OF ALL SETTINGS
AND THE FACT THAT HIGH QUALITY
IS FOUND IN ALL SETTINGS.
IGNORING THE IMPORTANCE OF HOME
BY THE SETTINGS INCLUDING FAMILY
CHILDCARE HOMES AND FAMILY
FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR NOT ONLY
BECAUSE THE HOURS MAY FADE OR
THE COST OR LOCATION BUT ALSO
BECAUSE THE HOME ENVIRONMENT MAY
JUST BE WHAT THE FAMILY WANTS.
IT MAYBE THE SETTING THAT BEST
FITS BEST FITS CULTURAL OR
LINGUISTIC NEEDS AND THOSE
THINGS ARE VITAL AND IMPORTANT
TO CLOSING THE OPPORTUNITY CAT.
FIGHTING IMPLICIT BIAS IS HARD
WORK BUT NOT IMPOSSIBLE ALL
DISCUSSIONS AND INVESTMENTS
MOVING FORWARD MUST INCLUDE ALL
SETTINGS ALL PROVIDERS AND
RECOGNIZE OUR COMPLETE SYSTEM
THANK YOU.
ON A HOUSE ABOUT WITH UNITED
WAYS -- OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED FUNDING FOR EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION AS WELL AS THE
EFFORTS OF THE YOU SEE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION -- UNITED WAY
OF CALIFORNIA SUPPORTIVE OF THE
EASY COALITION PROPOSALS
PRESENTED ON TODAY REGARDING
INCREASING CHILD SPACES FACILITY
IMPROVEMENTS AND RATE REFORM TO
ENSURE.
HEALTHY CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT
AND IMPROVED EXPERIENCES TODAY
FOR BETTER OUTCOMES TOMORROW
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEVIN HICKEY
REDUCE ROTATIONAL SERVICE AND
SAN FRANCISCO PART OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR EARLY
LEARNING I'M HERE TO ENDORSE TO
KEY PRIORITIES INCREASED
INVESTMENTS IN THE EASY WORK THE
C. E. WORKFORCE TRAINING.
WITH AN EYE TOWARDS THE DIVERSE
NEEDS OF OUR EARLY LEARNERS IT'S
CLEAR THAT THE LABOR MARKET IS
STARVING FOR QUALIFIED TEACHERS.
AND ALSO TO ENDORSE THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION'S
RECOMMENDATIONS AROUND
MODERNIZING AND INVESTING IN THE
COMPENSATION SYSTEM.
THE STATE WOULD DO WELL TO LINK
ITS OVERALL WORKFORCE STRATEGY
FOR HIGH GROWTH HIGH WAGE JOBS
AND FRIENDSHIPS TO THE EASY WORK
FORCE THE GROWTH IS THERE BUT
THE WAGES ARE NOT.
I WORRY EVERYDAY THAT GPS IS
WORK TO PREPARE HIGH QUALITY
TEACHERS IS LEADING TO A PATH OF
POVERTY RATHER THAN SELF
SUFFICIENCY I POUR THE STATE TO
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS THANK YOU.
HELLO AND CHRISTINE'S OUR JANICE
I COORDINATE THE JBS THE SECRET
PATHWAY PROGRAM I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS -- THE NEED FOR
REGIONALES REIMBURSEMENT RATES
TO ALL STATE SET US UP TODAY'S
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
PROGRAMS WITH THE CURRY
MERCENARY SYSTEM TEACHERS LIVING
IN HIGH COST OF LIVING AREAS
CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE WHERE THEY
TEACH THIS LEADS TO HIGHER
TEACHER TURNOVER AND TO
CLASSROOMS.
AND THE CURRENT TEACHER SHORTAGE
CRISIS THAT THREE BEING
EXPERIENCED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA AND OTHER AREAS AND IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- AS A
COORDINATOR OF THIS PROGRAM I
VISITED NUMEROUS -- EARLY CARE
AND EDUCATION SITES AND HAVE
SEEN MD CLASSROOMS THESE EMPTY
CLASSROOMS ARE NOT BECAUSE OF
LACK OF CHILDREN THAT NEED CARE
AND QUALITY -- EDUCATION BUT DUE
TO INABILITY TO HIGHER QUALITY --
QUALIFIED WORKFORCE AND KEEP
THAT STAFF -- IN THOSE
CLASSROOMS -- HAVE SOME LETTERS
FROM MY PARTICIPANTS IN THE
PROGRAM THEY'RE GOING TO BE THE
NEW WORK FORCE I'M EXPRESSING
THIS NEED FOR THAT REGIONALES
REIMBURSED EVERY SYSTEMS THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS AMBER LEE SAM
RIGHT.
TALK ABOUT WHY A COUPLE REGIONAL
WHO RECORD EQUITABLE REGIONAL AS
REIMBURSEMENT RATES ARE
IMPORTANT EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS IN CALIFORNIA.
AS A CURRENT STUDENT AN EDUCATOR
IN THE EARLY CHILDHOOD FIELD
LIVING IN THE BAY AREA.
I DON'T EARN ENOUGH TO HELP PAY
BILLS TUITION OR INVEST MY
CAREER DEVELOPMENT.
AS A STUDENT I'VE SEEN MY
CLASSMATES DROP OUT OF THE FIELD
BECAUSE THEY COULDN'T SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILY WITH THE WAGES THAT
THEY AREN'T.
TEACHER COMPENSATION AND HIGH
COST CITIES IS NOT PROVIDING
ENOUGH.
I COME FROM A FAMILY OF TEACHERS
MY MOM AND GRANDMOTHER TEACH
EARLY CHILDHOOD.
AND BECAUSE I GREW UP IN THE
SORT OF ENVIRONMENT I WANT TO
CONTINUE MY CAREER AS A TEACHER
AND HELP OTHERS BECOME TEACHERS.
BUT I SEE THE STRUGGLE OF
PURSUING AND STAYING IN THIS
FIELD OF WORK CALIFORNIA HAS TO
RECOGNIZE THE ANNEX INEQUITY OF
PAYING TEACHERS FOR AND THE
STATE SO THAT WE CAN SET A GOOD
PATH FOR FUTURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO BUT I'M MERRY BREEDING
WITH CALIFORNIANS FOR QUALITY
EARLY LEARNING.
AND FIRST I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR NOT ONLY HAVING THE FOCUS
AGAIN ON EARLY EDUCATION BUT I
FEEL LIKE.
THE MOMENTUM AND THERE'S THE
GOVERNOR'S SUPPORT LIKE THIS
TIME THINGS ARE GONNA HAPPEN --
WE WANT TO ENDORSE THE BLUE
RIBBON AND THE LA OWES
RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'D
LIKE TO ASK IS THAT THERE BE A
CLEAR DEFINITION OF THE CBO'S
THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. TO INCLUDE BOTH
THE NON PROFITS AND THE FOR
PROFITS.
AS WE'VE HEARD EARLIER TODAY --
THERE'S MANY HIGH QUALITY
COMMUNITY PROGRAMS WITH TEARS
FOUR AND FIVE WHO ARE PROVIDING
THE EDUCATION NOT JUST CHILDCARE.
OUT WE APPLAUD THE INCLUSION OF
THE MIX DELIVERY.
AND WE WANT TO ASK THAT THE
CBO'S HAVE DIRECT ACCESS TO THE
FUNDS AND BE ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER THEY HAVE.
TO WIN WIN DAHLE KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND THE STAFF SUPPORT
IS.
AND THEN MY LAST COMMENT IS ON
THE WAYS TOTALLY SUPPORT THE
INCREASING REIMBURSEMENT RATE.
BUT WE ASK THAT THE CLAUSE ABOUT
PROGRAMS NOT BEING ABLE TO
CHARGE -- LESS.
BAND THAT RATE TO THE FAMILIES
IS GOING TO HAVE A REAL IMPACT
ON MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES AS THE
PROGRAM'S RATE INCREASES.
THOSE MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES
WON'T BE ABLE TO AFFORD THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON MY NAME'S JAMIE MARK
AND I'M WITH THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION AND I JUST WANT TELL
MY MY COMMENTS WITH CALIFORNIA
FOOD POLICY ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT
OF THE CHILD.
AND NUTRITION PROPOSAL AND
ENSURING AT PRESCHOOL STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO A HEALTHY MEAL.
WE'RE GETTING TOWARDS THE END.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE MY NAME'S COURT ABLE TO
SKI WITH THE YMCA OF SAN DIEGO
COUNTY IN OUR CHILD CARE
RESOURCE SERVICE -- WE STAND
WITH CAP OF THE ARE IN OUR
NETWORK IN ABSOLUTELY THE
COALITION TO INVEST ONE BILLION
IN SUPPORTING OUR SMALLEST
CALIFORNIANS -- TO LOCAL FACTS I
WANTED TO BRING UP IN SUPPORT OF
THESE ISSUES IN SAN DIEGO --
BASED ON A STUDY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO LAST
YEAR NINETY SIX POINT FIVE ARE
ALMOST HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND ZERO TO TWO YEAR OLDS
DO NOT HAVE A LICENSED CHILDCARE
SPOT EITHER IN A FACILITY OR A
FAMILY CHILDCARE CENTER.
WE CONSIDER FAMILY CHILDCARE IN
THE CRITICAL NEED -- TO CONSIDER
THEM IN OUR DIVERSE -- MAKES
SYSTEM -- WE KNOW THAT 62% OF
FAMILIES WHO ARE RECEIVING
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT VOUCHERS ARE
USING THEM IN FAMILY CHILDCARE
SETTINGS -- THEY MEET THE NEEDS
AND WE NEED TO CONSIDER -- THEM
AS WE FURTHER PLANNING THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON A LITTLE
SHORT FOR THE I'M AT THANK YOU
SO MUCH -- I MY NAME IS DONNA
COLIN AND I'M WITH MOMS RAISING --
I'M HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
ECU COALITIONS RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT THEY PUT FORWARD A
PARTICULARLY LOOKING AT ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY FOR CHILDREN
FOR THIS FROM OPPORTUNITY -- WE
ARE ALSO COMMITTED TO CREATING A
MIXED DELIVERY SYSTEM AND
POLISHED POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT
BOTH SUPPORT AND HONOR THE HOME
LANGUAGE AND CULTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S KIDS.
AND THE LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS THAT
MEET PARENTS FOR THEIR WITH
THIRD THEIR DIVERSE CHILD CARE
NEEDS -- AND WE ARE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE CHILD
NUTRITION PIECE IN ENSURING THAT
ALL KIDS IN EARLY LEARNING
SETTINGS HAVE ACCESS TO
NUTRITIONAL FOODS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I CHAIRMAN
MCCARTY -- FIRST OF ALL I CHEN
GONZALEZ FROM THE LATINO POLICY
COALITION WE ARE A COALITION OF
LATINO THINK TANKS IT DOES
POLLING.
ON HOW MANY POLICY ISSUES --
FIRST OF ALL WHERE YOU CAN --
I'M YOUR CONSTITUENT I'M VERY
PROUD THAT YOU ARE -- MY
REPRESENTED BECAUSE FOR THE LAST
TWO YEARS I'VE WITNESS YOU
REALLY.
THIS EXHIBIT AMAZING LEADERSHIP
IN RESTORING.
THE BILLION DOLLARS OF CUTS THAT
WERE DONE FROM THE RECESSION AND
YOUR LEADERSHIP HAS BEEN
EXCEPTIONAL IN NOT SAVING MANY
E. C. PROGRAMS UP AND DOWN THE
STATE I THINK -- YOU KNOW.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE RECOGNIZING YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND NOW YOU'RE TAKING
ON A SITUATION AS YOU MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT WE START THIS
YOU'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT.
RESTORATIONS IN THE MAY REVISED
WE'RE STARTING OUT WITH SOME
REAL GOOD RECOMMENDATIONS NOW
FROM THE LOOP BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION.
AND FROM THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT FACILITIES
FACILITIES -- THERE ARE MENTION
VERY WELL IN THE BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION AND IN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET -- AT THESE GRANTS THAT
WILL MAKE OF SLOTS POSSIBLE PUT
ON ARE REALLY INTERESTED IN IS
THAT THE WORD ACQUISITION IS
MISSING.
IF WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THESE
GRANT IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THE TITLE FIVE OF PEOPLE THAT
GET THESE GRANTS ARE ABLE TO
ACQUIRE REAL ESTATE REAL ESTATE
PRICES ARE GOING UP.
AND IT'S NOW IMPORTANT AT THESE
GRANTS BE EXPEDITED BEFORE OF
THE REAL ESTATE PRICES RISE SO
MUCH THAT YOU THESE GRANTS --
CANNOT BE USED FOR ACQUISITIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIRMAN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN DION ERIN -- ON
BEHALF OF SEIU CALIFORNIA IN
UNITED DOMESTIC WORKERS -- WE
ARE ALIGNED WITH THE ECU
COALITION SET OF RECOMMENDATIONS
AS YOU KNOW BUT I ALSO WANTED TO
CHAT WITH A TALK ABOUT -- MISLI
MOUNDS REMARKS REGARDING
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING THERE IS A
RELATIONSHIP TO THE BUDGET IN
REGARDS TO THE COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING BILL IN THAT -- IF
LIST ARE GOING TO BE PROVIDED
AND WORK IS GOING TO BE DONE BY
BOTH THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
RELATIONS BOARD AS WELL AS THE
DEPARTMENT.
THERE WILL HAVE TO BE A BUDGET
COMPONENT RIGHT IN THIS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR I JUST WANTED TO
BRING THAT TO YOUR ATTENTION
WE'RE NOT SURE ABOUT THE NUMBERS
YET -- ABOUT WHAT THAT COST IS
GOING TO BE BUT WILL BE MEETING
WITH YOUR STAFF AND OTHERS TO BE
ABLE TO FLUSH THAT OUT.
THANK YOU.
THAT GOOD AFTERNOON SHOULD BE A
GAS AND GASKINS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CHILDREN'S DEFENSE ON
CALIFORNIA -- CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA STRONGLY
SUPPORTS INCREASING ACCESS TO
CHILD CARE FOR THE MOST
VULNERABLE INFANTS AND TODDLERS
BASED ON THE PROVEN EARLY HEAD
START MODEL.
CDF BELIEVES THAT WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THE WHOLE CHILD THEIR
FAMILY AND COMMUNITY TO ENSURE
ELEVENTH LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR
ALL OF OUR CHILDREN ESPECIALLY
TO POOR CHILDREN AND CHILDREN OF
COLOR.
AND HIGH QUALITY CHILDCARE WITH
COMPREHENSIVE FAMILY AND HEALTH
SUPPORTS ARE PREVENTATIVE AT
PREVENTATIVE INVESTMENT TO SET
CHILDREN ON A PATH TO SUCCESS IN
SCHOOL AND IN LIFE.
AND ALSO SUPPORT FAMILIES WHO WE
KNOW ARE STRUGGLING AND NEED TO
HAVE THEIR NEEDS MET THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN JESSICA
GOT I WITH THE CHILD CARE
ALLIANCE OF LOS ANGELES.
WE ARE A PARTNERSHIP OF THE TEN
EARLY LEARNING CARE AGENCIES IN
ACROSS LA COUNTY.
N. ARE ALSO A MEMBER OF THE EASY
BUDGET COALITIONS OR A LOT OF
OUR COMMENTS ARE IN LINE WITH A
LOT OF THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE WITH.
OUR BUT JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT
IN LA COUNTY WE HAVE A WAITING
LIST OF ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND
WILL MORE THAN FORTY THOUSAND
CHILDREN OTHER ELIGIBLE CHILDREN.
A **** JUST WAITING FOR CARE AND
ABOUT 20% OF THEM ARE AGES.
ZERO TO THREE SO WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT CHILD CARE AND EARLY
LEARNING WE CAN'T THINK OF THEM
AS SYSTEMS THAT EXIST IN SILOS --
AS THE SERVICE CRITICAL ANTI
POVERTY PROGRAMS AND WE REALLY
CAN'T CONTINUE EXPECTING OUR
FAMILIES TO WAIT -- FOR CARE --
THAT THE NEED IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO MEET THE
NEEDS OF THEIR CHILDREN AS WELL
AS A WORK FORCE.
THAT CONTINUES TO RECEIVE
POVERTY WAGES AND JUST CONTINUES
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY -- WHICH
REALLY IMPACTS THE INSURGENT
NARRATION OF POVERTY THAT OUR
FAMILIES ARE HAVING TO FACE
EVERY DAY OF THE WEEK.
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU THANK YOU OFFER
THAT TESTIMONY TODAY AND WITH
THAT -- WE WILL ADJOURN